So, auf geht's. Moin Leute, so. Was? Eine Frage, will eventuell wegen Microsoft Druck nun doch zu Windows 11 wechseln? Lohnt sich das oder noch bis 2025 warten?
Ähm, du meinst 2025, weil dann Windows 10 Support ausläuft oder was? Naja, das musst du wissen, was du von Windows 11 haben willst. Also, ich bin auf Windows 11 umgestiegen, nicht weil ich so großartigen Bock habe auf Windows 11, sondern weil meine CPU nur ordentlich von Windows 11 unterstützt wird.
Wenn du nichts in der Richtung hast, kannst du dir durchaus noch Zeit lassen auf der anderen Seite. Es schadet sicherlich auch nichts, ein bisschen vor Support.
Also, wenn du jetzt easy wechseln könntest, spricht ja eigentlich auch nichts dagegen. Ich würde, also ganz ehrlich, zwei Jahre bis zum Support-Ende, das hat keinen Sinn, da zu jetzt irgendwie bis einen Monat vorher zu warten und dann quasi umzustellen, festzustellen, manche Sachen gehen nicht und, also, schon nicht verkehrt, das jetzt zu machen.
Jasper, danke schön. Massive Subscription. Magst du das trinken? Ja, habe ich gerade schon.
Also, ich denke, das kann man jetzt schon machen.
Ich vermute,
dass eh schon
relativ viele
also, entweder
umgestiegen sind oder sich jetzt
auch gerade Gedanken machen. Ich glaube,
insgesamt sind bestimmt noch mehr Leute auf Windows 10
als Windows 11. War ich mir da nicht sicher.
Ich habe schon lange keine Statistik gesehen.
Aber das wird
die nächsten Jahre über schon
zunehmen. Ich meine, man muss ehrlich mal sagen,
Windows 11 hätte es nicht gebraucht.
Also, was
die bei Windows 11 gemacht haben, ist, hätten die auch
alles ohne Probleme machen können.
Also, Windows 11 oder Windows 10.
Aber man wollte wahrscheinlich mal wieder neues Windows verkauft.
Das dürfte der einzige Grund sein. Ich meine, ich habe es lustigerweise ja schon gesagt,
dass sie 2022 oder irgendwie, wann das wann, irgendwie das das 30 oder 50 jährige, nee,
wann gab es das erste Windows, das 30 jährige Windows Jubiläum irgendwie. Aber ich habe
selbst ja nicht daran geglaubt, dass das, dass das wirklich, dass das wirklich passiert.
Aber anscheinend hat sich Microsoft gedacht, ja, muss jetzt mal wieder sein.
Und Microsoft redet sich ja auch raus mit.
Sie hätten nie gesagt, dass es das letzte Windows ist, was es geben soll.
Und wenn man es mal genau nachguckt, hat das Microsoft auch nie selbst gesagt,
sondern halt kann man sowieso absichtlich so stehen lassen.
Aber unterm Strich ist es eh egal, was sie sagen.
Die könnten auch offiziell sagen, Windows 11 ist das letzte Windows, was es hier geben wird.
Und dann einfach drei Jahre später sagen, nein, doch nicht. Und weiter.
Also ich meine, was soll passieren?
Da können die Leute sagen, ja, Microsoft, ihr habt aber gesagt, es ist das letzte.
Sagt Microsoft ja und jetzt halt nicht mehr.
Ich fand diese Windows nennen wir es mal Windows as a Service Idee somit von wegen, wir bringen
ein Windows raus und updaten es dann die ganze Zeit eigentlich die beste Sache, die sie hätten
machen können weiter.
So dieses, ja, wir machen das, aber auch noch ein Upgrade von Windows 10 auf 11.
Und das fand ich echt bescheuert, weil eines der Vorteile war halt, dass du nie richtig upgraden musstest.
Er hat zwar unter der Haube oftmals so halbe Neuinstallationen gemacht, aber auch das haben sie recht gut in den Griff gekriegt unter Windows 10.
Und die Leute mögen es einfach, wenn sich nicht so viel auf einmal ändert.
Und vor allem, wisst ihr, was die Leute auch mögen, gerade Windows-User, wenn der alte Krempel weiterhin funktioniert und man nicht bei jeder Windows-Version irgendwas downgradet aus unerfindlichen Gründen.
Ja, wie zum Beispiel die Taskleiste in Windows 11. Ich meine, die Windows 10 Taskbar ist schon deutlich beschissener als die aus den letzten paar Versionen.
Und Windows 11 ist halt für den Arsch.
Ja, ob das Geld geht, geht es glaube ich gar nicht so sehr. Ich glaube, das Geld ist den meisten Leuten anstrengend.
Eigentlich ziemlich wurscht, was das angeht.
Ich glaube, für die meisten Leute ist eher entscheidender, wie das halt aussieht mit Arbeit, die man damit hat und Zeit, mit der man sich auseinandersetzen muss und Sachen, die sie geändert haben.
Ich glaube, es ist deutlich sinniger, wenn das schrittweise geht, weil dann gewöhnt man sich einfacher dran.
Und die 0815-User, die mögen es eh nicht, wenn sich was ändert.
Ich muss auch sagen, ich habe den Eindruck, dass bei vielen Anwendungen nur Sachen geändert werden, um sie technisch...
Tablet-artiger zu machen oder Smartphone-artiger zu machen.
Wenn man sich mal Desktop-Anwendungen, Desktop-Anwendungen wohlgemerkt, ja, anguckt heute und, keine Ahnung, 2013 rum, da sieht man schon einen riesen Unterschied.
Ja, die mögen vielleicht ein bisschen schicker sein.
Ja, also diese Oldschool-Windows-Anwendungen waren sicherlich jetzt nicht die reine Augenweide.
Aber oftmals war das relativ gut funktional gemacht und die hatten auch recht viele Optionen.
Ja, so Thunderbird ist zum Beispiel so ein Ding.
Ja, Thunderbird wird oft ein bisschen gehatet, also das ist so nachdem man so richtig außer Zeit gefallen und sonst was in der Richtung.
Aber ich muss halt sagen, sie haben es auch hier schon versucht, ein bisschen zu ver-Tabletisieren, ja.
Und ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, ich mochte das mit den Menüs und dem ganzen Zeug irgendwie lieber als mit den ganzen Buttons.
Aber okay, aber Thunderbird ist halt noch eine Anwendung, der erkennst du an, dass er eben eine Desktop-Anwendung ist, ja.
Ja.
Mit Schaltflächenmöglichkeiten, was du machen kannst.
Aber viele Anwendungen entwickeln sich halt auf dem Desktop Richtung Tablet und das finde ich schon seit Jahren ziemlich beknackt.
Hast du eigentlich AWS-Zertifizierung?
Nee, habe ich nicht.
Warum mit AWS?
Also AWS ist mit Abstand die Cloud, wo ich am wenigsten bisher gemacht habe.
Obwohl, glaube ich, AWS mit die Ersten waren in vielen Bereichen, gell.
Kann das sein?
Ich bilde mir das ein, dass das ungefähr so in der Reihenfolge war.
AWS.
Beziehungsweise Amazon hat diesen ganzen Cloud halt mit losgetreten.
Auch oftmals noch, das war auch noch zu Zeiten, da war Kubernetes und sowas noch gar nicht richtig etabliert.
Und danach kam Google und ich glaube, mehr oder weniger zeitgleich, wenn nicht ein bisschen später, Azure.
Also ich glaube, es war die Reihenfolge AWS, Google, Azure.
Natürlich nicht insgesamt, sondern bei verschiedenen Technologien waren die einen ein bisschen schneller als die anderen.
Was Kubernetes-Sachen angeht, war Google lange Zeit.
Ganz gut dabei.
Und sind sie immer noch.
Naja, gut.
Letztendlich ist es auch wurscht, wer da zuerst da gewesen ist.
Zumindest habe ich mit AWS noch am wenigsten gemacht bisher.
Ja, das ist halt Kacke.
Dass die Dinger responsive sind, da soll man ja recht sein.
Gerade bei Web-Anwendungen ist ja okay.
Aber bei Anwendungen, die explizit halt für Desktop gemacht werden.
Vergleicht mal zum Beispiel, falls dieses Ding noch einer kennt, diesen Musik-Player hier mit...
Mit, ähm...
Das ist halt so eine typische Windows-Anwendung von der Optik her aus, keine Ahnung, 2000 bis 2015, so rum, vielleicht.
Und vergleicht das mal mit aktuellen Musik-Playern.
Ja, genau.
Aktuelle Musik-Player sehen dann eher so aus und hier konntest du halt noch was machen.
Es fuckt mich jedes Mal richtig ab, wenn ich in irgendwelchen Musik-Streaming-Diensten bin und du hast so unsinnige Beschränkungen, wie...
Du kannst die Lautstärke nur in festgelegten Schritten verändern oder sowas, ja.
Oder das Playlist-Handling ist halt Smartphone- und nicht Maus-kompatibel und solche Dinger.
Das nervt mich dann immer, wenn ich mir denke, Alter, das ging doch früher auch wunderbar zu bedienen.
Warum muss man das so beschissen machen mittlerweile auf dem Desktop?
Ja.
Winamp war eh so eine Sache für sich.
Winamp gibt es ja mittlerweile sogar...
Ist ja sogar mittlerweile...
Gibt es ja sogar mittlerweile im Browser.
Und um nicht zu vergessen...
Das Standard-Winamp-Ding, was immer drinnen war.
Okay.
Das war der Standard-Sound, der immer, wenn du Winamp installiert hast und gestartet hast, standardmäßig dabei war.
iTunes, nee, iTunes mag ich nicht.
Aber Winamp war schon extrem pock.
Also ich würde wahrscheinlich Winamp auch heute noch verwenden.
Gibt es Leute von euch, die Winamp verwenden immer noch?
2023?
Gibt es das?
Gibt es das eigentlich überhaupt noch?
Öh.
Alter, das ist ja die Schlimmste...
Okay, das dürfte, glaube ich, das Negativbeispiel schlechthin sein für Vertabletisierung einer Anwendung schlechthin, wenn ich mir das so angucke.
Das sieht aus wie jeder 0815 Streaming-Audio plus als Desktop-Player.
Ah, fuck.
Deck.
Naja.
Warum ist die Playlist jetzt auf einmal so laut?
Ich habe tatsächlich noch ein paar MP3-Sachen.
Die habe ich aber schon jahrelang bei mir auf dem Nass liegen.
Das sind auch Dinger, die, ähm...
...findet man selten bei Streaming-Services.
Zum Beispiel, was ich immer noch ab und zu ganz gerne höre, ist...
...ein, eine Live-DVD von Blind Guardian.
Hier, warte mal.
Blind...
Hier.
Und...
Das gab es als DVD oder eben halt auch als, ja, MP3s.
Und kaum ein Streaming-Service hat das.
Ja, das sind solche Sachen.
Da habe ich noch, da habe ich noch, noch MP3s.
Also, ich meine Sachen, die es halt nicht auf dem Streaming-Service gibt.
Was, was, was willst du groß machen, ja?
Was ist EIMP?
Ist das, ist das irgendeine so WinAMP?
Okay, das ist, das ist was, was ein bisschen aussehen möchte wie WinAMP, oder?
Warum ist die, warum ist...
Die, okay.
.ru
Hat es auch mail.ru-Anti-Cheat drin, ne?
Oder, nee, mail.ru-Anti-Cheat gibt es ja gar nicht mehr.
Es heißt jetzt ja irgendwie anders.
Okay, YouTube, du hast jetzt mal eine Chance, uns was zu empfehlen.
Nope.
Okay, dann gucken wir jetzt mal eine Sache, die wir uns immer angucken, jeden Dienstag.
Äh, Dienstag? Wie komme ich auf Dienstag?
Ey, die wir uns immer angucken, jeden Sonntag.
Und zwar, was gibt es an GitHub-Trends?
Und warum ist es diese Woche wieder nur AI?
Oder ich könnte wetten, dass es nur AI ist.
AI! Geh los, Q-Code, moin.
AI?
Äh, nee.
Ein Switch-Emulator? Okay, pock, nice.
If...
Äh, was?
Was?
Ah, okay.
AI.
AI, AI, äh, äh, äh.
Was? Was ist das?
KAL.com.
Hab ich noch nie gehört.
Es ist ein Kalender.
Hä? Okay.
AI, AI, AI, AI, AI, AI, AI, AI, äh, AI.
AI.
Nicht sonderlich spannend, ehrlich gesagt.
Oh, was es jetzt die Sharp gibt, die Woche.
Natürlich den Switch-Emulator.
Azure Coast CLI.
Das ist tatsächlich nicht verkehrt, weil niemand blickt durch, was eine Cloud-Infrastruktur kosten wird.
Es gibt, äh, glücklicherweise...
... mittlerweile so ein paar Tools, gerade fürs Kubernetes-Umfeld, die können, die können dir beispielsweise auch Empfehlungen geben, wie du dein Cluster aufbauen solltest, dass es ein bisschen billiger wird.
Aber Cloud-Infrastruktur-Preis-Prognose ist immer, ist echte Wissenschaft für sich.
Ja, für alle, die ihre App gerne, ihre To-Do-App gerne over-engineeren, können sich Clean Architecture angucken.
Es gibt ein kostenloses Game in C-Shopper, wahrscheinlich Unity, oder?
Nee, das ist nicht mal Unity.
Was ist das?
Okay, Game ohne Screenshot, das ist schon immer ein bisschen, ein bisschen cringe.
Okay, animierter, animierter Desktop-Hintergrund, wenn man es braucht.
Ist halt auch so ein Ding, sowas wird es halt für Linux universell nie geben, weil da ja auch wieder jeder Desktop seine eigenen Dinger macht.
Ja, und zwischen X und Wayland schon mal ganz zu schweigen.
Warum gibt es zweimal Clean Architecture, was ist mit euch los?
Windows Optimizer, oje, da bin ich immer...
Und was optimist der?
Ah, der kann...
So Sachen wie, äh, wir schicken Mist heim.
Okay, das macht tatsächlich, das macht tatsächlich irgendwie noch halbwegs Sinn.
Anesthetische Windows-Services, Telemetrie, Cortana-Müll kommt weg, Office-Telemetrie, okay, Automatic-Updates würde ich nicht unbedingt ausschalten.
Uninstall komische UWP-Apps, die keiner braucht.
Ja, gut.
Ich bin immer noch, äh, ja, so ein bisschen am Zweifeln, ob man so Sachen wirklich braucht.
Aber okay.
Scheinen ja viele der Meinung zu sein, dass das nützlich ist.
Zwei verschiedene Autoren, aber das muss was miteinander zu tun haben.
Du hast doch nicht unabhängig voneinander zwei Repos, die irgendwie über 12.000 Sterne haben.
Das ist doch...
Stimmt.
Da habe ich ja gar nicht dran gedacht.
Ja, das wird schon daran liegen, dass das, ähm, Tears of the Kingdom bald rauskommt, dass der Switch-Emulator trendet, oder?
Da habe ich ja so, den Zusammenhang habe ich ja so gar nicht hergestellt.
Ja, du hast schon recht.
Kommt nicht von ungefähr, dass ein Switch-Emulator gerade trendet.
Ist das nicht Release nächste Woche?
Hast du jetzt dein Linux-Desktop eigentlich auf der Arbeit?
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein.
Ich muss mich weiter mit Windows rumkämpfen.
Aber ich habe eine Cloud-VM.
Ich habe eine Cloud-VM, auf der ich root bin, alles mögliche machen kann.
Wurde aber schon geleakt.
Ja, gut.
Ich meine, das wundert mich nicht.
Die physischen Datenträger, Nintendo hat ja sowas noch.
Ja, also, die haben ja so diese, diese Cartridges.
Dass die schon da sind und in Geschäften sind, das wundert mich nicht.
Und dass das dann irgendjemand dumpt, das wundert mich auch nicht.
Ja, die Emulatoren sind gar nicht übel.
Ich habe ja auch ein bisschen ausprobiert bei mir auf dieser Emulator-Kiste.
Und da habe ich Link's Awakening ein bisschen gespielt, also das Switch-Remake.
Mit, ich glaube, sogar höherer Auflösung als die Switch selber.
Und als der ausgibt.
Das Game sah richtig geil aus.
Also, auch von Kantenklettung her und alles.
Und es lief butterweich.
Also, es gab allerdings ein paar Grafik-Klitsches, ja.
Das habe ich euch, glaube ich, sogar damals im Video erzählt.
Aber ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass das sogar besser ist mittlerweile.
Es gab zum Beispiel den Grafik-Klitsch, dass der Kettenhund am Anfang einfach nicht da war und sowas.
Wobei das halt echt sehr subtiler Grafik-Klitsch war, weil der war nicht irgendwie verbuggt.
Dass er irgendwie pixel hätte oder sowas.
Aber gar nichts.
Das war ein sehr subtiler Grafik-Klitsch.
nicht da. Das ist natürlich dann schon ein bisschen
verdächtig.
Und dann weiß man nicht, ob man das Spiel gut durchspielen kann.
Aber gut, es sieht wirklich
nice aus und es läuft auch gut auf der Kiste.
Naja.
Wahrscheinlich ist es eine typische Emulator-Geschichte,
dass sie da irgendwelche Sachen benutzt haben,
die halt so ein bisschen
zweckentfremdet wurden, um den Catnode zu machen.
Deswegen ist der Emulator nicht richtig kann.
Deshalb wirst du lieben,
ein Software-Entwickler zu sein.
Wie auf einmal? Letztes Mal hat er uns doch noch erzählt, dass es Mist ist.
Na gut.
Gibt ja immer zwei Seiten von einer Medaille.
Übrigens, Leute, wir müssen ja
heute das Video angucken.
Es wurde ja reactet auf
meinen
Linux-Guides?
Wie hieß das so, ne?
Genau. Er hat ja hier reactet
auf mein Video. Das müssen wir uns
heute noch angucken. Ich hab gestern schon einen Kommentar
drunter geschrieben. Da hab ich geschrieben,
ich bin gespannt, was er sagt.
Ich hab's mir noch nicht angeguckt.
Was der Beste
war.
Hahaha.
Leute sind auch schon am Start.
Das müssen wir uns nachher angucken. Das will ich mir nicht als
erstes geben. Aber das müssen wir uns nachher
angucken. Zumal, hey, der Typ reactet
46 Minuten auf mein Video.
Wenn ich dazu was sage, sind es mindestens
46 Minuten. Bin mal gespannt.
Ich bin wirklich, wirklich gespannt. Also es ist
tatsächlich genau das, was ich hier geschrieben hab.
Bin echt gespannt, was er dazu sagt. Und ich bin
gespannt.
Ich kenn den Channel nicht.
Also ich bin gespannt, ob er die
Sachen absichtlich falsch versteht,
um da irgendwas
vom Zaun zu brechen, was ich so nicht sagen
wollte. Oder ob er tatsächlich drauf
eingeht. Das bist
du? Darkseid?
Ja, dann.
Dann gucken wir uns gleich an, das Video.
Oh, bestimmt ein Streaming-Comic.
Ja, schön, dass du deinen Weg hergefunden hast.
Ey, so lange wird das, so lange wird
das Ganze nicht gehen. Wir gucken uns jetzt aber erstmal irgendwas
anderes an. Und zwar, genau, ich mein,
hey, YouTube, YouTube
Content 2023.
Da wird reactet,
counter-reacted, reactet auf die
Reaction. Dann wird irgendwann noch
ein Video gemacht,
die, wie nennen sie das immer,
die Ansage oder irgendwie sowas.
Und dann
muss ich irgendeiner entschuldigen und rumheulen
im Video. Dann wird dann wieder auf das
Entschuldigungsvideo
reactet.
Dieses Ganze,
das ist so komplett so
selbst erhaltendes
System.
Reaction-Zeug auf YouTube.
Und ich glaube, du könntest da auch
theoretisch, also wenn
du willst, könntest du wahrscheinlich
den ganzen
Tag aufeinander reacten.
Ich meine, was heißt, wenn du willst? Das machen die ja auch.
Ja,
genau so könnte man das sagen. Das machen
die ja auch. Aber vorher
gucken wir uns das hier an.
Getting over it. Biggest barrier
was finally broken.
Getting over it. Speedruns
sind absolut abgedrehter Shit.
Also, die sind wirklich
richtig krass drauf. Falls das Game überhaupt noch
jemand kennt. Na gut, na klar kennt ihr
das noch. Aber das ist halt in der Versenkung
verschwunden wieder. Das war so ein kleines
Indie-Hype-Game irgendwie vor
frag mich nicht, fünf Jahren oder so.
Und jeder
hat es gespielt und jeder hat sich dabei aufgeregt.
Okay, jeder ist zu viel gesagt. Ich habe es nicht
gespielt.
Aber, ups, da wollte ich jetzt eigentlich
gar nicht hin.
Und die Speedruns waren damals schon
extrem krass. Jump King, ja,
Jump King war auch sowas.
Wobei ich nicht weiß, ob es Jump
King Speedrun, aber wahrscheinlich gibt es auch
Moment, Speedrun
bestimmt, bestimmt.
Vier Minuten.
Ja, war ja klar.
Das war ja so klar.
Okay, dann gucken wir uns das doch jetzt mal an, würde ich sagen.
Einmal kurz Musikpause.
Gucken wir uns das doch jetzt mal an.
Getting over it.
Was macht Battlefield 2042
eigentlich so? Das ist eine
gute Frage. Gibt es schon
eine Season 5 Release Date?
Will not feature new Specialists.
Ach, dass Rework of Hourglass
kommt und eine neue Map.
Da lag ich insofern schon mal falsch,
als ich gesagt habe, die machen nur das absolut
Mindeste. Wobei ich
irgendwo auch immer noch richtig liege, weil
man kann sich drüber streiten, ob
das Game nun das Mindeste denn
überhaupt schon hat.
So, okay, gucken wir uns das mal an.
Hello, you absolute legend.
Der redet immer so ein bisschen eingeschlafen, der Kerl.
If you were alive in the year
2017, and according
to my viewer demographics, everyone
who's currently watching this video was,
you would have seen a phenomenon
sweep through YouTube, the likes
of which the gaming world had never
seen. The most unlikely
Okay, das ist vielleicht ein bisschen übertrieben, aber ja,
das war schon ein riesen Hype, das Ding.
A game that by any common sense metric
should not be popular,
somehow took the internet by storm.
Getting over it with Bennett Foddy
isn't your typical game.
The goal is simply enough to understand,
just climb the mountain and launch
yourself into space, but the controls
are so unintuitive and unique
that within mere minutes...
Das war der Traum eines jeden Let's Players,
weil da konnte man auch so richtig schön
übertrieben drauf abgehen, was
aus irgendwelchen Gründen sehr viele Let's
Play Zuschauer
mögen, vor allem im englischsprachigen
Bereich, habe ich da den Eindruck.
Die mögen kein, wir gucken uns das Game
zusammen an und ich mache das möglichst unterhaltsam,
nein, für die ist unterhaltsam,
ich schreie rum und flippe aus dabei.
Also das ist so Content, das kann ich mir nicht angucken.
Aber ja, das war ein riesen,
ein riesen Hype, das ist auf jeden Fall klar.
Minutes, a pure sense of frustration
begins to eat away at one's sanity.
However, sometimes it's a game
like getting over it that can spread
like wildfire, exactly
because it's so difficult
and frustrating.
And in this case, that's what happened.
In late 2017,
every big name on YouTube
was playing Getting Over It.
Rage Compilation sprung
up in droves, highlighting
how unforgiving the game is.
It was everywhere.
Das ist auch so einer, der schreit immer gerne in seinen Let's Plays
wie verrückt rum. Kann ich mir alles nicht geben.
If you were a variety streamer in that
era, chances are you played
Getting Over It. Maybe
you didn't beat it, but you almost
certainly joined in on the meme.
And alongside the explosion
of popularity from variety streamers
came the speedrunner.
And it's obvious why.
A game this difficult is prime
territory to show off just how much
of a true gamer you really are.
Thus, Getting Over It
speedruns became and still are
also ich kenne nur Speedruns von dem Game,
das ist auch schon ein paar Jahre her und die waren damals
auch schon ultra krass im Vergleich
zu dem, was so die nur nach 15 Casual
Noobs in dem Game gespielt haben.
of the most popular speedruns ever
viewed. For example, take a channel
like IGN, a channel
with 17.4 million subscribers.
IGN covers
everything. Trailers,
reviews, news
and bizarrely, its sixth most
popular viewed video ever
is a random speedrun of
Getting Over It with 35 million
views. And while
Getting Over It may have long left
the gaming zeitgeist, speedrunners
never really got over it.
They continued advancing
their skills and pushing the game.
And for the past several years,
a single barrier has been
staring them in the face,
teasing, taunting,
begging them to overcome it.
Da denkst du doch nicht wirklich, dass das gerade jemand
spielt, oder? Da denkst du, dass es irgendwelche
gescripteten Movement-Sachen sind.
Ja, das sieht aus, als hätte
irgendeine AI gelernt, das zu spielen,
so nach dem Motto.
Ja, richtig krass.
In April of 2023
the player Blastbolt
made history, when he became
the first person to beat
Getting Over It in just 59
seconds. This run
is one of the most beautiful speedruns
in history.
Oh, oh, Leute. Blackfacing.
And especially more so, if you've ever actually
tried to play the game.
But in any case, it's a monumental
achievement. In this
video, we are going to take a quick
look at Getting Over It speedruns.
What makes them so difficult to
perfect, and why this...
The fuck?
Ich hab ja nach wie vor vergessen, der 0815 Casual
Spieler, der muss das...
Okay, das ist ein schlechter
Vergleich. Okay, das ist ein ganz schlechter, weil
die Leute dort haben ja irgendwie, was weiß
ich, 5000 Spielstunden oder so in dem Game.
Kann man nicht vergleichen, aber es ist schon
heftig, wenn man sich das anguckt. Es ist in
vielen Games so, wenn man sich mal irgendwelche Speedruns
anguckt versus wie das normaler Spiel.
Klar, aber ich glaube...
Also...
Neben so Sachen wie
Mario 64 zum Beispiel.
Jeder, der das erste Mal Mario 64
Speedrun geguckt hat, hat auch gedacht, fuck, Alter, was ist
das denn? Versus das,
wie ich da rumgesprungen bin.
Und so ähnlich
ist das hier auch. Also...
Wenn du das vergleichst mit wie normal gespielt
wird, ist das ja absoluter Wahnsinn.
Und dann kommt das erste Mal, das
...
Es ist auch heftig, wie gut dieser Typ besser geworden ist.
Man hat am Anfang gesehen einen Run von dem gleichen Spieler
und jetzt den hier mit dem Movement nochmal.
Also der hat sich einfach innerhalb von zwei, drei Monaten
von ich spiele das ziemlich gut zu, ich spiele das nahezu perfekt verbessert.
Doch, ich hab schon was gegessen.
Aber nichts Großartiges, Toastbrot.
Und das ist wirklich, wo diese bestimmte Geschichte beginnt.
Weil, obwohl das nur ein paar Monate nach dem Release war,
gerade diese Eisstelle ist übelster Abfuck.
Ich meine, das wollte ich gerade sagen, das verwundert ja nicht wirklich.
Bei einem Spiel, was quasi schon nach den ersten paar Monaten
auf unter drei Minuten runter war, dass die für jede weitere Minute
ja, immer mehr Zeit brauchen.
Und selbstverständlich, wenn man es unter einer Minute schafft,
dann gibt es keine weitere Minute-Barrier.
Ja, mehr, weil das ist ja schon eine Unterminute.
Das ist ja nicht verwunderlich.
Verwunderlich eher, dass es überhaupt möglich ist.
Den Dude kenne ich, ja.
Von dem habe ich auch schon ein paar Videos geguckt.
Der speedrunnt alle möglichen Games.
Der hat letztens auch irgendeinen Resident Evil 4 Remake speedrun hochgeladen und sowas.
Hat vielleicht auch schon eine andere.
Der hat alle möglichen Games.
Der speedrunnt.
Der ist einer der größten Speedrunner aller Zeiten.
Aber in einer anderen Weise, als ich es meistens beobachte.
Normalerweise spreche ich über Spieler, die so gut an einem bestimmten Spiel sind
und das Spiel so lange dominieren, dass es sie groß macht.
Jedoch ist Distortion 2 ein bisschen anders.
Wenn ein neues, populäres Spiel herauskommt
und du nicht auf Distortion 2 bettest, um einen neuen Weltrekord zu erreichen,
verstehst du einfach nicht die Geschichte des Speedrunners.
Und seine Erfolge sind nicht so groß.
Er hat die Weltrekorde in den größten Shooters,
den größten Rollen- und Action-Spieler-Games,
den größten Horror-Spieler-Games
und auch random Indie-Spieler-Games erzielt.
Imagine das Spiel in minus einer Minute durchspielen.
Das heißt, du bist quasi schon fertig, bevor du angefangen hast.
Du bist noch im zweiten Versuch vorher und dann bist du schon fertig.
Ja.
Das ist eine gute Idee. So sollten wir das machen.
Das geht aber nur mit Google Stadia, weil nur da hast du Negativ-Latency.
Was macht Google... Sekunde, Leute, was macht das eigentlich?
Nicht Googler, Google Stadia.
Da fällt mir nichts anderes ein zu mehr.
Ich hab auch, ich hab von Anfang an nicht daran geglaubt.
Und ich hab's auch in den Videos gesagt.
Und wie alle auf diesen Hype-Train aufgesprungen sind.
Oh, die Leute werden keine eigenen Rechner mehr daheim haben.
Keine eigene Konsolen. Die werden alles nur noch über die Cloud spielen.
Ja, ja, ja, ja.
Zum Glück ist der Mist weg. Ich fand's von Anfang an ziemlich... ziemlich crap.
Dazu kann man nur sagen...
Fick dich weg, du Robo-Fürst.
Ja, da bin ich froh, dass der Kram weg ist.
Ich fand's von... ich fand's schon immer kacke.
At the time, you can still sense the struggle.
The difficulty in the movement is so...
Was aber übrigens nicht heißen wird, dass nicht wieder sowas in der Richtung kommt.
Alle paar Jahre kommt dann einer so um die Ecke.
Was ist dann eigentlich aus diesem komischen Logitech-Streaming-Ding geworden?
Wo man auch von Anfang an sich überlegen konnte,
sich überlegen konnte, der Müll
wird doch komplett
nach hinten losgehen, wird doch nix.
Irgendwelche komischen
Let's Play Leute haben das mega gefeiert,
warum auch immer, vielleicht weil es bezahlt wurden
und nie wieder was von gehört.
Ja, dieses Ding hier.
Interessiert, interessiert keinen, oder?
Ich würde sagen, das liegt daran, weil das Movement
auch difficult ist.
Ja.
Aber die sind besser geworden.
Ja, das ist abfuck,
der Abschnitt hier.
Also ich muss ehrlich sagen, ich hab das Spiel
selbst nie durchgespielt, das war mir viel zu nervig.
Even in World Records.
And when we compare older runs
to current runs, we can see how much
of a difference better control makes.
After Distortion's
Sub 2, Luminant came back
rather quickly with his own
144. 12 seconds
ahead of Distortion, which is a
massive difference. And yet,
still in this difficult section
of terrain, you can see just how much
trouble he still had trying to scale
it quickly. If you look at a relatively
recent run from the current
champion, Blastbolt, it's a
night and day difference.
It's much smoother and much quicker.
But this isn't necessarily
a difference of strategy.
This is a difference of skill
and technique. Something that
only comes after thousands
of hours. Over the years,
players simply got faster,
made less mistakes,
became more accurate, and because
of this, were able to maintain much
more momentum throughout the run.
Having better control,
did allow one shift in the game's
meta. One tweak that I would
consider an actual change in strategy
that had a huge impact on the game.
Around the years
2019 to 2020,
some players had invested
so much time in the game,
by this point probably even thousands
of hours, that their control
started to get incredibly precise.
Up until this point,
just navigating up the terrain
without any major mistakes
would be considered a success.
And the primary goal.
But once you get enough control,
you can start to plan the smaller
details. Before this point,
there really wasn't any use
planning smaller details,
because players just weren't good enough to
consistently do them anyway.
But now, players were taking a
much closer look at the specific
techniques they were using,
and trying to find more optimal ways
of movement. And it's around this
time, there was a change away from
the normal way of moving.
Aber,
wie viele Stunden
muss man in dem Game haben,
um da so krass drin zu sein?
Das ist doch,
das ist sicherlich schon vierstellig, oder?
Also,
das musst du wahrscheinlich 4000 Stunden
gespielt haben, und dir wirklich Mühe
geben, dass du das jemals hinkriegst.
Ich könnte mir das auch gar nicht
vorstellen, das 4000 Stunden zu spielen.
Ich kann es auch nicht.
Und dieses einzige Veränderung
ist vielleicht das am meisten
beeindruckende Erwachsenen
in der Geschichte des Spiels.
So, was genau ist spinnen
und was ist tappen?
Um die Unterschiede zu beurteilen,
können wir wieder einmal einen früheren Run
mit einem späteren Run vergleichen.
Und einer der besten Orte, um
dieses zu demonstrieren, ist der
Anfang des Runs.
In 2018,
ein besonders populärer Runner
war Loch Ness, der
einen 1,24m in August
erhielt,
of 2018 using slow motion we can see that at the beginning of the run he has a very particular
technique which involves large arching motions of the hammer this is where he fully extends his arms
and does a sweeping motion every time he jumps you can see him extend the hammer and do a giant swing
this sweeping action is called spinning now let's look at a much more recent run by blast bolt
achieved late last year in his initial movement there is no sweeping outwards at all instead
keeps the head of the hammer close to his body and performs either a pushing or tapping motion
der verbrennt wahrscheinlich pro run eine halbe pizza an kalorien
also der Spieler
oder hat eine Maussenz von 3000
obvious at a section later on at the top of the church
here
the rock next to it and still he does a large outward swinging motion after pushing off the top
of the church and then again after pushing off the rock this causes him to lob himself into
the air in a slow arc but blast bolt uses tapping and again he keeps the head of the hammer close
to his cauldron and simply performs two quick taps which ultimately ends up being much faster
this new tapping technique is much more optimal
and because the hammer movement is so much quicker it allows you to push off more times from the terrain keeping your momentum
and you have much more options which direction you want to push or pull
which again allows you to create forces that already align with your current movement angle
so the question arises if tapping is so much faster than the large spins players used to do why did players do them in first place?
wahrscheinlich weil es schwierig ist
The answer is that tapping is extremely hard to do and requires extreme precision.
It's almost impossible to explain why it's difficult,
because the controls in getting over it are so unique that words can't really even do them justice.
But ultimately, every single variable plays a part.
How the character holds the hammer, whether he is holding it close or far away,
how fast he is moving, how fast he moves the hammer,
his angle of momentum, all affects how the hammer interacts with the environment.
And it takes so many thousands of hours of practice to do tapping that it just didn't exist previously because players couldn't do it.
Spinning on the other hand, or the act of extending your arms fully outwards,
essentially resets every single hammer.
This makes it easier, which is why earlier players defaulted to using this technique.
But over the years, certain players did lead the way in spinning less and tapping more.
Players like Mojito,
Stillo,
Crumpet,
and Barack Obispo.
Business all helped in pushing the technique forward.
Spinning is still used when possible, for example when there is a large jump and plenty of time anyway,
but the best players use tapping as much as possible, and generally the faster the run, the more tapping is involved.
Nothing better illustrates this than the current TAS, which just shows that spinning is almost not used at all.
It's almost entirely done using tapping.
Guck mal, die Kamera kommt nicht mal hinterher.
...tapping.
And really, this is the story of getting over it.
There were no game-breaking route changes,
no unbelievable discoveries that changed everything.
It's been a slow, steady progression of skill by the top players.
And nothing better illustrates this than the graph of the world record progression.
At the end of 2018, the progression flatlined,
and it's been nothing but power of will,
patience,
determination,
and mountains upon mountains of practice,
no pun intended,
that has caused this world record to go lower.
Yes, players still study-
...
Das ist halt...
Das ist bei jedem Game, was gespeedrunned wird.
Das wird halt...
gescienced ohne Ende.
...
...the finer details,
trying to figure out different ways to squeeze water from a stone.
But all of that,
ends up being meaningless without the skill to actually do it.
And getting over it is in the uppermost echelon of games,
where skill is king.
And humans are still far from attaining what is humanly possible.
Since September of 2019,
the game has more or less been dominated by a single player,
Blastbolt,
who achieved his first world record with a 1.14,
and has since held the world record for most of the last several years,
and has steb-
...Hier stand-
Das ist jetzt aber auch ein bisschen merkwürdig im Vergleich, oder?
...totally lowered it.
By early 2021,
the record sat at one minute and five seconds,
just five seconds away from the final barrier.
This doesn't seem like a big distance,
and yet, it's still-
Na doch!
Fünf Sekunden sind extrem viel,
wenn man sich überlegt, dass die halt nur bei einer Minute fünf sind.
...book years to windle this tiny distance down.
Despite Blastbolts dominance,
there were some other noteworthy world records,
by other players,
like a 1.02 by Yeet1 in September of 2021,
and a one-minute flat by Galaxy in March of 2023.
Honestly, at the very end,
there were several people who could have been the one
to achieve the first sub-one-minute run.
But given his domination for so long,
it did seem like fate that Blastbolt would ultimately be the chosen one.
And the run is so short,
that there really is no reason for us not to just sit back,
and marvel in the beauty of its entire glory.
For many years-
Doch, der Topf hat nen Skin.
Aber ich glaube, das ist von irgendeinem Modding-Pack.
Das sieht aus wie ein Obelix-Skin, ja?
Das ist-
Was heißt, sieht nicht nur so aus, das ist bestimmt Absicht.
People weren't even sure if this would ever happen,
and it will never happen again.
On the 2nd of April 2023, Blastbolt broke the final-minute barrier-
Okay, jetzt kommt der Weltrekord.
...and achieved-
This Run.
Ja, das ist echt nicht normal, das ist echt unnormal, ne?
Alter.
Vor allem das Timing auch dabei.
Krasser Scheiß, oder?
I dedicate this run to-
When you compare this run to earlier runs in history-
I dedicated this run to us, habt ihr's gehört?
Real Agent Smith, danke für den Sub.
Alter, was ein krasser Dude, ihr-
Blastbolt.
You can really see just how much the technique has improved.
It really is a work of art,
and trying to find out where it was slow would just ruin it, in my opinion.
If you truly are interested in either learning to speedrun the game,
or wanting to know some of the more finer details,
I would suggest joining the Getting Over It Speedrun Discord,
which I will put a link to in the description.
A huge congratulations to Blastbolt for being the first person to beat
Getting Over It in less than one minute.
I do think this achievement deserves much more attention,
than it's received so far.
I really hope this video has allowed you to appreciate
Getting Over It Speedruns just that little bit more.
And I hope you've learned something along the way.
Thank you so much for watching, you legends.
I hope you're having a fantastic day-
Krasser Scheiß, Alter.
Also, mich würde echt interessieren, wie viele Spielstunden der Kerl hat.
Vierstellig ist es garantiert, könnte ich wetten.
Wahrscheinlich hat der irgendwie wirklich 5-6.000 Stunden in dem Game.
Komm mal, Speedrun...
Ist auch noch aktuell so.
Krass.
Wie ich immer 1.000 Tabs offen habe.
Nicht nur da, auch da und in der VM auch noch.
So, wollen wir uns als nächstes jetzt die Reaction auf mein Video angucken?
Also die Reaction auf die Reaction der Reaction?
Okay, wir lesen mal kurz ein paar Kommentare vorher,
weil wahrscheinlich sind die Kommentare schon extrem lost.
Also, ich habe vor einer Weile ein Video aufgenommen.
Das nannte sich...
Linux ist kein Ersatz für Windows.
Und das Thumbnail war, glaube ich, so eine Hand mit Finger weg oder sowas.
Ja, das war vielleicht ein bisschen Clickbait, das Thumbnail, aber so musst du es halt machen.
Ja, genau, Finger weg von Linux, Fragezeichen.
Also, das ist das Video.
Lies dir mal die 2042 Kommentare durch.
Ich lese alle Kommentare. Welche meinst du denn?
Ich habe die höchste Wahrscheinlichkeit.
Ich habe die höchstwahrscheinlich gesehen.
Ach so, ja, die sind auch Pepega, ja.
So, mal gucken.
Also, es ist wohl ein Channel, der hauptsächlich Linux-Content macht.
Also, ich könnte mir durchaus vorstellen, dass er es anders sieht als ich.
So, ich muss mal kurz die Kommentare durchschauen.
Wo davon kann überhaupt nichts?
Ja, das ist so.
Ja, genau das, übrigens genau das sage ich auch im Video, ja.
Also, seriously, ernsthaft.
Wenn ich Leute...
Also, ich kann niemanden ernst nehmen, der Windows schreibt.
Ich meine, ich bin fast 39, aber das ist so richtiger Boomer-Humor-Cringe, das halte ich nicht aus.
Also, Leute, ohne Scheiß, die Windows schreiben oder die Mini-Weich anstatt Microsoft schreiben und sowas, ey, das kann ich nicht ernst nehmen.
Proton hilft, ja, aber auch nicht für alles.
Gnomebox, kurzer Hintergrund.
Was ich bei Adobe nicht verstehe, warum die keine Software für Linux anbieten, das ist auch eine große Frechheit.
Kann man jetzt so sehen, aber die bieten halt dort an, wo sie Geld machen können und das ist halt zur Zeit nicht unter Linux.
Aber ich habe es schon oft gesagt, es ist nicht nur, es ist nicht nur dieses, wie es immer genannt wird, Henne-Ei-Problem, so Verbreitung von Linux ist zu gering und dementsprechend haben die Hersteller keinen Bock und weil die Hersteller keinen Bock haben, ist die Linux-Verbreitung...
Das ist nicht das einzige Problem.
Das Problem unter Linux ist auch, dass sehr viel, wie soll man sagen, so Probleme hin- und hergeschiebe stattfindet.
Guckt euch das Trauerspiel an bei Windows-Systemen zum Beispiel, ja, also die ganze Geschichte mit X und Wayland.
Wayland, angeblich ja schon seit über 10 Jahren das geilste ever funktioniert, immer noch nicht gescheiten VMs und solche Geschichten.
Ich kann die Hersteller durchaus verstehen, dass sie für, keine Ahnung, sagen wir mal, sind wir mal großzügig.
Sagen 2% der User, was wahrscheinlich noch viel zu hoch gegriffen ist, dass sie für 2% der User keinen großen Aufwand betreiben wollen, um das gescheit zu supporten.
Wenn man das einfach nebenbei mitmachen könnte, ja, dann sicherlich würden das mehr machen, aber für so einen kleinen Teil der User größeren Aufwand treiben, um was unter Linux zum Laufen zu bekommen, das wollen die Hersteller nicht.
Und das kann ich auch verstehen.
Und da steht sich Linux auf dem Desktop tatsächlich.
Ich meine, überall anders ist Linux ja auch schon da.
Smartphones keine Frage, Server keine Frage, IoT und smarte Sachen daheim keine Frage, also Linux im Auto.
Linux ist ja überall schon da, nur auf dem Desktop nicht.
Und ich glaube auch nicht, dass das Linux auf dem Desktop in nächster Zeit, auch wenn jedes Jahr natürlich das Jahr des Linux-Desktops ist, irgendwie sich durchsetzen wird.
Da ist viel zu viel auch Probleme, Probleme rumgeschiebe.
Was man ja auch unter anderem, was ich im Video ja auch sage, was man unter anderem auch sagt.
Was man unter anderem auch sagt.
nee, das muss die Anwendung machen, ah, das muss vielleicht doch in Kernel rein.
Da kann ich die Hersteller schon verstehen, dass sie da teilweise keinen Bock drauf haben.
Wenn du für 2% der User einen überdurchschnittlichen Aufwand betreiben müsstest,
dann machen das die Hersteller einfach nicht.
Ja, gut, wenn man nur mit Apps im Browser klarkommt, dann ist es überhaupt kein Ding.
Wie gesagt, ich verwende Linux täglich, ich habe es auf der alten Arbeit täglich verwendet,
als, wie nennt man das so schön, Daily Driver.
Das funktioniert schon, ja, da habe ich Office, die ganzen Office-Geschichten auch zu 99% im Browser benutzt,
weil das unter Linux wunderbar funktioniert.
Wusstet ihr eigentlich, dass Office 365 eine React-JS-Anwendung ist?
War es zumindest lange Zeit, ich glaube, es ist immer noch.
Ja, und da steht sich das alles so ein bisschen selbst im Weg.
Das ist aber nicht schlecht, das ist einfach nur eine Sache, die sich nicht vereinbaren lässt.
Ich meine, eines der großen Vorteile von Linux ist halt, dass du machen kannst, was du willst.
Ups, den wollte ich nicht wirklich anklicken.
Dass du machen kannst, was du willst, dass du große Vielfalt hast,
das steht aber halt, so dieser Verbreitung, gerade was Desktop-Sachen angeht, dann auch schon wieder ein bisschen im Weg.
Wenn man sich über so einfache Sachen wie, sagen wir mal, Videodecoding erst mal sechs, sieben Jahre streitet,
wo das unter anderem Betriebssystem schon funktioniert, ist halt, ist halt so.
Ist auf der einen Seite Vorteil, auf der anderen Seite Nachteil.
Ich muss mal kurz ein paar Pepega-Comments durchlesen.
Okay, da habe ich gestern reingepostet.
Ins kalte Wasser springen Sie...
Gleich mal reporten für Verschwörungstheorien.
Hä?
Ist das ein Bot-Kommentar?
Das muss irgendwie, mit dem Avatar muss das irgendwas, irgendwas Troll-mäßiges sein.
Da habe ich ja gerade schon was zugesagt, dass man das nicht nur den Ball an den Herstellern hinschieben kann.
Es muss für den Hersteller auch attraktiv sein, was auf Linux anzubieten,
oder zumindest nicht komplizierter als die anderen Betriebssysteme sein, für einen Bruchteil der User.
Automatische Lautstärkeregelung.
Bin ich mir relativ sicher, dass man das unter, unter Linux irgendwie machen kann.
Wobei ich auch unter, unter Windows keine automatische Lautstärkeregelung benutze.
Linux in allen Aspekten auf demselben Niveau wie Windows, außer bei Spielen.
Ja, für ihn vielleicht.
Man muss auch sich mal irgendwo eingestehen, dass unterschiedliche User unterschiedliche Sachen unterschiedlich gewichten.
Für mich auch.
Ich benutze auch zu 90 Prozent für sie, für die Sachen, die ich an Technik-Sachen mache.
Linux hier auf dem zweiten...
Auf dem zweiten Desktop.
Das heißt jetzt aber nicht, dass ich sagen würde, das ist für jeden immer so.
Oder er sollte das so machen.
Ein Laie wird niemals die Struktur verstehen.
Welche Struktur?
Okay, das wollt ihr jetzt nämlich auch grad fragen.
Die Struktur des Root-Verzeichnisses.
Das muss...
Also, also mal ganz davon abgesehen, dass es wirklich nicht schwierig ist, so die Sachen, die man...
Ich verstehe, das kommt nicht, ja?
Also es ist tatsächlich gar nicht so schwierig.
Die Sachen, die man wissen muss, hat man relativ schnell drinne.
Und ansonsten, ganz ehrlich, unter Windows versteht das auch keiner, wo Windows da irgendwelche Dinger hinmacht.
Aber dann verstehst du es unter Linux, finde ich, fast noch ein bisschen besser.
Okay, die Kommentare sind gar nicht so pepega, wie ich vermutet hätte.
Linux ist Pseudo-Maso.
Okay.
Erstes pepega Comment gespottet.
Ich weiß nicht, was der Typ möchte.
Ich bin vor 20 Jahren...
Ich will sagen, dass es nicht für jeden was ist.
Ist doch ganz klar, was ich möchte in dem Video.
Der Typ spinnt sich einen zurecht.
Ohne Scheiß, die Art des Comments zu schreiben und der Username passt einfach wunderbar zusammen.
Das Forum Ubuntu-Users.
Ja, das ist wirklich gut.
Da findet man viele Sachen.
Linux soll nicht für Spiele geeignet sein.
Das habe ich nicht gesagt.
Ich habe gesagt, Linux ist für manche Spiele nicht geeignet.
Unter anderem für Sachen, die Anti-Cheat verwenden.
Und für Sachen, die nicht unbedingt auf Steam sind.
Ja.
Ich finde das immer geil.
Die Leute gehen überhaupt nicht auf das ein, was man sagt.
Ich habe gesagt, es geht vieles.
Es geht beeindruckend viel im Video.
Es gibt allerdings...
Oder wie habe ich es gesagt?
Es gibt auch vieles, das geht nicht.
Zum Beispiel das, das, das und das.
Und es kommt keiner, der sagt, nein, Max, das stimmt nicht.
Das geht doch.
Weil es geht halt einfach nicht.
Es stimmt halt, was ich gesagt habe.
Bevor ich jetzt die Kommentare weiter durchlese, gucken wir uns das Video an.
Der Max ist Linux-Senior-Engineer.
Cringe Comment, Alter.
Welcher Max, der YouTuber, der das filmt?
Cringe Comment, der Max ist...
Außerdem bin ich Senior Linux-Engineer und nicht Linux-Senior-Engineer.
So etwas finde ich auch immer cringe.
So etwas finde ich auch immer cringe, wenn die Leute einen dann verteidigen müssen unter Video.
Es sollte nicht das Ziel seines Terminals zu umgehen.
Das ist eines der besten Sachen, die es unter Linux gibt.
Werbung für seine Abzockerschulungen vor...
Meint der mich oder...
Ne, der meint wahrscheinlich denjenigen, der reactet.
Aber...
Hä?
Pepega, Leute.
Okay.
Gucken wir mal.
Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt.
Ja, Titel sind vollkommen...
Das sage ich ja auch immer.
Titel sind vollkommen egal.
Ist eh Auslegungssache, was man beim jeweiligen Unternehmen dann macht.
KDE, KDE haben wir uns gestern angeguckt.
Allerdings noch nicht fertig.
Das machen wir vielleicht heute Mittag fertig.
Okay, auf geht's.
Wann kommt ein neues Video von der Arbeit?
Ich stelle mich morgen in die Tiefgarage und nehme ein Video auf.
Easy.
Ne.
Ich muss euch noch unbedingt meine Bewerbung und alles zeigen.
Mach ich als nächstes.
Okay, auf geht's.
Gucken wir uns...
Wir reacten jetzt auf die Reaction von einem meiner Videos.
So geht das Content Game auf YouTube mittlerweile.
Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen Video auf Linux Guides.
Ja, mir ist vor ein paar...
Ich glaube, Lautstärke ist okay, gell?
Es ist immer schwierig einzustellen, wenn die Leute so dynamische Soundsettings haben.
Von leise bis laut.
Also...
So wie ich das auch habe.
...monaten das Video Finger weg von Linux aufgefallen.
Ja, okay.
Also, was ist denn mit Linux aufgefallen?
Ne, Linux ist kein Ersatz für Windows.
Korrekt.
Linux ist auch kein Ersatz für Windows.
Das ist ein komplett anderes System und das ist eigentlich eine der Hauptaussagen, die
ich da drin habe.
Gucken wir mal.
Ich bin sehr gespannt, was dieses Video zu bieten hat.
Du hast das Video im Vorfeld schon geguckt, wenn dir das vor ein paar Monaten aufgefallen
ist.
Exposed.
She made it.
Du hast das bestimmt schon geguckt und hast danach jetzt nochmal ein Video aufgenommen.
Was auch überhaupt nicht verwerflich ist, was wahrscheinlich die meisten Reaction-Leute
machen.
Ich reagte mal da drauf.
Ja, auf geht's.
Aber das tatsächlich noch gar nicht gesehen.
Ich habe mich gezwungen, es noch nicht zu sehen, sondern erstens für diese Aufnahme
hier.
Ich glaube immer.
Und ich würde sagen, wir schauen einfach mal, was hier Max FPS zu sagen hat und ich
meine auch natürlich dann meine Kommentare und Meinungen dazu.
Let's go.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, welche Richtung das Video geht.
Von daher würde ich einfach mal sagen, wir legen los.
Linux ist kein Ersatz für Windows.
Der Link dazu ist in der Videobeschreibung und wir schauen einfach mal an, was...
Mein Video ist 19 Minuten.
Ach so, er schaltet mich ja auf 1,5%, da haben wir ja gestern schon kurz reingesgibt.
Was er zu sagen hat.
So.
Hallo Leute, hier ist der Max und jetzt ist es wirklich passiert.
96 Tage nach dem Upload.
Ne, mal ganz kurz.
Die Katze ist nicht von mir.
Die ist von ihm hier.
Einmal hier.
Ich habe nicht eben eine Katze.
Nur, dass ihr Bescheid wisst.
Sehr viele Leute in den Kommentaren in dem Windows 11 Video haben geschrieben, dass sie
demnächst auf Linux umsteigen.
Ich scroll mal ein bisschen vor.
Ich glaube, aktuell kommt noch nicht viel.
Ja, stark.
Ne?
Ich habe ja leider wenig Kontakt mittlerweile zu Windows und zu Windows 11.
Insgesamt auch zur Welt.
Was tatsächlich...
Moment.
Ich bin verwirrt.
Ach ne.
Das sind die...
Alter, bin ich blöd.
Das sind die Subtitle von ihm.
... ein bisschen schade ist, weil man nämlich langfristig dann natürlich so ein bisschen
den Horizont verliert und ich sag mal, sich immer schlechter in die Umsteiger einfühlen
kann.
Ja.
Das finde ich ein bisschen schwierig.
Aber was wir hier auf jeden Fall...
Ja, das stimmt.
Das stimmt wohl.
... sehen.
Der Max FPS ist auf jeden Fall ein Linux-Nutzer, was wir hier sehen.
Und ich bin sehr gespannt, was er zu sagen hat.
Die drei Beste.
Ich bin mal zu frei und stelle das mal ein bisschen höher.
Und die...
Der Musik tut das zwar nicht gut, aber wir können uns das ein bisschen schneller anschauen.
Also es ging ganz oft in den Kommentaren um den Um...
Das hört sich ja bescheuert an.
... auf Linux.
Und dazu wollte ich einfach mal was sagen.
Weil ich denke...
Ich lehne mich jetzt einfach mal ein bisschen aus dem Fenster und sage, ich bin überzeugt
davon, dass...
Ich bin überzeugt davon, dass...
... Linux für die meisten nicht die Lösung ihrer Probleme ist und wahrscheinlich auch
in Zukunft keine Lösung sein wird.
Okay.
Also seine Aussage ist, für die meisten Leute ist Linux nicht geeignet.
Nein.
Das ist...
Das...
Das ist nicht unbedingt das, was ich gesagt habe, was ich gesagt habe, beziehungsweise
im Video dann auch gesagt habe.
Aber was dann auch klar wird, ist, dass für die Leute Linux nicht die Lösung ihrer Probleme
ist, die sie mit Windows haben, zumindest für die meisten.
Das würde ich tatsächlich dementieren.
Ich würde sehr wohl sagen, dass Linux für sehr, sehr viele Leute sehr gut geeignet ist.
Da schauen wir einfach mal weiter, was er da zu sagen hat.
Und ich gebe euch Brief und Siegel drauf.
Die meisten Leute, die einfach jetzt ins kalte Wasser springen und sagen, ich nehme jetzt
Linux als Windows-Ersatz, die werden nicht glücklich.
Ja.
Dann ist natürlich die Frage, warum?
Und warum sage ich das als hauptberuflicher Linux-Benutzer?
Denn das sollte ich vielleicht auch noch erwähnen.
Ich verwende Linux täglich.
Alter, ich kann mir mein Gelaber nicht anhören in 1,5-fach, das halte ich nicht aus.
Der Chat ist über seinem Gesicht.
Okay, Sekunde, Leute.
Ich blende mal den Chat aus.
Wir brauchen jetzt nicht Doppel-Chat.
Ne?
Ich meine, wir haben ja hier...
Wir haben hier Chat von mir.
Leute.
Chatception.
Chat von mir von vor irgendwie einem halben Jahr.
Oh, Moment.
Ich habe das Falsche ausgeblendet, oder?
Wait a minute.
Ich habe das Display ausgeblendet und nicht den Chat.
Ups.
Seit 15 Jahren.
Ja.
Bisschen länger sogar noch.
Stark.
Also sehr, sehr, sehr lange auch drin.
Länger als ich in der Linux-Welt drin.
Ich bin seit 2013.
Dann müsste er so seit 2007 drin sein.
Das Video ist jetzt fast ein Jahr schon alt.
15 Jahre täglich.
Privat und auf der Arbeit.
Und ich könnte mir gar nicht mal vorstellen, ohne zu arbeiten.
Und eins ist ganz klar.
Linux ist heute überall.
Im Kühlschrank.
Das ist kein Witz.
Es gibt smarte Kühlschränke mit Linux drauf.
Auf dem Smartphone selbstverständlich.
Im Fernsehen.
Guckt euch aktuelle Smart-TVs an.
Ganz oft ein Android-TV oder irgendwas Linux-artiges drauf.
In der Cloud.
Auf Servern.
Aber auf dem Desktop eher weniger.
Und selbst unter...
Der macht es richtig.
Der hydratet sich.
Ich trinke auch mal was, Leute.
So.
Das kann man mittlerweile mit WSL direkt Linux-Programme auswählen.
Also Linux hat sich wirklich durchgesetzt.
Ich glaube, darüber müssen wir wirklich nicht mehr diskutieren.
Und Linux ist wirklich überall präsent.
Und es hat sich da auch dementsprechend die letzten Jahre verdammt viel getan.
Brauchen wir nicht mehr darüber diskutieren.
Deswegen lasse ich das einfach mal weiterlaufen.
Nur, dass ihr Bescheid wisst.
Überall.
Trotzdem.
Einfach ist der Umstieg.
Jetzt zu sagen, ich schmeiße Windows weg und haue mir Linux drauf.
Nicht.
Und ich halte den Umstieg.
Würde ich nie empfehlen.
Dass man sagt, okay, gut, ich schmeiße mein Windows in die Tonne.
Und gehe jetzt vom einen auf den anderen Tag auf Linux.
Das geht auf jeden Fall schief.
Jedenfalls die Wahrscheinlichkeit dafür ist sehr, sehr hoch.
Das ist einfach nicht der Weg, wie man es für Linux finden sollte.
Ich sage vielleicht am Ende des Videos nochmal meinen empfohlenen Plan.
Das finde ich gut, weil am Ende des Videos sage ich auch, was ich empfehlen würde.
Mal gucken.
Bin ich mal gespannt.
Den Umstieg auch für die meisten Leute nicht für sinnvoll.
Und was man machen kann, beziehungsweise was ich für einen guten Weg halte, Windows und
Linux zusammenzuverwenden, erzähle ich euch am Ende des Videos.
Aber erstmal jetzt, warum halte ich das nicht für sinnvoll?
Der erste Punkt ist, dass Umsteiger denken sich so, ja, Windows 11 oder Windows im Allgemeinen
und Microsoft, die regen mich auf.
Es gibt irgendwelche Punkte, die ihnen da halt überhaupt nicht gefallen.
Und dann...
Ich denke, das gibt es aber auch bei vielen Linux-Hunds, sondern bei Linux, denke ich.
Das ist so der ein oder andere Punkt.
Sicherlich, ja.
Den einen stört.
So richtig aufregen nicht, denke ich.
Wie würdest du aktuell...
Sekunde.
What?
Wie würdest du eigentlich Go aktuell platzieren, wenn du Programmiersprachen ratest vom Nutzwert,
wenn man es lernen würde?
Also welche Sprachen würdest du heute als erstes lernen, wenn du...
Es hängt immer ganz entscheidend davon ab, was ich eigentlich für Software erstellen will.
Manche Sachen gehen halt nur oder besonders gut.
Mit der einen Sache und nicht mit der anderen.
Also wenn ich gar keine Ahnung hätte, was ich machen wollen würde, dann tatsächlich
Javascript.
Weil mit Javascript kannst du ja unterm Strich nahezu alles in Zukunft auch machen.
Du kannst Web-Anwendungen bauen, du kannst allerdings auch Backend-Anwendungen bauen,
du kannst auch Desktop-Anwendungen bauen.
Vielleicht nicht immer so in der Perfektion in der jeweiligen Sparte, wie man sich das
dann vorstellen würde.
Aber nicht umsonst ist beispielsweise Discord auch quasi...
mehr oder weniger eine Javascript-Anwendung mit ein paar C++-Modulen.
Ja, also da würde ich Javascript anfangen.
Und zum Thema Go...
Ich würde auch nicht mit TypeScript als erstes anfangen, sondern tatsächlich mit ganz normalem Javascript.
Go würde ich tatsächlich relativ hoch raten.
Das liegt da...
Also je nachdem, in welchem Bereich du bist natürlich.
Go würde ich allerdings trotzdem relativ hoch raten, weil du kannst mit Go auch...
Warte mal...
Das meiste machen.
Aber Go ist gerade was im Cloud und im...
Wie nennt man das so schön?
So Cloud-Native-Umfeld, wenn man eben da unterwegs ist.
Oftmals die Sprache, in der viele Tools erstellt wurden.
Ich glaube Terraform ist da drin erstellt.
Kubernetes selbst ist relativ viel in Go.
Also Go ist eine sehr beliebte Sprache und auch für Linux-Command-Line-Tools, wenn man
irgendwas so self-containedes braucht.
Oder auch für Web-Anwendungen, Backends und solche Geschichten ist Go eine super Geschichte.
Aber gerade im Cloud-Umfeld ist Go sehr beliebt.
Also in den Tools, die da drin programmiert sind.
Aber halt auch für Sachen, die man damit machen kann.
Und die Packages, die es dafür gibt.
Also ich würde sagen, Go ist aktuell eines der wichtigsten Programmiersprachen, die man
mal gesehen haben sollte.
Also ich würde sagen, man sollte Go mal gesehen haben.
Man sollte Javascript mal gesehen haben.
Man kann sich aussuchen.
Man sollte mal Java bzw. C-Sharp gesehen haben.
Ich persönlich bin natürlich mehr Richtung C-Sharp.
Ihr kennt mich ja, ich bin kein großer Java-Fan.
Man sollte Python mal gesehen haben.
Und wenn man im Operations-Admin-Bereich da ist, sollte man auch ein bisschen Ahnung
haben von Shell-Scripts.
Sei es jetzt Bash oder halt Linux-Shell-Scripts.
Oder meinetwegen, wenn es Windows ist, dann auch PowerShell.
Das sind so die Sachen, wo ich sage, dass es auf jeden Fall sinnvoll ist, mal gesehen
zu haben.
Okay, gucken wir weiter.
Habe ich jedenfalls noch nichts gefunden.
Aber ich denke, stören tun uns auch manchmal der eine oder andere Sachen.
Also kein System ist perfekt, ganz klar.
Die logische Konsequenz, ja gut, suche ich mir eine Alternative, gehe ich zu Linux.
Und die denken sich dann, das benutze ich dann halt so wie Windows, nur dass es dann
eben wie Windows ist, ohne die Sachen, die mich nervt von Windows.
Und da muss man halt ganz klar sagen, das funktioniert nicht.
Selbst wenn...
Ja, unterstreiche ich zu 100 Prozent.
Das ist das Riesenproblem.
Manche erwarten genau das Gleiche, genau die gleiche Funktionsweise von Windows.
Und da liegt schon tatsächlich der Fehler begraben.
Oder ich sage mal...
Da sind wir uns auch einig.
Also von daher, man muss sich schon in gewisser Weise bei Linux auf Änderungen einstellen.
Das System funktioniert an verschiedenen Stellen anders und viele wollen es vielleicht am Anfang
gar nicht so wahrhaben, weil sie natürlich nur die ganze Zeit Windows kennen.
Sie wissen gar nicht, dass es auch anders geht.
In gewisser Weise.
Und sie wollen.
Und das ist das.
Das ist der Punkt, den ich auch in dem Video nochmal unterstreichen wollte.
Sie wollen eigentlich auch Windows verwenden.
Sie wollen Windows, allerdings ohne diese Sachen, weshalb sie nicht Windows wollen.
Also sie wollen eigentlich weiterhin Windows, bis auf so ein, zwei Punkte, die sie nicht
wollen.
Das heißt, sie wollen quasi ein Linux, was genauso ist wie Windows, aber halt die Punkte,
die sie nerven, besser macht.
Und das wird es halt nicht geben.
Dort holen wir natürlich dann den einen oder anderen Nutzer erstmal nicht so ab.
Wobei in der Benutzeroberfläche für den Endanwender ist das doch schon, ich sage mal,
mittlerweile sehr ähnlich geworden.
Was ja, ich denke, Vorteile für beide Seiten hat.
Außer man verwendet I3 dann nicht.
Aber ja, wir haben uns gestern ja KDE Plasma angeguckt und ich denke, mit KDE Plasma dürften
auch die meisten Windows-Anwender glücklich werden.
Es ist sogar besser in dem Fall als die Windows-Oberfläche, was Customizability angeht.
Das war ich gestern tatsächlich beeindruckt von.
Ich habe ja KDE, wie gesagt, ich habe ja früher KDE schon öfters angeguckt, auch die letzten
Jahre über mal wieder.
KDE früher war halt immer so extrem überladen an Options und ich finde die aktuelle Version,
das ist wirklich ein guter Kompromiss zwischen immer noch, quasi du kannst immer noch mehr
oder weniger alles das einstellen, was du früher auch einstellen konntest und sehr,
sehr viele Sachen mehr.
Überall gibt es Plugins und Plugin Manager und hast du nicht gesehen.
Aber es ist mittlerweile Interface-technisch so verpackt, dass man halbwegs...
gut klarkommt.
Gibt es keine Windows-Klon-Distribution unter Linux?
Doch.
Gibt bestimmt, weiß ich jetzt nicht, aber ja, es kommen immer mal wieder welche raus,
die so aussehen wollen wie Windows.
Aber das ist der falsche Ansatz, weil dann hast du vielleicht eine Oberfläche, die die
ersten fünf Minuten so aussieht wie Windows.
Aber wenn du dann ein paar Untermenüs aufmachst, wirst du schon mal feststellen, nein, es ist
doch kein Windows.
Und spätestens, wenn du halt an Settings und Details rangehen musst, dann ist es halt
einfach kein Windows.
Es macht auch keinen Sinn.
Linux zu Windows.
Linux zu Windows komplett umzubauen von der Optik her, weil unten drunter wird es halt
nie ein Windows sein.
Compets war eh das Beste früher.
Selbst wenn man eine Distribution nimmt, die erstmal ähnlich zu Windows aussieht,
Linux ist ein fundamental anderes System.
Also ganz klar, Linux ist nicht die Lösung für Windows-Probleme.
Das muss einem klar sein.
Ganz klar.
Also niemand sollte Windows verlassen, nur weil er die eine Funktion unter Windows nicht
mag.
Ich denke, man sollte Windows verlassen, wenn man möchte.
Aufgrund des Datenschutzes.
Aufgrund der Freiheit, die man dazu gewinnt bei Linux.
Dass dein Rechner wirklich dir wieder gehört.
Da gebe ich ihm recht.
Wenn das der Hintergrund ist, dann auf geht's zu Linux.
Keine Frage.
Die Sachen wie Performance, Funktionalität sind nette Features, die es dazu gibt.
Aber man sollte es nicht wegen diesen verlassen.
Weil sonst ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass man wieder zurückgeht, sehr, sehr hoch.
Ihr solltet Linux nutzen, wenn ihr wirklich...
Matthias.
Matthias, Mac ist auch eine ganz gute Alternative, weil du hast unter Mac so eine schöne Kombination
aus.
Es ist, sagen wir mal, Unix-Linux-artig genug, es ist ja eigentlich ein BSD im Kern, um nicht
abzufacken.
Und es ist weit genug von Windows entfernt, um da auch nicht abzufacken.
Also Mac ist insofern eine ganz gute Kombination.
Wenn man so dieses gesamte Ökosystem mag.
Ja.
Ja, wieder euren PC zurückzugewinnen in gewisser Weise.
Man kann nicht einfach sagen, ich möchte ein Windows ohne die nervigen Seiten von Windows unter Linux.
Das gibt's doch nicht.
Das ist erstmal ganz was anderes.
Und das fällt, denke ich, vielen auch recht schnell auf.
Und es ist gut, dass es was anderes ist.
Es ist kein Windows.
Und es ist auch kein einfaches Windows-Deplacement.
Zum Beispiel, unter Windows ist man gewohnt, dass man so gut wie alles über irgendwelche
grafischen Menüs machen kann.
Außer Sachen, auf die Microsoft keinen Bock mehr hat.
Die sind dann entweder in der Registry versteckt oder im tausendsten Untermenü, die aussehen
wie aus Windows 3.11.
Aber man ist zumindest unter Windows gewöhnt, man macht das meiste über die grafische Oberfläche.
Dadurch haben viele Angst.
Ein bisschen vor Kommandozeile und Shell.
Weil sie nur dieses hässliche Steinzeit-CMD kennen mit Batch unter Windows.
Selbst da gibt es neue Sachen.
Es gibt ein neues Terminal unter Windows.
Ich finde seine Bezeichnung für die Batch bzw. das CMD in Windows sehr treffend.
Hässliches Steinzeit-CMD.
Ist ja auch so.
Aber es stimmt, das Ding kann nix.
Im Gegensatz zu den anderen Shells.
Ich persönlich PowerShell als ziemlich gute Automatisierungs-Shell empfinde, aber weniger
gut als interaktive.
Aber das ist was anderes.
Das Standardsystem unter Windows aus CMD und Batch, das ist aus der Steinzeit.
Aber viele User verbinden damit eben Steinzeit.
Terminal gleich Steinzeit.
Sagen wir mal so generell, viele User verbinden nicht nur Terminal mit Steinzeit, sondern
auch, dass es viel zu kompliziert ist.
Viel zu kompliziert.
Und da würde ich den Usern auch zustimmen, den neuen Nutzern.
Ich würde euch auch nicht groß empfehlen, Terminals am Anfang zu verwenden.
Versucht relativ viele grafisch zu machen.
Ich zeige zwar immer mehr in meinen Tutorials.
In meinen Tutorials auch mal als Terminal, weil es nämlich für alle Systeme oder für
viel mehr Systeme gleich ist.
Dann kannst du es unter Ubuntu ausführen, unter Linux Mint, unter dem Tuxedo OS, Pop
OS und so weiter.
Und das ist genau der gleiche Befehl.
Ansonsten müsste ich das für jede Distribution nochmal einzeln zeigen, weil jede Oberfläche
anders aufgebaut ist.
Deswegen nutze ich da häufiger das Terminal und versuche das aber auch bei manchen Linux
Mint Videos so weit wie möglich rauszuhalten.
Ja gut.
Hey.
Und wenn es da so ein gewöhnliches UI dafür gibt, wo man dann auch das findet, was man
sucht, dann ist das ja keine Frage.
Dann kann man das ja auch über ein UI machen.
Aber ich habe ja später noch ein paar Beispiele im Video.
Manchmal ist halt das Ding, du kommst nicht drum herum.
Und ich finde es auch gar nicht schlimm, dass du nicht drum herum kommst, weil ich denke
gerade je aufgeschlossener man dieser Sache gegenüber ist, umso mehr kann man auch letztendlich
unter Linux rausholen.
Das ist für mich eines der Haupt, wie nennt man das so schön, Produktivitätsbooster, keine Ahnung, eines der Haupt-Pluspunkte für Linux.
Dass du gescheite Terminals hast, dass du gescheite Shells hast und dort eben auch was drauf machen kannst.
Guck mal, ich meine, ich verwende noch nicht ohne Grund das minimalste an Desktop- bzw. Windows-System, was es hier irgendwie gibt.
Okay, das stimmt nicht, es gibt noch deutlich minimalere, das kann man nicht sagen, das ist immer noch.
Aber für manch einen ist sicherlich sogar mein Desktop hier, es ist ja gar nicht mein Desktop, ich habe nur immer Desktop-Symbole.
Für viele ist sicherlich sogar mein Desktop bloated hier, weil ich habe hier eine Menüleiste und irgendwie einen Timer, den ich starten kann und sowas.
Das ist für manche schon super bloated.
Aber insgesamt, ich habe eine Terminal im Fullscreen und ich kann damit machen, was ich will.
Für die Sachen, wo ich nicht im Terminal mache, habe ich natürlich meinen Browser auf, habe ich hier meinen Editor auf oder sonst was.
Übrigens passt von der Zeit her, der Pepo ist gerade am futtern.
Ja klar.
Wenn jemand neu ist, ist es sicherlich nicht verkehrt, alles über die Oberfläche zu machen, aber man sollte keine Angst haben im Terminal, weil spätestens, wenn man irgendwelche Guides ausführen muss, weil irgendwas nicht funktioniert, weil, keine Ahnung, weil es Probleme mit irgendwelchen WLAN-Treibern gibt oder sonst was, wo man dann nach ETC-D, äh, nicht ETC-D, äh, ETC-Mod, äh, wo es das Mod, Modules-D, irgendwas eintragen muss, irgendwas Blacklisten muss, weil das WLAN nicht richtig funktioniert.
Irgendwelche Parameter.
Irgendwelche Parameter irgendwo ändern muss.
Ja, das ist tatsächlich am angenehmsten auf der Shell.
Deswegen finde ich es eigentlich was Gutes, dass das unter Linux eben so ist.
Und dass man sich nach Möglichkeiten auch, es ist gut, gut vorteilhaft für einen ist, wenn man sich damit auseinandersetzt.
Also ich würde gar nicht sagen, dass es was Negatives ist.
Das wollte ich, das will ich in dem Video auch nicht sagen.
Ich glaube, das kommt in dem Video auch raus.
Das ist was Negatives.
Erstmal muss das quasi als, als Teil.
Das funktioniert nicht.
Das, du kommst unter Linux nicht dran vorbei.
Terminal, Terminal und ordentliche Shell ist die beste Art, sein System zu verwalten und zu administrieren.
Ähm, von Windows-Umsteigern hört man dann allerdings sowas.
Gehe ich mit, ist für den Endanwender aber egal.
Eigentlich egal.
Wenn das System einmal eingerichtet ist, wenn es einmal läuft, dann brauchst du das Terminal nie wieder.
Bis du an diesem Punkt bist, ja, kann es schon sein, dass du den benötigst.
Sowas wie, alter, muss nicht, kann.
Was ist da los?
Ich soll Shell-Befehle lernen.
Wo sind wir denn?
19.
Okay, ich meine, wenn man sein System einmal einrichtet und dann nie wieder was dran macht.
Vielleicht, ja, okay.
Aber, ja, genau.
Was weiß ich, irgendwelche Dateien überschrieben werden bei einem Update.
Es kann immer mal was sein.
Ja, gut, würde ich, würde ich soweit auch mitgeben, würde ich sagen, hey, wenn man das einmal initial einrichtet und dann nie wieder was dran machen will.
Oder auch nichts irgendwie ausprobieren will oder sonst was.
Braucht man es nicht.
Nicht zwangsläufig, aber das ist ja auch gar nicht der Punkt.
Der Punkt ist ja, dass man vieles sogar besser machen kann übers Terminal.
Genau, Linux ist nie fertig eingerichtet.
Dass man vieles einfach auch besser machen kann.
Deswegen ist es eigentlich eine blöde Sache, das so als sein Feind zu sehen, das Terminal, sondern man muss es als Teil des Systems sehen und eigentlich als einen der größten Vorteile davon.
1990, aber so ist es.
Früher oder später müsst ihr unter Linux was mit dem Terminal machen.
Ja, da werden wir nicht dran vorbei.
Wenn man ein paar...
Wenn man jetzt einen Browser starten will, YouTube-Videos aufmachen will, da brauchst du kein Terminal.
Aber früher oder später wird jeder, der sich selbst in Linux installiert und das ein bisschen customisieren will, ein bisschen einrichten will und mal was nicht geht.
Du wirst nicht darauf hinkommen, mal irgendeinen Guide aus irgendeinem Forum machen zu müssen und dann musst du ins Terminal.
Das wird nicht anders funktionieren.
Um sage ich so zu gucken, ja, wo genau hat es jetzt euren USB-Stick hingehängt?
Ja, vielleicht müsst ihr irgendwo mal ein Skript ausführen.
Ja, also Skript ausführen oder Druckertreiber installieren, das ist sehr nervig teilweise.
Ne, weil da bieten manche Hersteller nichts an.
Also es ist schon schwierig unter Linux generell für immer um den Terminal herumzukommen, aber man schafft das doch eigentlich sehr, sehr, sehr gut als normaler Nutzer.
Aber man sollte gar nicht.
Man sollte es benutzen, weil es eines der besten Vorzüge ist, das man haben kann.
Dass du da nicht drauf musst, vor allem wenn man Leute hat, die einem da helfen.
Ich will das in dem Video ja auch gar nicht erzählen, dass es was Negatives ist.
Das muss so sein.
Das ist eines der besten Sachen, die es gibt.
Die sich da ein bisschen besser auskennen, ne?
Linux Guide Support, nur mal ganz kurz eines sagen, aber auch bekannte, die einem dann diese Arbeit abnehmen.
Dann bist du eigentlich...
Was hat er da für einen Lüfter im Hintergrund?
Hört ihr das?
Da geht immer irgendein Lüfter an.
Das Endanwender komplett fein raus.
Und dein Linux administrieren musst du eigentlich nur zum Beginn...
Vor allem, was soll dann eigentlich ein Endanwender sein?
Der Admin und der Endanwender ist genau das gleiche in dem Fall, wenn sich einer daheim den Krempel installiert.
Sei es jetzt auf seiner Hardware oder in der VM.
Da ist nicht so, fragt sie ihren Administrator.
Okay, vielleicht wenn ich jetzt meiner Mutter oder wenn ihr euch eurer Oma oder was auch immer das installiert.
Okay, dann könnte man sagen, die Oma ist Endanwender und ihr kümmert euch um das System.
Gut, dann könnt ihr das natürlich alles so einrichten, aber das ist ja meistens nicht der Fall.
Also zumindest nicht für die Leute, die die Videos gucken.
Die meisten wollen sich das selbst installieren und wollen das dann auch selbst einrichten, customisieren, administrieren.
... in und zum Aktualisieren.
Das war's.
Ansonsten währenddessen kannst du Linux ganz normal nutzen, wie auch ein anderes System.
Du müsstest vielleicht CPU-Auslastung nachgucken, oder?
Ja gut, CPU...
Also wenn er darauf jetzt einsteigt, okay, CPU-Auslastung kannst du natürlich auch anderweitig nachgucken.
Ja, es gibt für vieles grafische Alternativen, aber unter Linux funktioniert das meiste besser und einfacher wie übers Terminal.
Ja, und spätestens.
Da stimme ich zu.
Einfacher und besser schon, weil es schneller geht.
Einfacher...
Kommt...
Liegt immer im Auge des Betrachters.
Das stimmt, das stimmt.
Ich würde ihm dazu stimmen, weil wenn man es einmal weiß, weiß man es, wie es auf allen Distros geht.
Bei den Oberflächen sucht man sich dann doch manchmal den Wurm.
Aber das kommt darauf an.
Also ich kann vollkommen verstehen, wenn Nutzer nicht das Terminal erlernen wollen.
Und ich habe auch ganz, ganz viele Nutzer, die ich betreue, die nicht das Terminal erlernt haben und es auch nicht wollen.
Dann verpassen sie halt einen der größten Vorteile von Linux.
Und das muss man...
Na gut.
Kann man so nicht sagen.
Ja, je nachdem, auf was sie Wert legen.
Aber es fehlt schon ein beträchtlicher Teil, der das System so gut macht.
Nicht unter Linux.
Sobald mal irgendwas nicht funktioniert.
Außer du willst deinen Rechner teilweise selber administrieren oder hast einen blöden...
Ja, natürlich, jeder will seinen Rechner selbst administrieren.
Wie gesagt, es sei denn die Oma, der ihr was einrichtet.
Die Leute installieren den Kram selbst, administrieren das selbst und benutzen es auch selbst.
Druckertreiber zu installieren, dann kommst du da nicht rum.
Aber auch selbst das bekommt man dann ganz gut.
Hinten durch YouTube-Tutorials oder sowas in die Richtung.
Das geht dann schon.
Wie erwartet.
Ja, dann ist das Erste, was man macht.
Terminal auf, Arch-Linux-Wiki öffnen und nach dem How-To gucken.
Und dann ist Kommandozeile angesagt.
Ob man will oder nicht.
Das ist für mich persönlich, als ehemaliger Linux-Administrator, zumindest von meiner Ausbildung her, beim Provider noch,
das ist für mich ein Riesenvorteil.
Für viele Leute und gerade für viele Windows-Umsteiger ist das Steinzeitgefühl und Nachteil.
Also das muss man sich tatsächlich...
Vor allen Dingen, weil das auf Englisch ist, auch nochmal zusätzlich für viele.
Und sehr kryptisch beschrieben ist.
Ja, also du hast schon viele...
Module und Konzepte unter Linux, die du unter Windows nicht hast und nicht kennst.
Und sich da einzuarbeiten...
Was er redet halt aus Sichtperspektive als Firmen...
Man hilft Firmen dabei...
Ja gut, aber mein Video ist ja eindeutig jetzt Linux auf dem Desktop für Leute, die daheim von Windows umsteigen wollen.
Außerdem würde ich auch sagen, Dance-Game-OS auf Deutsch gestellt.
Anfang Buch mit sieben Siegeln.
Also mir ging es...
Ich kann mich an meine Anfangszeit erinnern.
Ich wusste nicht, wo hinten und vorne ist.
Mittlerweile, so langsam kann ich euch sagen,
irgendwann blickt es.
Dann blickt man durch.
So ein bisschen wenigstens.
Also wer Linux komplett durchsteigt, jede einzelne Ecke, das ist schon sehr bemerkenswert.
Na gut, das mache ich auch nicht.
Ich glaube, da gibt es niemanden, der an jeder Ecke wirklich komplett durchsteigt.
Ich meine, ich würde sagen, ich kenne mich jetzt ganz okay aus.
Aber durchsteigen an jeder Ecke?
Nee, nee, nee, nee.
Auf gar keinen Fall.
Ich glaube, das schafft auch keiner mehr.
Nee.
Tatsächlich abschminken, da muss man sich drauf...
Braucht man aber auch nicht, bin ich ehrlich.
Einlassen.
Und das...
Wichtig ist, den Überblick zu behalten.
Und?
Und so ab fünf Jahren aufwärts schafft man das dann schon, Linux-Benutzung,
wenn man sich so ein bisschen mit der Administration beschäftigt hat.
Und das wird euch auch jeder mit etwas Linux-Erfahrung sagen.
Ihr könnt ja mal in die Kommentare schreiben, vielleicht, wenn ihr Leute seid,
die Linux selbst schon länger verwenden, wie ihr das seht.
Linux-Terminal und Shell, kommt man dran vorbei oder nicht?
Also ich bin der Meinung...
Ja, habe ich schon vorhin beantwortet.
Als Endanwender kommst du auch gerne...
Nee, du, danke schön für den Sub.
Zur Administration wird es echt schwierig teilweise.
Wie gesagt, ich bin der Ansicht, im Heimbereich ist der Admin und der Endanwender...
Endanwender hat das Gleiche.
Je früher man sich...
Wobei tatsächlich Linux Mint das versucht, so am besten wie möglich das Terminal zu vermeiden.
Also durch die Aktualisierungsverwaltung, durch die Kernel-Installation in Vida...
Ja, ich habe schon festgestellt,
Vmware-Tools geht nur über Kommandozeile zu installieren.
Auch unter Linux Mint.
...Treiber-Installation, Druckertreiber ist...
Okay, wahrscheinlich über Synaptic oder irgendwie sowas wäre es wahrscheinlich aufgegangen.
...tief einfach gehalten.
Man schafft echt viel ohne Terminal.
Und das wird auch immer mal wieder, ich sag mal,
von anderen Linux-Usern ausgeblendet, dass es da fast manche Distros gibt,
die es komplett ohne Terminal eigentlich schaffen.
Kommt drauf an, wenn du einen ganz blöden Druckertreiber hast,
den du selber manuell installieren musst.
Wie gesagt, das Terminal ist ja nicht der Feind.
Ich finde das gar nicht so wild, wenn man da hin muss.
Das sollte man sich einfach eben als User überlegen,
dass das ein wichtiger Teil vom System ist.
Man kann aber nicht so richtig das Linux was dafür,
da können eher die Hersteller was dafür.
Ansonsten Linux...
...kann das schon ganz gut mittlerweile.
Und ich habe einen ganzen Anwenderkurs, also ganz kurz hier.
...Linux mit Kurs für Anwender.
Wir werden niemals den Terminal öffnen in diesem Kurs und danach kannst du Linux...
Ich weiß nicht, ich weiß nicht, ob das so eine gute Idee ist.
...richtig gut verwenden und sogar auch in Richtung Administrierung reinschauen.
Also schauen wir hier einfach mal rein, Ausdruck aus dem Inhaltsverzeichnis.
Sehr gerne hier mal reinschauen.
Da ist ganz schön viel drin.
Wir werden an keiner Stelle den Terminal verwenden.
Und das ist eigentlich sehr, sehr stark.
Also es funktioniert.
Nur wissen das die meisten Linux-User gar nicht.
Klar, weil es ja immer den...
Ja klar, ich will gar nicht bezweifeln, dass man vieles machen kann.
Auch...
Ich weiß nicht.
Also...
...da macht man sich das Leben doch schwerer als es ist.
Man muss es doch nicht verkomplizieren, oder?
Wenn man...
Wenn man doch schon so ein System benutzt, was eben eine super Command-Line-Umgebung hat,
dann sollte man den Leuten doch vielleicht auch eher erklären, so nach dem Motto,
ey, ihr müsst da keine Angst vor haben, das hat nix mit diesem Crap von Windows zu tun,
sondern das ist eigentlich ganz gut.
In Terminal nutzen.
Ja, okay.
Und von daher haben wir hier wieder ein Henne-Ei-Problem.
Aber es funktioniert.
Das möchte ich hier vielleicht nochmal ganz klar sagen.
Natürlich, letztendlich unterm Strich funktionieren tut vieles.
Ich kann auch Textdateien nur mit Seed bearbeiten.
Also man kann vieles machen, was irgendwie dann auch funktioniert.
Ich kann auch nur mit Hex-Editor programmieren.
Administration selber kann manchmal schwieriger sein.
Aber als Anwendereien absolut kein Problem.
Auch bei komplizierteren Sachen.
Genau.
Umso früher man sich damit auseinandersetzt, umso besser.
Allein schon für das eigene Wohlergehen.
...mit ordentlichen Terminals und ordentlichen Shells kommt.
Aber viel...
Ganz klar.
Aber ich glaube, Linux passiert.
Auch darauf.
Also Linux baut ja darauf auf.
Also du schaffst ja...
Hast ja früher nichts geschafft ohne das Terminal.
Und ganz klar nimmst du das natürlich dann weiter.
Und du hast immer so eine Grundlage, so eine Unterlage.
Beispielsweise plane ich jetzt nächste Woche einen kleinen Code-Marathon.
Ja, aber das ist auch ein Unterschied, Chad.
Windows ist in der Regel quasi erstmal UI-mäßig first.
Auch wenn es nicht so aussieht.
Ja.
Und so Sachen wie PowerShell und sowas gibt es ja auch noch nicht.
Klar, PowerShell selbst gibt es schon eine ganze Weile.
Aber so dieses Windows ordentlich zu administrieren auf CLI kann ich verstehen.
Ich würde das auch nicht wollen, weil es eklig ist.
Es ist erst die letzten paar Jahre halbwegs erträglich geworden.
Mit am Anfang PowerShell und jetzt WSL davor.
Kein Wunder, dass sie das nicht wollten.
Weil es ist halt...
Es sackt halt.
Indem ich hier so ein Programm programmiere,
womit man Rechnungen relativ einfach erstellen kann.
Und dort ist...
Der Rechnungs-Champ.
...eine Shell-Integration.
...eine Shell-Implementierung eingeplant,
damit man das über die Bash oder über Disk Terminal öffnen kann
und bedienen kann, dass man das in Skripts einbauen kann besser.
Das sind auch riesen, riesen Vorteile, die du hast unter Linux,
die du unter Windows so gar nicht hast mit den Skripts.
Ja, Ezekar, wenn du das administrierst für die
und die dann nur noch im Browser klicken musst,
und das ist ja was anderes.
Das ist ja aber auch überhaupt nicht die User, von denen ich rede.
Ich rede von Usern wie du und ich,
die sagen, okay,
es gibt ein paar Sachen, die mir unter Windows auf Kicks gehen.
Ich probiere mal Linux aus.
Das heißt, du bist Administrator und Endanwender in einem,
was die meisten Leute so im Heimbereich eben auch sind.
Die wenigsten haben jemanden, der für sie das administriert
und sie es dann nur benutzen würden.
Nur benutzen werden.
Du kannst zwar auch ein bisschen Batch-Skripten,
aber ich glaube, das hört da relativ zügig auf.
Bei Linux kannst du alles in solche Skripts packen.
Das ist der Unterschied.
Musst du aber nicht.
Viele Leute können es halt nicht leiden.
Das heißt, wer Abneigung gegen Terminals hat,
so prinzipiell und sich auch nicht darauf einleisten will,
der wird unter Linux auf gar keinen Fall glücklich.
Da stimmt er nicht zu.
Da gehe ich ganz von aus.
Weil wenn er einen Kurs anbietet ohne Terminal und so,
das wird er nicht sehen.
Ich sehe es weiterhin so.
Also da stehe ich tatsächlich komplett dagegen.
Wusste ich, wusste ich.
Ich würde auf jeden Fall sagen,
dass du auch so glücklich werden wirst.
Vorausgesetzt, du hast jemanden,
der dir irgendwann mal unter die Arme greift.
Okay, ja.
Wenn du, okay.
Hey, hey.
Wenn du einen Support-Dude hast,
den du fragen kannst, wenn es nicht funktioniert,
der macht es dann für dich.
Okay.
Ja, aber das ist ja nicht der Fall, von dem ich ausgehe.
Das muss man leider schon sagen.
Aber ansonsten ist es schwierig.
Da stimme ich schon zu.
Aber als Anwender, als reiner Anwender,
das kriegst du gut hin.
Du brauchst nur einen Verwandten oder einen Bekannten.
Es gibt ganz viele Linux-User-Groups,
die helfen alle.
Auch kostenlos.
Die sind froh, wenn sie ein paar Leuten helfen können.
Tatsächlich sind immer nette Gespräche.
Und ja, also kann ich euch nur empfehlen,
dann zu sich.
Ich empfehle das Freenas-Forum.
Da bekommt man immer besonders nette Antworten.
Oder alternativ das Microcontroller-Forum.
Da bekommt man auch immer so nette Antworten.
Okay, hat jetzt mit Linux nichts zu tun.
Es gibt schon echt nervige Ecken im Internet,
um nach Hilfe zu fragen.
Aber das Ubuntu-Users-Forum ist gut.
Da kann man fragen.
Das Arch-Wiki ist super Geschichte,
nicht nur für Arch-User.
Auch, auch,
ähm,
äh, wenn du auf, auf Reddit guckst,
äh, Gaming und das Gaming on Linux Subreddit
ist ziemlich gut.
Okay, ich sehe, ich bin nicht der Einzige,
der schon tolle Erfahrungen mit diesem Forum gemacht hat, ja.
Ich hab nie, ich hab nie in diesem Forum gepostet.
Ich stolpere immer nur manchmal über die Foreneinträge,
weil ich irgendwelche Probleme google.
Und dann komme ich auf einen Foreneintrag
von Microcontroller raus
und stelle immer fest,
wie voller Spasten dieses Forum überhaupt ist.
Ey, ich würde mich da im Leben nicht anmelden.
Ähm, ja.
Ah, Freenas, das Freenas-Forum war ähnlich kacke früher.
So nach dem Motto, irgendjemand, äh, hat sich daheim, äh, was zusammengebaut,
keine Ahnung, äh, äh, zwei 10T-Platten,
eine SSD reingepackt,
irgend so eine Low-Power-Intel-Kiste,
3, 400 Euro vielleicht, ja, und sagt jetzt,
okay, er hat, äh, eine Frage, wie soll er am besten ZFS,
keine Ahnung, welches Rate-Level soll er verwenden.
Und da kommen, genau,
und da kommen die Leute an, so nach dem Motto,
oh, du hast ja nicht mal ECC-RAM drinne.
Und, und, und flamen ihn dann über drei Seiten,
dass er keinen ECC-RAM drinne hat.
Das ist komplett unsinnig.
Oder dass er nicht irgendwie, ähm, 500 Gigabyte RAM pro Terabyte,
äh, nee, oder was ist so die, was ist so die Regel?
Ein Gigabyte pro Terabyte?
Ein Gigabyte RAM pro Terabyte-Disk?
Irgendwie sowas.
Ähm, vollkommen in Ordnung,
wenn man das empfiehlt, wenn er das jetzt beispielsweise
in so einer Small-Business-Office-Umgebung einsetzen möchte.
Das ist, das ist ja durchaus in Ordnung, das dann zu raten.
Aber das so als die ultimative Wahrheit hinzustellen,
du kannst das ohne nicht betreiben, ist kompletter Schwachsinn.
Selbstverständlich kannst du ZFS ohne ECC-RAM benutzen.
Selbstverständlich kannst du ZFS im Heimbereich auch benutzen
ohne ein Gigabyte RAM pro Terabyte-Storage.
Ja, und, also, so, weiter.
...lokalen Linux-Gruppen zu gehen, wenn ihr da Probleme oder Fragen habt.
Nächster Punkt ist, überlegt euch mal, ob's die Software, die ihr verwendet,
so täglich, ob's die auch unter Linux gibt.
Ja.
Und wenn nicht, ob ihr bereit seid, euch nach Alternativen umzugucken,
wenn vorhanden, oder was komplett Neues zu lernen, oder vielleicht auch drauf zu verzichten.
Ich denke mal, die meisten von euch, oder die meisten Windows-Umsteiger,
sind jetzt nicht so die richtig krassen Power-User, ähm,
aber sie sind auch keine Oma, die nur Surft und E-Mails anguckt.
Die meisten Leute sind so ein bisschen was dazwischen.
Ja, keine krassen Hackermans, aber auch keine, keine totalen, sowas dazwischen.
Das heißt ja, durchschnittliche Windows...
Moin, Michael, fünf Spieljahren.
Also, ich glaub, ihr wählt darauf hinaus, ähm, Programme-Kompatibilität.
Und ich muss sagen, ähm, wenn du Garmin-Geräte hast,
da krieg ich immer, ähm, immer mal wieder Anfragen,
das funktioniert nicht.
Wenn du Photoshop nutzen willst, mit der Adobe Creative Cloud,
lass es lieber.
Funktioniert, ja.
Ähm, aber ansonsten kommst du so eigentlich ziemlich gut mit dem Linux rum.
Es ist genau das, was ich gesagt hab.
Du musst im Zweifelsfall auch, äh, bereit sein, dich nach Alternativen,
um zu gucken, ja.
Zum Beispiel, ich verwende ganz gern hier Affinity Designer,
um meine YouTube-Thumbnails zu machen, wenn ich's nicht outsource,
die YouTube-Thumbnails.
Und soweit ich weiß, funktioniert Affinity Designer auch null,
gar nicht unter Linux.
Und, äh, Sony Vegas beispielsweise, wenn man sich daran gewöhnt hat,
wie es funktioniert, auch nicht gescheit unter Linux.
Das sind halt so Dinger, ja, da, man findet sicherlich unter Linux
Alternativen, die man verwenden kann, ja.
Beispielsweise DaVinci Resolve für alle, die so, so, rundum Schlagvideos,
Bearbeitung, Editing-Geschichte brauchen für Video-Audio-Effekte.
Keine Frage, aber es ist nicht das Gleiche, was man kennt unter, unter Windows.
Das heißt, man muss genau das machen, weil ich gesagt hab,
man muss bereit sein, sich nach Alternativen umzugucken
und dann sich auch, äh, die Zeit, die Zeit nehmen, in was Neues einzuarbeiten.
Moment, was ist ziemlich gut?
Darm-Tablet?
Heißt das wirklich, ach, Dark-Tablet.
Ich wollt grad sagen, was zum Teufel, wo ist das Tablet im...
Dark-Tablet, das hab ich schon mal gesehen.
Das hab ich schon mal gesehen.
Ja, ja, wie gesagt, es gibt Alternativen, aber das ist ja genau das,
was ich in dem Video, was ich in dem Video sagen will.
Du musst dich halt dann auch daran gewöhnen, dass du vielleicht dich in Alternativen einarbeiten musst, ja.
Ist halt so.
Tatsächlich in meinem Linux-Arbeitsplatz-Konzept, ähm,
gibt's eine Kompatibilitätsschicht.
Damit schaffst du tatsächlich, ähm, auch mal ne Windows-App auszuführen, wenn du...
Ja, geil, ne Windows-VM starten. Ja, super.
Ich sag mal, dass man brauchst. Fürs Gaming-Gerät reicht das beispielsweise
und für andere Apps dann auch in der Hinsicht, die du dann immer mal wieder brauchst,
wenn du dann, ähm, deine App hast, mit der du 10 Stunden am Tag arbeiten musst,
um deine Brötchen zu verdienen, ähm, und die nicht unter Linux gescheit läuft,
dann kann man mal drüber überlegen, ob das Sinn macht, natürlich auf Linux zu wechseln.
Aber wenn du nun mal gelegentlich so ein gewisses Windows-Programm brauchst,
reicht das über die Kompatibilitätsschicht absolut aus, ne.
Kompatibilitätsschicht, das ist ne Windows-VM.
Stichwort Maschine, relativ gut integriert in den Linux-Desktop.
Ja, der benutzt sowas wie den Epic Store für Games, Steam, GOG.
Gaming ist ne andere Sache. Da wirst du eigentlich ein Dual-Boot-System brauchen.
Ja.
Das heißt, du, ähm, lässt Windows für Spiele laufen.
Und daneben installierst du Linux, was du dann für deine anderen Sachen verwendest.
Oder, man macht so wie ich, man lässt Windows drauf und verwendet Linux in der VM ohne Dual-Boot.
Und hat quasi kaum, äh, wie soll man sagen, äh, Nachteile durch Linux in der VM.
Aber du hast die Vorteile von, ähm, dem Native Windows.
Und du kannst ja auch was Performance-mäßig unter der Linux-VM.
Also, die hau-, ist ja hauptsächlich CPU-Performance.
Und hab ich schon oft genug gesagt, CPU-Performance ist ja in der VM und auf dem Host kein sonderlich großer Unterschied.
Das funktioniert wunderbar.
Vielleicht Adobe Creative Cloud Abo, will ab und zu mal sein iPhone.
Ja, Adobe, ist klar.
Oder sein Android-Synchen oder da Bilder-Backup-Bilder.
Ja, bei iPhone und Android-Synchen müsste, glaub ich, ganz gut funktionieren.
iPhone hab...
Ja, das funktioniert auch.
Das, das funktioniert auch.
Das funktioniert, ich hab das letztens erst gemacht.
Ich hab mit, ähm, aber halt auch hier...
Aber halt auch hier extra Packages, Terminal, ja.
Äh, iFuse, äh, das da.
Er ist letztens wieder installiert.
Da kannst du dein komplettes iPhone mit mounten.
Und dann Backup ziehen.
Allerdings, worauf ich eigentlich raus wollte, ist, dass du keine iTunes verwenden kannst und solche Geschichten.
Hab ich selber selten gemacht, müsste aber, denk ich, auch klappen.
Will da rauf und runter schieben, irgendwelche Sachen draufziehen.
Ähm, der will seinen neuesten Fitness-Tracker anschließen.
Vielleicht synken mit der App oder irgendwelche...
Fitness-Tracker an den PC anschließen?
Crazy, dass es sowas gibt.
Also, ich denk immer, dass...
War jetzt mal ein Beispiel.
Schreibt mir gerne, wenn ihr da irgendwie etwas auf dem PC habt für euren Fitness-Tracker.
Auswertung von seinen Fitness-Daten in der Cloud machen.
Er will vielleicht mit irgendeiner etwas älteren...
Aber Cloud ist ja kein Problem, das sind die Web-Anwendungen.
Da vielleicht nochmal später einen ganz großen Punkt auch nochmal zu.
Äh, Elgato Game Capture, was aufnehmen.
Ja, also nicht die Oma, die nur surft.
Aber halt auch nicht der krasse Hacker, mein Power-User.
Äh, übrigens, ich muss sagen, die neuen Elgatos funktionieren unter Linux.
Die alte Elgato funktioniert seit Jahren schon nicht und wird es wahrscheinlich auch nie.
Ähm, woran auch immer das liegt, ich weiß es nicht.
Vielleicht daran, weil die nen...
Hardware-Encoder hat und da irgendwie komische Dinge über USB macht.
Keine Ahnung.
Das ist so das, was ich mir vorstelle, was so normale Windows-User machen.
Ja, ihr könnt ja mal in die Kommentare schreiben, was ihr so macht unter Windows.
Aber so ungefähr stell ich mir den normalen Windows-User vor.
Und da ist es halt so.
Also, es gibt viele Alternativen mittlerweile unter Linux.
Auch, ähm, was Audio- und Video-Editing betrifft, hat sich vieles getan.
Die letzten Jahre mit Sachen wie DaVinci Resolve zum Beispiel.
Also, da hat sich schon einiges getan.
Und auch Streaming geht dank OBS mittlerweile unter Linux ganz gut.
Ja.
Ja, man muss sich halt im Zweifelsfall drauf einlassen auf die Software, die es da gibt.
Ähm, das ist...
Das ist eigentlich die Kernaussage, die ich da sagen würde.
Ja, man muss halt im Zweifelsfall auch gucken und was Neues lernen.
Und dann dementsprechend auch Zeit und Lernaufwand reinstecken oder bereit sein, die reinzustecken.
Ja, genau.
Wenn es eben die altbekannte Software nicht unter Linux gibt, sich was Neues zu suchen.
Also, ähm, es gibt sehr, sehr viel Alternativ-Software.
Du wirst aber selten genau das Pendant, ähm, oder genau die gleiche Software natürlich finden unter Linux.
Ähm, außer du nutzt natürlich schon freie Software unter Windows.
Das ist erstaunlich viel, wenn ich mal nach kostenloser Software für Windows suche.
Ja, das stimmt schon.
Also, die meisten Open-Source-Projekte, was zumindest da mal so irgendwelche grafischen Tools angeht, da gibt es ja vieles.
Ja, ich würde sogar sagen, fast die meisten gibt es dann für...
Kommt ein bisschen drauf an, auf was die basieren.
Aber offensichtlich...
Oftmals gibt es sie für Mac, Linux, Windows.
Oder zumindest für Linux und Windows.
Nicht lange suchen, bis ich keine gute, freie Open-Source-App finde.
Also, in diesen ganzen Downloadlisten.
Wollte ich für verschiedene Tutorials mal so richtig verwenden, habe ich nie gute Beispiele gefunden.
Das ist, das ist unglaublich.
Ähm, also von daher, wahrscheinlich nutzt ihr ja schon einiges auch in Open-Source-Software.
Und ansonsten, klar, ein bisschen Umstellung ist mit dabei.
Einfach zu lernen, wie die anderen Apps funktionieren.
Das geht aber relativ...
Zügig, würde ich mal sagen.
Gut, jetzt bin ich natürlich technisch ein bisschen affin.
Aber ich denke, auch so der normale Nutzer kriegt das ganz gut hin.
Na, aber in der Hinsicht würde ich auch wieder sagen, steigt Schritt für Schritt um.
Installiert euch Linux immer neben Windows erstmal.
Und lernt das dann so parallel dazu.
Am besten in der VM.
Und dann, wenn ihr euch...
Ich bin kein Dual-Boot-Fan.
Okay, jetzt starte ich mein Windows wirklich schon lange nicht mehr.
Dann kann man es immer noch runterschmeißen.
Aber davor lasst das bitte unbedingt drauf.
Weil sonst...
Weil sonst, wenn irgendwas nicht funktioniert oder ihr euch mal irgendwo nicht auskennt,
ihr aber genau wüsstet, wie das unter Windows geht,
dann ist der Frust groß, wenn ihr es dann gerade unter Linux hinbekommen müsst zu diesem Zeitpunkt.
Vor allem, wenn ihr unter Zeitdruck steht.
Dann ist eigentlich...
Dann wird geflamed.
Da wird ein Grabstein für Linux vor euch gesetzt.
Von daher, versucht das erstmal parallel zu betreiben.
Und dann am Ende zu entscheiden, okay, in welche Richtung gehe ich.
Und ich denke, das wird die meisten betreffen.
Jetzt gibt es natürlich welche, die vielleicht ein bisschen Ahnung von Linux haben und sagen, ja gut.
Aber was ist denn so mit Wine und was ist denn so mit Proton?
Nun ja.
Man kann Windows-Software und Spiele zum Teil auch ohne offizielle Unterstützung zum Laufen bekommen.
Mit Wine oder Proton.
Es hat sich unglaublich viel getan in dieser Richtung.
Es gibt Launcher wie Ludwigs, die das Spiel viel viel einfacher machen.
Ludwigs?
Die Untertitel...
Unterstützung zum Laufen kommen mit Wine oder Proton?
Es hat sich unglaublich viel getan in dieser Richtung.
Es gibt Launcher wie Ludwigs...
Es gibt Launcher wie Ludwigs, alles klar.
Ludwigs Launcher, kennt ihr den nicht?
Ganz bekannt.
Viel viel einfacher machen.
Das Setup auch unter Linux viel einfacher machen als früher.
Über Steam sieht man zum Glück mittlerweile auch alles, was native direkt supported wird unter Linux.
Das heißt, wenigstens da kann man sich sicher sein, wenn man da was kauft, das ist okay, das wird wahrscheinlich funktionieren.
Für alle anderen Sachen gibt es halt sowas wie Wine und Proton.
Also sprich, wo Teile von Windows nachgebaut wurden und die Software bzw. die Spiele quasi gar nicht merkt, dass sie denn jetzt unter Linux läuft.
Das ist alles schön und gut.
Und es geht auch wirklich.
Ich kenne die Entwicklung, wie gesagt, der letzten 15 Jahre.
Und ich muss auch sagen, es geht wirklich beeindruckend viel mittlerweile.
Absolut.
Also...
Im Gegensatz von vor 5 Jahren, das ist unglaublich, was sich da getan hat.
Generell in der Linux-Welt.
Also, es ist unglaublich, was sich da technologisch in den letzten 5 Jahren allein getan hat.
Hätte ich nicht für möglich.
Das haben wir tatsächlich auch vieles Valve zu verdanken, die halt schon...
Gaben war ja noch nie großer Windows-Fan.
Da hat sich einiges getan.
Und da sieht man mal wieder, ein bisschen Koordination bei solchen Bemühungen und Geld im Hintergrund macht halt...
Gaben Klepp macht halt einiges aus.
Ich bin gespannt auf die nächsten 5 Jahre.
Ich weiß, ich weiß.
Der war ursprünglich...
Ursprünglich war er aber bei Microsoft.
Hat er nicht sogar Valve gegründet mit dem, was er mit Microsoft-Aktien verdient hat?
Aber er ist schon lange kein großer Windows-Fan.
Hat er auch schon öfters gesagt.
Im Vergleich zu früher.
Man muss dann nur mal auf ProtonDB oder WineHQ werfen.
Da gibt es wirklich viel, was funktioniert.
Aber es geht auf vieles nichts.
Das heißt, eine Sache, was mit Sicherheit viele Leute wollen, wenn sie ihren Desktop-PC benutzen, ist...
Ja.
Wie Steam oder GOG.
Bei GOG bin ich mir übrigens gar nicht sicher, ob es da mittlerweile...
Bei Gott bin ich mir nicht sicher.
Gute Frage.
Müssen wir mal nachgucken.
Also, es gibt da einen ganz guten Heroic-Games-Launcher.
Kann das sehr, sehr gut.
Ja.
Die Subtitel sind komplett lost.
Oder Epic Store oder sowas.
Die Leute wollen das starten, sich ein Game raussuchen, Game kaufen, Play drücken und los geht's.
Ja, aber, ne?
In puncto Spielen haben wir schon gesagt, werdet ihr unter Linux eventuell nicht glücklich.
Das muss man ganz klar sagen.
Ist ganz klar.
Ja.
Jetzt ist halt die Frage, geht's denn los?
Man weiß es nicht so genau.
Die Chancen sind ganz okay, dass es läuft.
Aber genauso, dass es nicht läuft.
Oder dass man ja längere Zeit mal googeln muss, dass man irgendwelche Tweaks findet oder irgendwelche Hacks.
Richtig.
Also, vergisst es einfach.
Na, außer ihr seid wirklich dann so stark und könnt auf das eine oder andere Spiel verzichten.
Ich muss sagen, man kann Stunden, ja hunderte Tage lang Stunden und so weiter, schon Spaß haben mit Spielen unter Linux.
Also, das ist jetzt nicht, dass nichts funktioniert, aber wenn ihr ein Deepings-Spiel habt und das nicht unter...
Es ist gar nicht mal so sehr das Lieblingsspiel.
Ja, das ist sicherlich auch was.
Klar, da kann Leute den ganzen Tag Fortnite criten wollen.
Es ist auch eher so diese Sache mit, es kommt ein neues Game raus, was man spielen will.
Und normalerweise denkt man halt, okay, man kauft das im Store, drückt auf Play und es funktioniert.
Ja, die Chancen sind so ganz okay, dass es funktioniert.
Aber es kann auch genauso sein, dass es nicht funktioniert.
Und das ist halt das Ding.
Du kannst dich nicht wirklich darauf verlassen, was du ja eigentlich willst, wenn du ein Spiel kaufst.
Dass du dir darauf sicher bist, okay, geht jetzt.
Man könnte jetzt natürlich argumentieren und sagen, okay, die Spiele sind in den letzten Jahren so kacke geworden bei AAA-Releases,
dass es auch unter Windows nicht mehr richtig funktioniert.
Okay, das ist so.
Aber dann unter Linux ganz erst recht nicht.
Unter Linux funktioniert, dann seid ihr natürlich aufgeschmissen.
Ansonsten sowas wie CSGO, Dota, alles mögliche.
Ich habe mal ein ganzes Video zu Gaming gemacht.
Da funktioniert schon erstaunlich viel, muss man sagen.
Also, das ist schon unglaublich.
Die Hacks, dass es doch vielleicht geht.
Oder vielleicht muss man auch ein paar Wochen nach Release warten, bis es irgendwelche Patches gibt.
Also, sprich, neue Software und vor allem neue Games sind eine kleine Zitterpartie.
So, das einfache Starten des Launchers, Kaufen, Anklicken, Spielen, wenn es nicht gerade direkt unter Linux unterstützt wird, ist halt nicht.
Aber es ist extrem besser geworden.
Das stimmt, ja, sag ich dir auch.
Ich schätze mal so 80 bis 90 Prozent der Spiele funktionieren unter Linux.
Von den AAA-Spielen.
Ja, aber es gibt halt ganz...
Also, wenn man sich mal anguckt, 80 bis 90 der Spiele in...
Summe lasse ich mir vielleicht noch gefallen, wobei das wahrscheinlich auch schon ein bisschen hochgegriffen ist.
Aber okay, sagen wir mal 80 Prozent.
Aber wenn man das jetzt mal nicht anhand der Menge der Spiele bewertet, sondern mal nach den Spielen, die viel gespielt werden.
Was unter anderem so Sachen sind wie Fortnite, Warzone, Rainbow Six, CS...
Wobei, CS geht ja mittlerweile.
Und solche Dinge.
Da ist halt wieder...
Sind die Sachen, die Millionen an Leuten spielen und die gehen halt nicht.
Funktionieren.
Die hören viele Linux-User nicht gern, aber was soll ich sagen?
Es ist halt so.
Ich persönlich würde mich freuen, wenn ich heute Windows komplett in die Tonne kloppen könnte.
Ist so, ist so, ja.
Und die Sache aber auch so benennen könnte.
Es ist halt einfach so.
Anti-Cheat ist auch so ein Reizthema.
Ja, also Anti-Cheat ist ganz klar.
Aber ansonsten meint er, ja, er braucht noch unbedingt ein Windows.
Das finde ich sehr, sehr stark.
Vor allen Dingen, weil er schon 15 Jahre Linux...
Ich brauche ein Windows.
Naja, ich habe es ja schon.
Ich brauche für meine Videos Sachen Windows.
Ich brauche für die Streaming-Gaming-Sachen Windows.
Ich brauche an ganz vielen Fällen Windows.
Windows, deswegen mache ich es ja auch so, wie ich es mache.
Linux hier auf dem zweiten Desktop in der VM und Windows als Host-System.
Das ist für mich persönlich und das ist das, worum es ja geht.
Man muss was finden, was für sich gut funktioniert.
Ist das die beste Lösung?
Das heißt nicht, dass es unbedingt für euch die beste Lösung ist.
Es ist eine Lösung, die ich empfehlen kann, es so zu machen,
wenn eure Anwendungs-Sachen, also wie soll man sagen,
euer Anwendungsprofil ähnlich ist zu meinem.
Also ich hätte überhaupt keinen Bock auf Dual-Boot.
Also entweder er spielt halt irgendwelche Spiele sehr, sehr, sehr gerne.
Das...
Das ist natürlich dann klar, dann braucht er das.
Wahrscheinlich ist es so, dass er das so anspricht.
Aber ansonsten bin ich tatsächlich...
Nein, wir haben keinen Chat eingeplantet,
weil der Chat sonst direkt bei ihm über dem Kopf wäre.
Nicht auf Windows gebunden.
Das Einzige, was ich mal gebraucht habe,
ist vor, ich glaube, zwei, drei Jahren mal ganz kurz PowerPoint.
Wegen einer ganz bestimmten...
Kann man mittlerweile glücklicherweise auch im Browser machen.
...in der virtuellen Maschine gelöst.
Und ich glaube auch vor zwei, drei Jahren einmal,
um ein Handy zu entsperren,
was bestimmte Windows-Software gebraucht hat,
habe ich auch über die virtuelle Maschine gelöst.
Ansonsten habe ich seit, ich meine, über fünf Jahren
kein Windows mehr auf dem Laufraum.
Ey, würde ich auch gerne machen.
Da hätte ich gar keine Schmerzen mit.
Ich bin aber zu faul, mir Alternativen...
Im Prinzip das zu machen, was ich am Anfang angesprochen habe.
Mir für die ganzen Programme, in die ich mich eingearbeitet habe,
Alternativen zu suchen.
Und halt das Thema Gaming ist mir halt auch zu wichtig,
dass ich sage würde,
ja, nö, lass ich bleiben.
Ich meine, ich kann den ganzen Tag Supertox-Kart spielen.
Okay.
Nein, installiert.
Ich glaube, es ist sogar schon länger.
Ich glaube, seit 2016 habe ich kein Windows mehr.
Das sind auch schon geschmeidige sieben Jahre tatsächlich.
Ordentlich.
Braucht man nicht unbedingt.
Aber ich bin sehr gespannt.
Klar, wenn du Spiele spielst, ist klar.
Valve, also der Valve-Anti-Cheat,
ist ja mittlerweile ganz gut unterstützt unter Linux.
Sachen wie Battle.i haben da auch ziemliche Fortschritte gemacht.
Aber es gibt genauso viel, was nicht funktioniert.
Rainbow Six, keine Chance.
Fortnite, keine Chance.
Valorant, keine Chance.
Absolut.
Da gibt es nichts.
Sachen wie Witcher 3 oder ein bisschen ältere Singleplayer-Spiele,
die laufen wiederum nahezu perfekt.
Oder zumindest durchspielbar.
Also je nachdem, was ihr spielen wollt, ist das möglich.
Aber bei vielem eben auch nicht.
Und wenn was nicht geht,
und wenn ihr vielleicht irgendwie ein How-To findet,
wie es doch gehen könnte,
seid ihr erstens viel mit Basteln beschäftigt,
Linux lernen will, weil wir wirklich Linux verwenden.
Ich spule mal ein bisschen vor, wenn ich spiele.
Der muss ins Terminal.
Früher oder später führt kein Milch dran vorbei.
Das Gute ist, 2022,
viele Leute benutzen heute einen Browser
für 90 Prozent ihrer Sachen, was sie machen.
Genau, also hier spricht es auch schon an.
Ich denke, er geht darauf hinaus,
dass die Web-Apps immer mehr ins Kommen sind.
Das heißt, du hast immer weniger Windows-Software wirklich,
sondern es läuft immer mehr im Web-Browser.
Und das sieht man eigentlich überall.
Und das kommt natürlich der Linux-Welt auch sehr gelegen.
Das ist so.
Da läuft alles an Web-Browsern.
Und von daher kommst du natürlich da auch ganz gut
dann an die jeweiligen Programme,
die halt im Internet laufen.
Beispielsweise für die Animation,
für Videos und für,
ähm, ähm, Thumbnail-Erstellungen nutze ich mittlerweile Canva im Web, ne?
Ist leider nicht Open Source.
Das kenne ich.
Das ist ganz, ganz nett für so Thumbnail-Sachen und sowas, ja.
Vor allem, weil es halt viele Vorlagen hat.
So aus bin ich ganz ehrlich.
Ist aber für mich vom Workflow her um einiges noch mal produktiver, ne?
Heißt ja auch nicht,
ich weiß, da sind viele so ein bisschen so auf dem Kreuzsucher unterwegs.
Das heißt jetzt ja auch nicht,
dass wenn man Linux verwendet,
dass man nur noch Open Source und freie Software einsetzen muss.
Also,
gerade wenn man irgendeinen Web-Service hat,
der einem viel Arbeit abnimmt oder was einem gefällt,
spricht da überhaupt nichts dagegen, das zu verwenden.
Ich weiß,
allow me to interject for a moment.
Jetzt kommt wieder irgendeiner mit dem,
mit dem Stallman-Meme um die Ecke.
Aber, gut,
in praktischer,
in praktischer Anwendung für normale User,
die das eben nicht so als Glaubensfrage sehen,
ist das so.
Für alle anderen, gut,
die müssen halt sich auf,
äh, offen und sonst was beschränken.
Jahrelang auch GIMP verwendet,
ist auch eine tolle Software.
Ich mag GIMP nicht.
Wenn es wieder so ein Pendant in der Hinsicht gibt,
verwende ich das wieder, ne?
Aber in der Hinsicht...
Ich mag GIMP nicht.
Liegt aber auch daran,
weil ich nicht durchbleche in GIMP.
... dann mir auch mal fragen,
oder mich dann auch mal fragen,
okay, gut,
wo bin ich effizienter?
Und da war jetzt bei mir dann Canva doch die Sache,
was mich dann effizienter gemacht hat.
Ah, äh,
Bilderverwaltung, äh, Video...
In anderer Hinsicht ist es anders.
Blender beispielsweise ist komplett open source.
Blender ist top.
Und ist auch sehr, sehr führend dort tatsächlich, ne?
Also, es gibt auch andere Beispiele nochmal.
... Videos angucken, Videos streamen,
To-Do-Listen verwalten, Einkaufslisten verwalten,
Kalender verwalten, alles mögliche.
Also, 90 Prozent von dem, was die Leute machen,
oder gibt's bei vielen Leuten so,
ist halt im Browser.
Und da gibt's...
Genau.
Und da sehe ich hier doch auch wieder
eigentlich einen großen Punkt,
dass Linux doch für viel, viel mehr Leute geeignet ist,
als er vielleicht hier so am Anfang an teasert.
... gibt's unter Linux wenig Probleme.
Wenn ihr nur Browser-Anwendungen verwendet,
also nur Web-Anwendungen verwendet,
ja, dann könnt ihr quasi alles benutzen,
wo es einen aktuellen Browser gibt.
Ja, Tablets, Windows, Linux, Android, iOS,
das ist ziemlich egal.
Aber einen Desktop-PC hat man ja hauptsächlich auch für Sachen,
die über reine Browser-Anwendungen und rudimentäre Apps hinausgehen.
Und da ist es halt immer noch so,
das ist weiterhin unter Linux, je nachdem, was man verwendet, schwierig.
Und nicht nur bei solchen Sachen.
Beispielsweise auch bei Dingen...
Hätte ich gerne noch ein paar Beispiele gehabt.
Ich habe mich...
Ich habe mich davor, glaube ich, eine halbe Stunde darüber ausgelassen.
Je nachdem, welche Programme er da anspricht.
Klar, Adobe hatten wir schon vorhin.
Ist klar, dass das nicht geht.
Also, ne?
Ähm, Spiele, check.
... für Videos.
Die meisten Leute denken sich jetzt mal, was will er denn?
Na ja, guckt mal in den Task Manager.
Und macht mal ein Video auf, in Firefox oder Chrome, unter Windows.
Ihr werdet feststellen, ihr habt kaum CPU.
Ah, jetzt sind wir bei meinem Lieblingsthema.
Hardware-Video-Decoding.
Wie sieht es eigentlich aus mit AutoCAD oder sowas?
Ne, ich glaube nicht, dass es da irgendwas gibt.
... CPU-Last. Das meiste geht über die Grafikkarte.
Also sprich, die Grafikkarte decodet eure Videos.
Und rendert dann letztendlich auch die Videos.
Du brauchst kaum CPU-Last und du brauchst auch ziemlich wenig Akku heutzutage,
wenn du es im Notebook hast, wenn du Videos abspielst.
In unterstützten Formaten.
Was YouTube ist.
Und das ist halt unter Linux immer noch so ein Ding.
Ja, das geht zum größten Teil...
Was YouTube ist, aus meiner Sicht habe ich da ein bisschen falsch ausgedrückt.
Ich müsste sagen, dass YouTube H.264 unterstützt.
Und H.264 halt das ist, was nahezu jede Feld-, Wald- und Wiesen-Kombi irgendwie Hardware decoden kann.
... Teil, aber eben manchmal auch nichts.
Man merkt eben auch, dass der Fokus von Grafikkartenherstellern definitiv nicht die Entwicklung ihrer Linux-Treiber ist.
Äh, Arteno, warum? Wir sind uns doch in vielen Punkten sogar einig.
... Treiber ist.
Das muss man sagen.
Also, Linux-Treiber sind manchmal immer ein bisschen hinterher.
Bei Nvidia.
Bei Nvidia vor allem.
Ja, Nvidia bekleckert sich.
Wobei du kommst...
Dazu, dazu müsste ich jetzt eigentlich den Linux-Clip abspielen können, was Nvidia angeht und Linux-Unterstützung.
Da sind wir schon gut zurecht.
Also, ich habe nie Einschränkungen mit meiner Nvidia-Grafikkarte gehabt.
Ähm, ansonsten Video-Coding sozusagen in der Hinsicht.
Selber noch keine Probleme gehabt.
Ne, sowohl...
Das glaube ich dir nicht!
Seit... Wie ist das? Seit 10 Jahren verwendet er, verwendet er Linux.
...
So lang...
Nicht mal ansatzweise so lang funktioniert ordentlich Video-Decoding im Browser unter Linux.
Es ist mittlerweile in der richtigen Kombination, geht das mittlerweile schon ganz gut, ja.
Wie gesagt, gerade wenn es H.264 ist, gerade wenn es die richtige Kombination aus Browser-Version, Mesa-Treibern, Grafikkarten-Treibern, Windows-System-Version ist das, funktioniert das aber auch noch nicht so lang.
Tatsächlich, ich würde mal behaupten, bei Intel, da bin ich mir aber nicht sicher, ich würde mal mich jetzt aus dem Fenster lehnen und sagen...
...
da auch natürlich läuft.
Ja, nee, eben nicht.
Ja, eben nicht.
Das ist es doch. Wenn du es unter Windows machst,
dann läuft das größte Teil, wenn du mal
einen Browser aufmachst und ein Video aufspielst, eben nicht über die CPU.
Du hast so einen
gewissen Prozentsatz eventuell
dann auch nochmal in Windows
drin. Eventuell.
Und hast dann vielleicht andere Ressourcen, die dich dann
viel, viel mehr killen,
als dann hier nur das Video
im Webbrowser. Also,
das würde ich mal gar nicht so
groß sehen. Das war ein Beispiel
für Sachen, die halt unter Linux ein bisschen
hängen. Und ich sag mal,
Hardware-Decoded-Video-Abspielen
ist ja nun wirklich jetzt kein kleines
Feld. Also, gerade Leute, die das
auf dem Notebook benutzen wollen und auch mal Videos gucken,
ist das sehr wichtig, weil ansonsten
ist der Akku halt schneller leer, als du gucken
kannst. Und
ja, auch im
Browser willst du wirklich 250%
CPU-Last haben bei einem 4K-Video?
Das Thema.
Aber klar, absolut,
Grafikkarten sind unter Linux
immer ein bisschen weniger oder
ein bisschen stiefmütterlicher behandelt,
wobei ich selber
eigentlich keine Einschränkungen...
Mein Video ist ja fast fertig. Wie geht denn das jetzt noch
für 15-Minuten-Schränkungen irgendwo, Merke?
Und es geht mittlerweile.
Du hast recht. Ja, Jasper, du hast recht. Auf dem Desktop
merkst du es nicht so wirklich. Wenn die CPU schnell genug ist,
dann spielt es halt einfach ab. Aber es ist halt
schon ein Unterschied, ob es
5% CPU-Last verursacht oder
250%.
...Kombination aus aktuellem Browser, aktuellen Flex
im Browser, in der Konfigurierung schnell, richtigen
Treibern, richtige Settings-Kombination. Es geht.
Aber wenn es nicht geht...
Das beschreibt es zu kompliziert, würde ich
sagen. Nee, das ist so.
Guckt euch mal Guides an
von vor ein paar Jahren, wie bekommt man
Hardware-Decoding unter Linux zum Laufen.
Das ist so. Und selbst heute
funktioniert noch nicht alles.
GPU,
Decoding,
ich glaube, hier haben sie
ein ganz gutes, ganz gutes...
Gute Tabelle irgendwo, wo was funktioniert.
Hier.
Ja, da funktioniert... Guckt euch mal
die Genauung... Du musst schon wirklich
die exakten Kombinationen
hier haben, dass das alles
richtig miteinander funktioniert.
Und dazu kommt noch, du brauchst
noch die Mesa-Treiber-Version, Grafikkarten-Treiber-Version,
du brauchst die richtige Browser-Version, du brauchst
auch teilweise noch
die richtige Wayland-Version, die richtige
X-Geschichten und so. So einfach ist
das gar nicht.
Da hast du unterschiedliche
Grafik-Schnittstellen zum Treiber noch und so was.
Ja.
Wobei ich glaube,
er ist nicht ganz...
Wir sind da nicht
ganz auf einer
Wellenlänge so, was
ich gerade meine.
Ich meine jetzt nicht,
dass es so kompliziert ist. Mir geht es explizit um
Hardware-Video-Decoding, was
halt lange Zeit riesige Probleme
gemacht hat und heute in der passenden Kombination
auch immer noch nicht richtig funktioniert.
Einfach.
Dann guck dir einfach mal auf die CPU-Auslastung
und dann...
Müsst ihr eigentlich nicht machen.
...Ferde feststellen. Fuck. Ein YouTube-Video macht auf einmal
8 und werden
Pferde feststellen. Alles klar.
Alles klar.
So. Ich schau mal nach. Gut.
Ich muss sagen, bei mir ist es verzerrt.
Ich nehme noch währenddessen auf.
Lass uns mal nachschauen. So. Gut.
Also wir haben jetzt hier so eine Standard-Auslastung
von dem und jetzt mach ich mal das Video
an und wir schauen einfach mal.
Hm. Das war ja unter Windows nicht so.
Was sind solche Sachen? Da liegt halt nicht der Fokus.
Und es gibt auch immer wieder neue Probleme in dieser Richtung.
H264-Decoding. Ja. Ja. Ein bisschen.
Ein bisschen höher ist das. Aber das sieht aus, als scheint
GPU-Decoding bei ihm halbwegs zu funktionieren.
Sehe ich jetzt nicht.
VP9-Decoding ist neuerdings verbuggt.
Ja. Das ist...
Dass das bei ihm funktioniert. In der richtigen Kombination.
Mit dem richtigen Drive. Mit dem richtigen
Browser-Version. Das sag ich ja gar nichts dagegen.
Seit der letzten Version.
Also wie gesagt. Ja. Dass so Sachen wie VP9
einfach mal zwischendurch nicht mehr funktionieren, ist halt auch so.
Man merkt, dass da einfach nicht der Fokus drauf liegt.
Und es ist...
Es wird da natürlich auch immer schön gestritten, wer dafür zuständig ist,
anstatt die Probleme zu fixen. Ja. Browser-Hersteller sind dafür zuständig.
Die Desktop-Entwickler dafür zuständig. Sind die Windows-System-Entwickler
dafür zuständig? Sind die Grafik-Handtreiber-Programmierer
dafür zuständig? Ist der Linux-Coil selbst vielleicht sogar dafür zuständig?
Da wird sich auch gerne mal drei, vier Jahre am Stück gestritten.
Und jeder sagt, nein, nein, nein. Ich implementiere das nicht. Das müssen die anderen
implementieren. Ja. Ist so.
Also so ein Thema. Das kommt unter Linux relativ oft.
Das stimmt schon.
Also es gibt immer mal wieder solche Themen.
Aber uns als End-User
hab ich jetzt...
Als End-User juckt mich das insofern,
wann mein GPU-Decoding nicht richtig funktioniert.
Nicht groß gesehen,
wo sie uns krass betreffen.
Vielleicht bin ich da auch einfach
nicht in der Entwicklung drin. Das kann sehr gut sein.
Ich als Anwender... Da geht halt einfach
dein GPU-Decoding nicht. Das ist
für den Anwender auch schon kacke.
Mir ist das dann am Ende eigentlich auch egal.
Oft war. Also mir wär's nicht egal,
wenn mein Akku ein Drittel schneller unter Linux
im Notebook leer ist.
Und gerade bei Techno... Also weil die meisten
Sachen nicht funktionieren. Also ich wüsste jetzt nicht...
Mein Punkt ist ja auch, dass es mittlerweile
ganz gut ist, bis es halt mal wieder nicht funktioniert.
Wie beispielsweise, dass letztens
VP9-Decoding einfach mal wieder nicht funktioniert hat
in der Kombination.
Wo ich in Linux wirklich eine
große Einschränkung hab.
Bis auf die Kompatibilität von Adobe
und den Spielen.
Also mal Wheel Talk
wirklich nicht. Müsste ich nicht.
So was wie GPU-Decoding dauert manchmal unter Linux
ärgerlich lange, bis das funktioniert.
Das ging 10 Jahre schneller unter Windows und Linux.
Video-Rendering in meinem Videoschnitt.
Das mein ich nicht.
Ich mein,
GPU-Decoding von Videos.
Das ist so ein Ding, das ging 10 Jahre unter Windows.
Ohne jegliche Probleme.
Und unter Linux setzt du die letzten...
Ich würd sogar sagen,
die letzten 2-3 Jahre, wenn überhaupt,
halbwegs problemlos.
Und dann auch nur wirklich in der richtigen Kombination.
Richtige Hardware, richtige
Grafikkartentreiber, richtige Mesa-Treiber,
richtige Browser-Version,
richtige Zwischendings-Layer-API-Gezeugchen-Zelt,
richtige Wayland-Version,
richtige X-Version.
Das ist tatsächlich nicht so
easy, wie es jetzt auf den ersten Blick aussehen muss.
Klar, wenn ich einen neuen Rechner habe,
mit gut unterstützter Hardware,
installiere ich mir da eine aktuelle
Linux-Distribution drauf von 2023,
dass die Chancen da am besten
noch irgendwie mit Intel-GPU,
dass da die Chancen relativ hoch sind, dass es funktioniert, ist klar.
Aber das ist ja gar nicht der Punkt gewesen.
Der Punkt ist, dass sowas teilweise unter Linux 10 Jahre
rumgewerkelt wird,
bis es richtig funktioniert.
Und manchmal einfach auch Sachen zwischendurch
schlicht und ergreifend kaputt gehen.
So wie VP9-Decoding, was jetzt irgendwie vor einem Jahr oder so
einfach mal wieder nicht funktioniert hat.
Das hat so Dinger.
Probleme gibt es halt sonst nicht.
Die hast du aber unter Linux halt.
Das ist eigentlich,
ich kann es in die Tonne treten.
Ich mache das immer noch über die CPU, bin ich ganz ehrlich.
Und das liefert mir viel, viel bessere Ergebnisse
und viel schärfere Ergebnisse am Ende.
Die Nvidia-Grafikkarte ist zwar schneller,
aber das Video ist dann
viel, viel verwaschener.
GPU-Encoding ist ja wieder was,
ganz was anderes.
Gerade FFmpeg,
ist da relativ, relativ gut
drin, die Sachen anzusteuern.
Also wenn man FFmpeg
selbst, selbst encodet.
Also NVN
kann ja FFmpeg seit Jahren
schon, und ich denke mal, das habe ich ehrlich gesagt
nie unter Linux probiert, denke mal,
dass das auch schon recht gut lange Zeit
unter Linux geht.
Aber dann sicherlich auch nur mit der passenden
Treiber-Geschichte.
Das ist ganz gut.
Ja, und das ist tatsächlich so,
wenn du GPU encodest,
dann brauchst du
ein bisschen höhere
Bitrate, um auf die gleiche
Qualität zu kommen.
Aber es ist halt
deutlich schneller.
Das muss man auch mal sagen.
Ich mache mittlerweile auch für die Gaming-Sachen
nur noch GPU-Decoding.
Ich encode allerdings dann mit
irgendwie 17, 18 Mbits.
Variabel auch.
Das sieht ganz gut aus und geht halt schnell.
Also während ich selbst auf meinem
neuen super hier NASA-PC,
ungefähr, also wenn ich, wenn ich
upscale 4K und, ne, nicht 4K,
1440p upscale, 60 FPS und mit der CPU rendere,
dann bin ich so ungefähr so bei
Laufzeit des Videos
ein bisschen, ein bisschen geringer als
die eigentliche Laufzeit des Videos,
was die Render-Dauer angeht.
Also sagen wir mal, ich habe ein 10 Minuten Video,
dann rendert das vielleicht 9 Minuten 30,
okay, wenn ich über die CPU rendere.
Rendere ich über Quick Sync oder über
NV-ENG oder sowas,
dann ist das teilweise, das 10 Minuten Video
ist dann teilweise in 3,5 Minuten gerendert.
Also das ist enorm, sehr, sehr, sehr
viel schneller. Gut, der Upload dauert dann
ein bisschen länger, weil mehr Bitrate,
aber das ist meistens gerechtfertigt
für die schnellere Render, Render-Dauer.
Ich habe hier auch unter dem Video wieder eingesagt,
Max, das stimmt überhaupt nicht, was du sagst und das ist eigentlich alles viel besser
und ich habe da überhaupt keine Probleme und sowas, aber okay.
Genau das, was er gemacht hat.
Ich weiß, dass viele in der Linux-Community
tun sich tatsächlich, egal wie dezent
vorgebrachte Kritik, manchmal ein bisschen schwer.
Das ist so.
Es gibt Linux-Communities, das sind teilweise richtig, das kann man nicht anders nennen,
richtig elitäre Deppen unterwegs, das heißt, wenn ihr da nach Hilfe
fragt, kann es durchaus vorkommen, dass man euch sagt.
Also erstmal erster Teil, ich hoffe,
dass er das so ein bisschen getrennt hat.
Hoffe ich mal, dass ich kein elitärer Depp bin.
Schreibt es in die Kommentare.
Ich habe gesagt, in manchen
Communities.
Aber jedenfalls.
Nein, glaube ich nicht. Ich denke mal, wir sind uns
an einigen Punkten da tatsächlich einig gewesen.
Also ich würde sogar sagen, wir sind uns mehr oder weniger
in dem Großteil der Punkten,
ja, sogar einig gewesen.
Was hat er gesagt?
Also genau, es gibt viele, die da sagen,
ja, du hast ja kein Problem.
Ich glaube, er meint es nicht so, wie ich
das jetzt gemeint habe. Ich glaube, er meint die Leute,
die da so richtig
Hardliner-mäßig unterwegs sind.
Da gibt es leider solche
Proben in der Community. Da gibt es genug.
Ich habe das Gefühl, dass vor allem in der Linux-Community,
das muss man auch sagen, wenn man so auf die
Veranstaltung geht teilweise,
dann doch häufiger
solche Brocken findet, in Anführungszeichen.
Solche Leute, die jetzt, ich sag mal,
sozial
ausbaufähige Leistungen haben.
Sagen wir es einfach mal so.
Und das muss ich sagen, ja, das ist sehr, sehr
schade. Also du hast häufig in verschiedenen
Communities einen Ton, der ist
nicht mehr menschlich.
Link zum Video, auf das er reactet.
Hier, Linux ist kein Ersatz.
Das ist ein Video von mir.
Linux ist kein Ersatz für Windows.
Das ist das Originalvideo.
Kann man besser machen?
Im Linux Guides Forum.
Das ist eine ganz, ganz
Natürlich ein bisschen Sellout für die eigene Seite,
aber ist ja nicht schlimm, würde ich genauso machen.
Auch für Einsteiger sehr, sehr gut geeignet.
Laufen, wenn ihr möchtet.
Ich scrolle jetzt auch mal ein bisschen vor.
Schaut euch das gleich an.
Es gibt solche Communities, Arch, Linux,
finde ich einfach nicht redlich.
Ich skippe das Community-Ding jetzt mal.
Da kann man sicherlich auch getrennter
Linux und Windows parallel.
Und dadurch bleibt es natürlich
ein sehr, sehr kleiner Kreis.
Sehr viele wirklich sehr hilfreiche Communities,
beispielsweise das Gaming on Linux Subreddit,
finde ich recht hilfreich.
Arch-Wiki ist gut, muss ich sagen.
Obuntu-Users auf Deutsch
ist auch sehr, sehr, sehr gut.
Das sind so die Wikis, die ich so gut kenne.
Debian-Wiki ist auch toll, wenn ihr Debian nutzt,
aber dafür müsst ihr Debian nutzen.
Wenn ihr was nachgucken wollt.
Jetzt habe ich viel darüber geredet,
warum es vielleicht für euch keine so gute Idee ist,
Windows runterzuhauen und Linux drauf zu machen.
Tja, wenn einen Windows nervt,
aber der komplette Umstieg auf Linux
auch eher nix für einen ist,
was kann man machen?
Direkt einen Mac kaufen?
Genau, kauft euch einen Mac.
Vielen Dank für das Video.
Sehr tolles Video, ne?
Kann man machen, ist aber da auch,
ich sag mal,
trotzdem zentralistisch in der Hinsicht.
Ich hätte auch keinen Bock,
einen Mac zu benutzen.
Das sind wir uns einig.
Es ist ein Mac-OS da
und Mac da viel, viel sicherer ist
und deine Daten auf jeden Fall noch viel, viel besser schützt.
Mac, mir geht es gar nicht so sehr darum,
ob ein Hersteller dahinter ist oder nicht.
Mac ist einfach Unix-Linux-artig
genug, es wäre ein BSD,
um nicht zu nerven.
Ja, das ist das Wichtigste.
Unter Linux kann man es beweisen,
unter Mac ist es schwieriger.
Das wäre jetzt ein komplett anderes Thema.
Das hat auch so seine Probleme.
Aber was ihr machen könnt,
man stellt Linux parallel zu Windows aus
und ich meine kein Dual-Boot.
Ich meine sowas wie VirtualBox
oder Vmware Player oder Vmware Workstation
oder meinetwegen noch Hyper-V.
Jetzt wollte ich ihm gerade zu 100% zustimmen,
da hat er die VirtualBox genannt.
Die VirtualBox ist nicht schlecht,
wenn man das in der VirtualBox ausprobiert
oder in der virtuellen Maschine,
nur hast du eine viel, viel schwächere Performance
und ich erlebe immer wieder im Linux Report,
dass Leute meinen,
das hat in der VirtualBox nicht funktioniert
und jetzt auf dem richtigen Linux funktioniert.
Kommt natürlich drauf an, was es ist.
Gerade irgendwas mit
GPU-Access und 3D
beziehungsweise
accelerated OpenGL-Gedöns
und so, ja, da gibt es sicherlich
die ein oder anderen Probleme in der VM.
Aber die Performance,
wir reden jetzt ja mal hier von CPU
und nicht von GPU,
dass es GPU-technisch in der VM
nicht so dolle ist,
ja, das ist so, wenn ich da Anwendungszwecke habe,
gut, man kann immerhin Super-Tux-Karten spielen
mit 60 FPS in der VM,
was für GPU-Sachen keine allzu gute Sache ist.
Man kann sogar Blender und sowas
in der VM laufen lassen, wenn man das unbedingt will.
Ja, dass das für sowas,
wenn ich GPU-Sachen-Anforderungen habe,
vielleicht nicht die beste Idee ist,
das in der VM zu machen, okay.
Aber für alles andere,
für alles andere,
CPU-Performance ist in der VM
nicht wirklich viel schlechter
als auf dem Host.
Wir haben auch letztes Mal Benchmarks gemacht,
wo ich zu blöd war,
die richtigen Parameter rauszufinden.
So von uns auf die Schnelle mal durchgeführt,
ich weiß gar nicht mehr,
was das gewesen ist.
Was haben wir für einen Benchmark gemacht?
Der eine, der die Ergebnisse
online hochladen wollte und sonst nicht angezeigt hat,
der war Mist, und dann irgendein anderer.
Also hat man gesehen,
und bei mir hatte ich vor allem noch das Problem gehabt,
dass es auf den Efficiency-Kurs
teilweise gescheduled hat
und nicht auf den Performance-Kurs.
Und selbst da war,
na, wenn es hochkommt,
dann mal 10% Leistungsunterschied, eher 5%.
Und wenn ich
den Benchmark mal richtig machen würde
und vielleicht auch noch die Core spinnen würde
von der VM, da würde man sehen,
dass CPU-technisch nahezu
kein Unterschied ist zwischen
Host und VM.
Die CPU ist ja auch das einzige,
was in einer VM nicht wirklich virtualisiert wird.
Alles andere wird in einer VM
virtualisiert, die CPU nicht.
Bei der CPU passieren Magic
Translation,
Umschreibsachen on the fly
und mit
VM-Unterstützung in der CPU
sogar noch weniger als früher.
Also CPU-Performance ist in der
VM echt kein Ding.
CPU-Performance ist nahezu native.
Check ich nicht.
Also von daher, ja,
macht's parallel.
Würde ich euch empfehlen.
Jetzt gibt's ja auch wieder hier
zwei Meinungen.
Aber Dualboot ist, ich find Dualboot nervig.
Da musst du, gerade wenn du neu
anfängst, da musst du dann Dualboot machen,
dann bist du in einem System, wo du dich
nicht mit auskennst. Und auf der anderen Seite
kannst du dann wenigstens in Windows
reingucken, kurz suchen, okay, wie könnte man
das Ganze jetzt machen.
Wieder zurück in die Linux-VM.
Und außerdem
hat man den großen Vorteil, man kann beide Systeme
parallel benutzen und die Vorteile
von beiden Systemen ausspielen.
Man hat unter Linux eben eine ordentliche
Command-Line-Umgebung
und kann
vom Programmieren bis
Technik-Sachen, Netzwerktechnik, Microcontroller,
Gedöns, kann man alles, oder surfen
vielleicht auf ein bisschen unsicheren
Seiten, kann man alles unter Linux
erledigen.
Und Sachen wie
Videos schneiden,
neue Sachen ausprobieren,
keine Ahnung, eine Runde Valorant spielen, was auch immer,
kann man alles unter Windows machen.
Das heißt, so hat man das Beste aus beiden Welten.
Das ist für mich der größte Vorteil, was Dualboot angeht.
Zwei Leute, die das sagen.
Vielleicht sagt er noch gleich, warum
man das parallel nicht empfiehlt.
Also, so mal zum Reinschnuppern ist die Virtual Machine super.
Aber wenn ihr es wirklich nutzen wollt,
bitte, bitte, bitte
parallel nutzen.
Nicht alles.
Ja.
Natürlich findest du jetzt was,
was du nicht in der VR machen kannst.
Ach ja, jetzt ist Video
abspielen auf einmal ein Problem.
Mit hoher CPU-Auslastung, so, so.
Vorher war das kein Ding.
Da habt ihr die Probleme, das stimmt.
Na so, wenn ich jetzt in der Virtual Machine wäre
und dann dort meine Videoleistung
anschauen würde, wenn ich da die,
also meine CPU-Leistung anschaue, wenn ich ein Video
abspiele, dann ist das unterirdisch.
Das ist ganz klar.
Das liegt aber in der VR.
Genau an dem gleichen Grund.
Das liegt nicht daran, dass meine CPU suckt,
sondern es liegt daran, dass GPU-Decoding nicht funktioniert.
Was auch leider immer noch 2023
in einigen Kombinationen nicht
out of the box, auch auf Hardware funktioniert.
Und es jahrelang, fast schon
übertrieben jetzt gesagt, jahrzehntelang,
naja, das ist ein bisschen übertrieben,
aber auf jeden Fall jahrelang Probleme gab.
Wenn du einen Rechner laufen hast,
dann hast du doch viel, viel, viel mehr Performance
als unter der Virtual Machine.
Kann man sich drüber streiten?
CPU-Performance nimmt sich nahezu gar nichts
zwischen Host und VM.
Zumindest nicht im nennenswerten Bereich.
Grafik, ja klar.
Also Blender würde ich auch nicht in der VM
den ganzen Tag laufen lassen.
Da würde ich das sogar noch ein bisschen weiter
hochstellen.
Ja doch, das ist schon so.
Du hast richtig krasse CPU-Auslastung,
wenn du ein Video abspielst in der VM.
Klar, du hast ja auch keinerlei GPU-Decoding.
Guck mal hier.
Ich kann euch das ja mal zeigen.
Das ist dann nicht optimal für...
Ja, so.
Ja, ja.
Gehen wir nicht auf den Keks.
So, spielen wir jetzt, keine Ahnung, irgendwas von Battlefield.
Da ist ein bisschen Gameplay, wo sich was bewegt.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Wir stellen das jetzt mal hoch.
Das läuft, aber ihr seht,
meine CPU-Auslastung ist schon
nicht gerade so gering.
Also gehen wir mal hier hin.
Ja, ganz toll.
Alter.
Ja.
Sieht man schon, das ist ein bisschen am aus...
ein bisschen am Brummen, das Ganze.
CPU-Technik ist nicht im Bereich, dass es
nicht funktioniert.
Das ist aber halt kein GPU-Decoding.
Das gleiche Problem, was du hast, wenn GPU-Decoding halt nicht funktioniert.
Das liegt sicher daran, dass meine CPU-Performance
suckt, sondern die CPU-Performance, wie man sieht,
ist ja eigentlich relativ gut.
Sonst würde es nicht funktionieren in der VM.
Naja, gut.
Was ich bei mir zu Hause auf dem Desktop habe,
beziehungsweise so, wie ich auch Linux verwende.
Ich verwende mehrere Desktops unter Windows.
Ich habe auf dem ersten Desktop meinen Windows-Desktop.
Fullscreen, vor allem bei Workstation, mit Linux.
Natürlich Arch Linux, by the way.
Was sonst? Das muss ich euch jetzt an der Stelle auch nochmal erzählen.
Arch, by the way.
Auch sehr interessante Methode, wie er Linux dann nutzt.
Also, dass er das gar nicht nativ drauf hat.
Ich kann es nativ nur empfehlen.
Macht viel weniger Probleme insgesamt.
Würde ich...
Je nachdem, was man machen will.
Das stelle ich mir so vor.
Und ich habe es umgekehrt.
Ich habe einen Linux mit einer Windows-VM, wenn ich sie wirklich mal brauche.
Ich muss sagen, mittlerweile...
Hat man andere Probleme.
Ich glaube, wirklich vor 1, 2, 3 Jahren.
Die letzte Zeit gar nicht.
Nur für Kunden ausgetestet.
Verschiedene Sachen.
Aber nie was selber gemacht dort drunter.
Stark.
Also, ich habe es genau andersrum.
Was man aber daran auch wieder sieht,
ist,
viele Wege führen zum Ziel.
Und man muss einfach schauen,
was für das jeweilige Anwendungsprofil,
oder ich weiß nicht, wie ich es nennen soll,
was für den jeweiligen User
eben das Richtige ist. Was der machen will.
Und für mich ist es sehr praktisch,
wenn ich beide Systeme parallel habe.
Ich kann mein Streaming-Gaming-Video-Kram
unter Windows machen.
Und habe nebenbei noch auf dem zweiten Desktop die Linux-VM,
in der ich alle möglichen Technik-Sachen mache.
Und, hey, wir haben so viele Sachen hier im Stream schon unter Linux gemacht.
Ihr seht, dass das performance-technisch
überhaupt kein Problem ist.
Und auch GPU-accelerated Sachen
im Rahmen
funktioniert.
Natürlich ist das nicht mit einer eingebauten Grafikkarte
zu vergleichen.
Aber so basic Sachen wie, sagen wir hier,
transparente Hintergründe
und sowas, das ist ja auch alles irgendwo
mit
Composite-Rendering und sowas.
Das funktioniert schon. Und wir haben hier sogar mal
diesen
Uni-Engine,
ach, keine Ahnung,
Evan-Benchmark, ich habe keine Ahnung, wie der heißt,
diesen
Teslation-Benchmark laufen lassen.
Der lief auch mit 240 FPS.
Das geht. Aber natürlich ist es kompatibilitätstechnisch,
was Vulkan, OpenGL
und solche Sachen angeht,
echt nicht zu vergleichen mit native
Linux-Installationen in der VM.
Wenn ich programmiere, wenn ich Technik-Sachen mache
oder auch einfach nur ganz normales Surfen, Bastel-Kram,
dann mache ich das auf dem zweiten Desktop in meiner Linux-VM
und spielen, streamen, Videos schneiden, aufnehmen
und solche Sachen, die mache ich unter Windows.
So kann man auch beides parallel benutzen.
Okay, ja, also,
er macht es genau parallel umgekehrt.
Dadurch, dass ich nicht spiele, bin ich nicht
auf die 3D-Leistung angewiesen
von der virtuellen Maschine.
Wenn ich jetzt krass spielen würde,
so krasse Spiele spielen würde,
die halt nicht unter Linux laufen,
dann, ja, ist das vielleicht
sogar eine Idee. Aber ansonsten,
ja,
ich spiele auch manchmal unter Linux, aber dann halt
Supertox-Karten.
Und es sind wirklich verdammt viele.
Schaut euch das einfach mal an.
Da gibt es enorm viel.
Auch was gut unter Linux funktioniert.
ProtonDB, Stichwort.
Ja, ProtonDB eigentlich.
Einfach mal schauen.
Ist sicherlich Geschmackssache.
Ist ja nicht so schön.
Ja, da hat er auch kein richtiges Argument gegeben.
Ich denke, er hat es auch nie richtig ausprobiert.
Natürlich!
Ich habe doch gerade erklärt, warum ich das verwende.
Weil zu mich die beste Kombination ist,
dass ich beide Betriebssysteme parallel benutzen kann.
Und ich Technik-Kram unter Linux mache,
Gaming, Videoschnitt, Streaming und sowas unter Windows.
Ich meine, hey,
was soll ich denn da noch mehr begründen müssen?
Ich glaube doch, mein Workflow ist
die beste Begründung und Erklärung dafür überhaupt,
oder? Warum ich das so mache.
Das ist ja nicht aus Spaß, an der Freude.
Weil ich mir denke, oh ja,
ich will unbedingt zwei Sachen parallel laufen haben.
Naja, gut.
Doch, ich habe das auch probiert
mit Dualboot.
Ich hatte das sogar früher mal
auf der Arbeit in Dualboot probiert.
Das ging mir aber extrem auf den Sack.
Klar habe ich das mit Dualboot schon ausprobiert.
Ich gebe zu, es ist länger her,
als ich das mit Dualboot ausprobiert habe.
Aber ich hätte auch ehrlich gesagt gar keinen Bock
auf Dualboot zu machen.
Wie soll ich meine Gaming-Geschichten machen?
Wie soll ich meine Video-Geschichten machen?
Wie soll ich meine Thumbnail-Geschichten machen?
Das ist einfach,
es passt einfach richtig gut zu meinem Workflow,
beides parallel laufen zu haben.
Also insofern,
deswegen mache ich es ja auch so.
Wenn man wirklich viel spielt,
ja gut, der Mai, dann brauche ich auf jeden Fall
noch ein Windows da drauf installiert.
Aber ja, ich finde mit der virtuellen Maschine
hast du trotzdem noch
dein Windows mit den ganzen
fast Nachteilen sozusagen.
Ja das stimmt, Windows wird dadurch nicht besser.
Aber ich muss halt die Sachen, die mich unter Windows
abfacken, nicht unter Windows machen.
Dementsprechend ist es schon besser.
Also dass du außerhalb Windows...
Aber hey, es ist
Geschmackssache unterm Strich.
Je nachdem, was man machen will.
... oder Windows 11 Pro,
dann hast du keinen
Online-Zwang, nicht unbedingt meine ich.
Du kannst deine Updates
besser timen und so weiter.
Aber dann blätterst du halt wieder Geld hin.
Das möchte ich jetzt beispielsweise in dem Fall
nicht unbedingt nur für so eine Funktion.
Also ich bitte euch.
... das Beste aus beiden Welten. Und ich finde das auch für meinen Anwendungszweck
am sinnvollsten. Deswegen kann ich euch das auch nur...
Genau das ist es. Ich finde das für meinen Anwendungszweck
am sinnvollsten. Deswegen mache ich das auch.
Wenn ihr mal ein bisschen in Linux reinschnuppern wollt,
dann würde ich euch wirklich empfehlen, installiert euch eine Linux-VM.
Ihr könnt auch WSL verwenden unter Windows.
Aber ich würde vorschlagen, benutzt ein echtes Linux
in einer VM.
Also zum Reinschnuppern ist es super.
Zum produktiven Verwendung finde ich stark,
dass das so gut funktioniert.
Wer macht das genau andersrum,
kann man darüber streiten. Möchte ich gar nicht.
Also in der Hinsicht...
Ich denke, es sollte jeder so benutzen, wie das bei ihm am besten funktioniert.
Ich selber würde es anders machen.
Es hat ja auch keinen Sinn. Das kann man, denke ich, auch nicht oft genug sagen.
Es hat ja auch überhaupt keinen Sinn, so diese ganzen
Kriege, die es da immer gibt.
Android oder IOS, Linux, Mac, Windows.
Was ist das Beste? Das Beste ist,
was für einen jetzt im Moment
eben am besten passt.
Was die beste Umgebung bietet für das, was man machen will.
Natürlich
die beste Umgebung hat je nach
Anwender unterschiedlichste Faktoren.
Manch einer legt sehr viel Wert drauf.
Nur free and open source.
Der hat dann irgendwie nur einen Richard-Stellman-Poster
über dem Bett hängen, was auch immer.
Ist das das Allerwichtigste.
Manch einer sagt, ich brauche aber unbedingt diese Software.
Das Anwendungsprofil ist immer ein bisschen
unterschiedlich. Es kann jeder...
Muss sich das für sich selbst überlegen.
Aber Hauptsache
Art-Spielung ist korrekt.
Wenn er halt eben sagt, gut,
wenn er spielen würde und wenn ich jetzt ganz viel spielen würde,
dann wäre es vielleicht eine Idee mit einem Dual-Boot.
Ansonsten...
Ja, und weil ich zu faul bin, mich umzugewöhnen
auch bei viel meiner Software.
Ich finde, Affinity Designer ist eine super Geschichte.
Ich habe mich an Vegas für Videosachen gewöhnt.
Ich will ja meine Streaming-Geschichten machen.
Ich will Spiele auf Steam spielen
oder auch über andere Stores.
Die ganze Kombination...
Würde ich nicht glücklich werden unter Linux.
Linux auf dem Desktop, Windows auf dem Server
change my mind. Mach was du willst, wenn du dich quälen willst.
Ja, hast du trotzdem noch
Windows immer als Hauptsystem laufen.
Was eigentlich viel mehr Ressourcen frisst
nochmal zusätzlich.
Komm, ein bisschen...
Ja, das mag schon sein.
Also, ja, es ist bestimmt so,
dass Windows in der Standard-Installation
ein bisschen mehr Leistung frisst,
als vielleicht...
Gerade, wenn du dir anguckst, was da für ein Scheiß
mittlerweile im Hintergrund alles passiert.
Es ist aber auch für moderne Hardware
nicht wirklich so ausschlaggebend.
Muss man auch mal sagen.
Also, wenn man jetzt nicht einen Rechner hat,
der irgendwie nur noch einen Dual-Core hat
oder sowas. Das funktioniert wunderbar.
Oder was heißt 10 Jahre? Reicht ja.
Ich hab letztens meinem Vater
einen Rechner zusammengebaut.
Meine alte Quad-Core Xeon-Kiste.
Und Windows 11 drauf gehauen.
Ließ ich auch ohne Probleme installieren.
Das läuft wunderbar und zackig.
8 GB RAM.
Relativ älterer Quad-Core.
Natürlich, unter Linux könnte das dann
was...
Idle-mäßig noch ein bisschen mehr idlen
als unter Windows. Okay.
Das macht nicht wirklich großen Unterschied.
Weil er ja eigentlich
eh immer sein Linux offen hat,
wenn er ja nur ganz normal surft. Richtig.
Dann verbraucht er eigentlich
noch mehr Ressourcen. Ja, das stimmt.
Aber das ist nicht wirklich schlimm.
Und ich kann das Beste aus beiden Welten verwenden.
Was für mich in dem Fall jetzt eben
das Angenehmere ist.
Und gerade, wenn du unter Windows unterwegs bist
und ich guck beispielsweise
in meine Business-E-Mails rein
und irgendeiner schickt mir komische PDFs oder Links.
Selbstverständlich mach ich die nicht unter Windows auf,
sondern unter Linux.
Wo man schon wieder einen echten Mehrwert hätte,
davon das Parallellaufen zu haben.
Weil soll ich dann erst mal Duel booten
und dort das dann nochmal aufmachen?
Das ist doch kacke.
Und dann ist der Rechner immer ein bisschen
langsamer, sozusagen, generell.
Also, bei meinem NASA-PC ist das kein Unterschied.
Und beim alten war es auch kein Unterschied.
Sondern vor allem im Hintergrund ist jetzt ja nicht,
als würde die wahnsinnig viel Leistung oder sowas ziehen.
Das Einzige, was die braucht,
ist natürlich ordentlich RAM.
Klar, aber naja,
ich hab genug RAM.
So ein bisschen dann durch die
Virtualisierung, wie wenn er
das einfach andersrum hat.
Dass er seine normalen Sachen auf Linux
macht, auf dem nativen Linux und seine ganz speziellen
Sachen dann halt auf Windows.
Ich glaub, er macht's genau andersrum.
Ich mach's andersrum, korrekt.
Mit der passenden, mit der grafischen Oberfläche,
die ihr euch ausgesucht habt unter Linux.
Was kommt jetzt noch? Fazit!
So sieht's aus.
Also, ich glaub, er hat da auch einige Ansätze.
Ähnlich wie ich. Ich würd's mit dem
Dualboot anders machen. Haben wir, glaub ich, schon ganz
genug gesagt. Ansonsten
ein ganz nettes Video. Ich muss sagen, ich hab Max FPS
nicht richtig auf dem Schirm.
Ich hab ihn immer mal wieder so gesehen.
Ja gut, ich mach ja auch normalerweise andere Sachen.
Aber tatsächlich nie groß
irgendwie, ich sag mal, Videos
geschaut, leider. Sehr selten, wenn dann.
Aber auf jeden Fall. Ja, sehr cool. Wusste gar nicht,
dass er 15 Jahre lang schon
Linux nutzt. Mich würde es interessieren,
in welcher Position er da
arbeitstechnisch drin ist. Vielleicht schreibt ihr mir das.
Das kann ich. Das schreib ich ihm drunter.
Das schreib ich ihm jetzt. Ansonsten ein tolles Video
tatsächlich. Und ich würde mitgehen
mit dem Titel, also jetzt, ne?
Am Anfang hab ich gedacht so, ups, ne?
Bisschen Kritik. Wollte ich mir ja nicht anschauen.
Ist tatsächlich doch positiver ausgefallen, als
ich gedacht. Ich hab mir schon
ein wärmeres Fell anziehen wollen, sozusagen.
Aber passt ja eigentlich ganz gut.
Generell geh ich mit dem Titel
mit in der Hinsicht...
Ja, gut. Hey, ich mein,
klar, kannst du jetzt sicherlich noch eine halbe Stunde
an dem Thumbnail oder an dem Videotitel rumkritizieren.
Ob das jetzt wirklich 100% mit dem Inhalt
und sonst was... Man darf aber nicht vergessen,
es ist YouTube, ja?
Dementsprechend brauchst du einen gewissen Aufhänger
im Titel und im Thumbnail.
Das kannst du mir jetzt nicht irgendwie negativ auslegen.
Dass du halt nicht
eins zu eins das umstellen kannst, ne?
Manche denken das. Vergiss es.
Kriegst du nicht hin. Aber, ähm,
ansonsten, ja,
stimme ich ihm da eigentlich schon ganz gut zu.
Wie er das jetzt so begründet alles.
Magst du das dringend erinnern?
Kann man sich drüber streiten, aber
das ist nicht die Seltenheit unter Linux.
Ähm, frag 10 Linux-Leute
und da kriegst du 20 Antworten.
Ich denke, das ist ein ganz guter Durchschnitt.
Von daher denke ich, passt soweit.
Und ich bin sehr gespannt, ob er nicht
eventuell dann doch nochmal
man Linux wirklich richtig nativ
auf die Hardware zimmert.
Ja, doch. Ich hab ja auf der Arbeit lange Jahre
Linux nativ auf der Hardware benutzt.
Die letzten, weiß ich nicht, äh,
wie lange hatte ich denn dann? Ich hatte eigentlich schon immer
Linux-Notebooks und Linux-Hardware auf der Arbeit.
Ja.
So, als hätte ich nie nativ Linux verwendet.
Und dann da
das langfristig auch mal als Produktivsystem
nutzt, würde mich sehr interessieren.
Wie nennt man das so schön? Daily Driver
seit über 10 Jahren
auf der Arbeit oder, ja,
kann man fast schon sagen, seit Anfang an, seit 15 Jahren
auf der Arbeit schon gemacht.
Was mit unter anderem halt
genau auch zu dieser Kombi für mich im privaten
Umfeld geführt hat, Windows als Hausbetriebssystem
und Linux in der VM.
Auf der Arbeit war das kein Ding.
Das war, ich own die Linux. Und wenn ich Microsoft
Zeug benutzen wollte, hab ich hauptsächlich
halt Office im Browser benutzt. Das ging auch.
Und Teams halt im Browser und sowas.
Schauen wir einfach mal.
Ja, ansonsten die, der Ausblick,
ich geh tatsächlich davon aus, dass es immer
leichter wird, immer integrativer
auf Linux umzusteigen,
zumal halt immer mehr Software im Netz läuft.
Ja, also Chat, komm.
So nen, so nen schlimmen Eindruck, dass der da so
fanatisch hinterher, was Linux angeht, hat er doch jetzt
gar nicht gemacht. Klang noch alles, äh,
klang noch alles relativ nachvollziehbar.
Und...
Wir sind uns ja auch mehr oder
weniger bei den meisten Punkten einig. Klar,
so ein paar Sachen hat jeder so seine
Vorlieben und sieht, sieht jeder auch ein bisschen anders.
Pa, paar Sachen konnte ich überhaupt nicht,
überhaupt nicht, äh, folgen. Gerade was das
mit GPU-Decoding geht, dass das ja überhaupt kein
Ding ist, wo man sich als Endanwender Gedanken drum machen muss.
Naja, also, find ich schon.
Aber gut, hat jeder so ein bisschen seins.
Ansonsten ging das doch vollkommen klar.
Und dadurch, äh, Geräte
unabhängig, beziehungsweise Betriebssystem
unabhängig wird, äh, da wird Linux noch mal
einiges, denke ich, dann langfristig
mitnehmen. Und, ähm, wenn ich sowieso
schon sehe, was für coole, neue Technologien
mit Linux kommen, mit Fedora,
Silverblue und so weiter, das, äh,
find ich auch sehr, sehr stark. Das, ähm, geht noch mal
einen ganz, ganz anderen Ansatz. Und ich glaube
nicht, dass Windows 12 so einen Ansatz
geht. Ich glaub, da haben sie gar nicht die Infrastruktur,
beziehungsweise die
Kompatibilitäten dafür. Also dieser ganze
Containerisierungsansatz mit Flatpak
und Snap und Co., das, äh, find ich
tatsächlich eine sehr, sehr starke Lü-
SNAP!
Okay, ich glaub, ich muss die Meinung
revidieren.
Snap ist ja wohl so das Allerschlimmste, was
es gibt.
Gut. Aber warum nicht?
Kann jeder benutzen, was er will.
...Lösung mittlerweile. Und, ähm,
da bin ich auch sehr gespannt, was
das dann langfristig mit
sich bringt in der Hinsicht. Und ich denke auch
für viele Einsteigernutzer. Ansonsten, wie ist
mein empfohlener Einstieg für
einen Linux-Nutzer? Lass mich raten! Lass mich raten!
Dualboot?
Ganz klar, schaut euch
Linux gerne mal an, wenn ihr wollt, am Anfang
erstmal eine virtuelle Maschine. Ich finde,
es schadet aber erstmal nicht, sich
das einfach mal draufzuziehen, auf
eine Festplatte, ähm, auf
eure ganz normale Festplatte, einfach 100 GB
abziehen, dann dort das, äh, Linux drauf
installieren. Ja, aber beim nächsten Windows-Update
ist der Crap kaputt, wobei ich weiß gar nicht, ob das,
ob der Windows-Update da immer noch rumwurstet.
Ich natürlich auch schon mal ein Video
dazu gemacht, einfach mal Linux
Crash Course eingeben,
dann müsstet ihr das sogar direkt finden.
Na, gebt mal Linux Mint Crash Course ein.
Ich glaube, dann findet ihr genau das, was ich
haben möchte. Genau, das hier einmal, ähm,
das kann ich nur empfehlen.
Und dann findet ihr hier tatsächlich,
ja, eine komplette Anleitung.
Und wenn ihr dann Linux lang
genug nutzt und merkt, ey, ich
nutze Windows immer seltener, dann
entfernt das. Und wenn ihr merkt, hey, ich nutze
eigentlich beide sehr gerne, dann bleibt halt da drauf am
Ende. Und wenn ihr am Ende sagt, ja, nee,
Linux ist vielleicht doch nicht genau das, was
ich mir vorgestellt habe, dann deinstalliert
es wieder. Ist auch kein Problem. Habe ich auch
mal ein Video gemacht. Müsste ich eigentlich mal
aktualisieren. Schreibt es gerne mal in die Kommentare,
wie ihr so seht, wie ihr das
einstellen könnt. Ey, er will halt seine Kurse auch ein bisschen um die Leute
bringen, Chat. Aber finde ich jetzt überhaupt nichts
Verwerfliches dran. Ich meine, ey,
scheint ja Chef von irgendeiner
Beraterbude
oder irgendwie sowas zu sein. Keine Ahnung.
Da muss man ein bisschen Sellout machen.
Sonst funktioniert das nicht. Man muss,
man muss, die Leute müssen einen kennen. Also, dass
er da Sellout oder so.
Und dass er dementsprechend das Ganze auch ein
bisschen boosten will. Also, das so zu machen,
wie in seinen Kursen. Ah, ja.
Muss gucken, wo du bleibst.
Finde ich nicht. Finde ich jetzt
nicht wild.
Und wenn ihr umsteigen wollt,
aber es noch nicht getan habt, schreibt auch gerne,
warum ihr das noch nicht machen wollt.
Ich versuche mit meinem YouTube-Kanal und
mit dem Linux-Guides-Projekt, mit dem Forum,
mit dem Support und allem Möglichen, auch
für Unternehmen mit einem Linux-Arbeitsplatz,
dann den Umstieg so
einfach wie möglich zu machen. Okay, das ist ein bisschen
Sellout noch für seine Sachen. Alles klar.
Im Prinzip waren wir uns doch eigentlich
einig. Ist doch top.
Was ist das hier?
Wie ist das, in einem Startup zu arbeiten?
Einen Tag in meinem Leben.
Wahrscheinlich nicht Tischkicker
spielen.
Alter, was sind das wieder für Empfehlungen,
Alter? Vor allem, hier wird es ja
schon langsam Pädobär-mäßig, Alter,
in den Shorts.
Wisst ihr, was ich daran
immer so ein bisschen merkwürdig
finde?
Ohne Scheiß. Die ganzen
Mädels, also klammer mir das
Kind mal aus, ja,
die ganzen Mädels in diesen Shorts,
die sind halb so alt wie
ich. Wenn überhaupt.
Wenn überhaupt.
Also, wenn da eine
schon 20 ist, würde ich mich wundern, ne?
Okay, halb so alt wäre
bei mir ja aktuell nicht 20, sondern
19,5.
Ich bin 39
in ein paar Monaten, ja.
Schlimm, ne?
Boomer Mode enabled.
Nicht anklicken. Die gefährlichste
Malware aller Zeiten.
Oh, das ist ein guter Titel. Das Video geht
bestimmt auch gut.
Was haben wir denn hier noch zu bieten? Serverless was a
big mistake, says Amazon.
Oder Amazon.
Amazon sagt viel, wenn der Tag lang ist. Vor allem, wenn sie
was Neues haben, was sie verkaufen wollen.
Die gefährlichste
Malware aller Zeiten. Okay, das müssen wir uns jetzt mal angucken.
Guck mal hier. Dieser alte
Samsung Laptop aus dem Jahr
2008 ist mehr wert als
ihr jetzt wahrscheinlich denkt.
Er wurde 2019 versteigert und
jetzt rate mal, wie viel Geld der Künstler
Gu Odong... Okay.
Wir raten mal. Wie viel Geld würde er für das Notebook
bezahlen? Es müssen 1,3
Millionen sein, weil
alle anderen sind viel zu gering, um das jetzt in
dem Video zu bringen. Es müssen 1,3
Millionen sein. Weil ganz ehrlich,
er würde dieses Beispiel jetzt nicht in dem Video einbauen,
wenn es 2050 oder sogar
2500 Dollar wären. 1,3 Millionen.
B. Ich logge
ein. Dafür bekommen
ich 1,3 Millionen.
Ja, richtig. 1,345 Millionen US-Dollar.
Das ist viel Geld. Für jemanden wie
dich. Den Betrag hat eine nicht
näher bekannte Person für diesen Laptop
bezahlt und das natürlich nicht, um damit zu
arbeiten oder weil das Ding so schön aussieht,
sondern weil der chinesische Künstler
darauf sechst, der historisch...
Achso, ich kann den Chat übrigens wieder einblenden.
Irgendwelche Tipps
an einen alten Sysadmin, um sich bei
Kubernetes reinzufuchsen.
Ja, mach dir einen
Google-Cloud-Test-Account.
Da kriegst du 300 Dollar
Trial-Guthaben.
Du musst zwar beim Anmelden
Handynummer und Kreditkarte hinterlegen,
allerdings, und das haben sie tatsächlich
ganz gut gemacht im Vergleich
zu AWS und bei Azure bin ich mir
nicht sicher. Ich glaube, da ist es auch nicht gut gemacht.
Solange
du nicht den Account explizit
upgradest, wird nie Geld
abgebucht. Also der Account
bleibt irgendwie 90 Tage oder so im
Trial-Status und in der Zeit kannst du deine
300 Dollar ausgeben. Und
obwohl du Kreditkarte hinterlegt hast, wird nie
was abgebucht, sofern du nicht explizit sagst,
ja, ich möchte upgraden. Auch nach Ende der
Trial...
Ja, der Trial-Periode
nicht.
Und du kannst dann alles Mögliche ausprobieren. Du hast ein paar
minimale Beschränkungen. Du hast
glaube ich pro
Location in der Google-Cloud hast du
glaube ich maximal 300 GB
SSD-Speicher. Also hast du ein paar
kleine Limitierungen, aber
das ist nicht, dass es wirklich
jetzt Probleme machen würde, um sich da
ranzutasten. Also das ist das erste, was
ich machen würde. Ich würde mir ein Google Trial...
Die machen das mit Handynummer
beziehungsweise mit Telefonnummer und Kreditkarte
hauptsächlich deswegen gehe ich stark davon aus,
dass man sich nicht
20 Trial-Accounts
machen lassen kann und darüber dann ein Kubernetes-
Cluster spannen und quasi
immer nur Trial macht
und nie wirklich was bezahlt. Weil überlegt's
euch mal. Man könnte ja theoretisch
...
5 Trial-Accounts machen
und darüber
einen Kubernetes-Cluster spannen
und dann
immer wenn ein Trial-Account
ausläuft, einen neuen Trial-Account machen
in den Cluster reinnehmen und man hätte quasi
einen riesen fetten Cluster
kostenlos für immer.
Und man kann es
on the fly upgraden, die Nodes. Also insofern
also
aus- und wieder reinpacken in den Cluster. Also man könnte
quasi rollierend Update
machen über Trial-Accounts und das
Google vermeiden will, kann ich
verstehen. Ja, die wollen nicht, dass
einer tausende Euro Cloud-Guthaben
pro Monat quasi
als Trial
durchrotiert.
Also das ist das erste, was ich dir empfehlen
kann. Mach dir ein Google. Also es muss nicht
sein. Du kannst auch zu DigitalOcean gehen.
Da ist Managed Kubernetes deutlich günstiger.
Aber Google Cloud hat den Vorteil,
ich finde, die sind zum Einstieg
ganz gut vom Web-Interface her.
Nicht ganz so schick wie Azure, aber
finde ich ganz praktisch.
Wie sie
es gemacht haben.
Und ich finde auch im Kubernetes Umfeld ist
die Google Kubernetes Engine
gerade mit dem Autopilot Cluster, wenn man
nicht so viel Bock hat, sich da selbst mit dem
reinen Setup des Clusters zu beschäftigen,
ganz nett. Ja, dann müsstest du dich halt,
wenn du es auf eigenen
VMs installieren willst, dann müsstest du dich halt
wirklich mal mit dem Setup von einem Kubernetes Cluster
beschäftigen. Da sind ja, würde ich
sagen, zwei so bisschen Wissenschaften für sich.
Das eine ist ein Cluster überhaupt einrichten
und das andere ist ein Cluster betreiben und
registrieren. Man muss nicht zwangsläufig
beides gut können, muss man sagen.
Weil in der heutigen Zeit ist halt vieles
quasi managed.
Und wenn du dir einen Standard Cluster bei Google
holst, ist schon ziemlich viel managed dabei.
Und wenn du dir den Autopilot Cluster
holst, ist alles managed dabei.
Also da musst du noch nicht mal
Nodes provisionieren und sowas. Das macht ja anhand
deines Workloads alles automatisch
nach Google Best Practice,
was auch immer das heißen mag.
Also ein Autopilot Cluster und
Google Kubernetes Engine, Autopilot
Cluster dürfte wahrscheinlich das beste
sein, wenn man sich einfach mal mit Kubernetes
an sich zum wie administriere ich
ein Kubernetes, wie mache ich Anwendungen drauf,
wie mache ich Deployments drauf beschäftigen will,
weil dann muss man sich nicht um
die Cluster, um das Cluster Setup
an sich kümmern. Wenn man das Cluster Setup
an sich sich angucken will, dann
ist das aller einfachste,
nehmen Minikube.
Minikube ist ein
na auf, geh mal auf.
Minikube ist ein Tool, um lokalen
Kubernetes Cluster zum Laufen zu bringen.
Single Node. Das heißt, wenn du
mal wirklich ein Cluster selbst aufsetzen willst
und auch dich drum
kümmern willst, dass ein Ingress Controller
drauf läuft, dass Loadbalancing
funktioniert und solche Geschichten, dann
nehmen Minikube. Das habe ich ja auch schon, haben wir auch schon öfters
öfters im Stream
benutzt. Aktuell gibt es
kein Minikube Cluster. Du kannst
bei mir auf GitHub mal gucken.
Wir haben ein paar
Repos. Ich glaube,
das hier.
Wir haben einmal das
Repo, da habe ich ein bisschen Kubernetes
Setup gemacht und hier eine Test-App
zum Deployen auf Kubernetes.
Dann mach ein Minikube. Mach ein
Minikube lokal und
taste dich da ein bisschen ran, weil das kannst
du easy wegschmeißen. Du sagst dann quasi
Minikube start,
dann kriegst du einen lokalen Cluster
und wenn du fertig bist,
sagst du Minikube delete und es ist wieder
alles weg. Du kannst es entweder in der
VM laufen lassen oder, was ich empfehlen
würde, lass Minikube
starten.
Wenn die ganzen Kubernetes Sachen unter
der Haube über Docker laufen,
dann hast du nämlich gar keine Probleme mehr.
Kannst du alles auf deiner Kiste machen. Alles ist
mega, mega schnell. Achso, ja.
Ich muss Docker restarten, weil ich meine
VM,
naja, meine VM mag das nicht, wenn ich sie
suspende und restarte und
Docker will das nicht.
Ja, und dann hast du Minikube
am Starten. Wenn Minikube läuft,
dann, ich glaube, jetzt habe ich es kaputt
gemacht, weil ich, wenn man Docker
kaputt war wegen dem Image.
Das Problem hast du nicht. Das ist nur, weil...
Ah, ich habe ein
Kernel-Update gemacht. Daran liegt das.
Das liegt gar nicht an
meiner VM. Ich habe ein Kernel-Update
vorhin gemacht und nicht rebooted.
Deswegen geht da die ganze Docker-Geschichte nicht.
Okay, das wird es natürlich erklären.
Lul...
Lulw.
Oh, nicht zu sagen.
Lulhd.
So, Minikube start.
Ja, jetzt
funktioniert der ganze Kernel auch.
So, und dann wirst du sehen, du hast cubectl
get pods, wenn das Ding
gestartet ist. Irgendwann mal
demnächst. Ah, du siehst, jetzt
funktioniert es schon. Also mehr brauchst du nicht. Du brauchst Minikube.
Dann
startet er dir den lokalen Kubernetes-Cluster
im Hintergrund und da hast du hier schon dein
Kernel laufen. Du siehst, der bootet noch.
Ist beispielsweise noch gar nicht gestartet.
So, und dann hast du hier so eine minimal
Kubernetes-Setup, was du
brauchst an
Control-Containern schon dabei.
Ab da musst du die Sachen
halt selbst machen. Von Loadbalancer bis
Ingress, alle möglichen Sachen.
Genau, wenn du fertig bist, sagst du einfach
minikube delete und schon ist
wieder alles weg. Also es ist tatsächlich die beste Art und Weise
lokal sich da ein bisschen ranzutasten.
Klar, lokal funktioniert manche Sachen anders.
Muss man selbst machen im Vergleich zu Google.
Ja, Ingress installieren kannst du bei Google
beispielsweise in Cloud LB benutzen, der ist schon
dabei. Loadbalancer funktioniert
standardmäßig halt auch lokal nicht. Da brauchst du
sowas wie Metal LB. Aber
wenn du dich mit Hintergründen beschäftigen willst,
dann ist das eine gute Sache.
So.
Ich hatte die ganze Zeit den Chat ausgeblendet.
Ich hab den eben gerade erst wieder eingeblendet.
Gut, alles klar. So, dann
gucken wir uns mal das Video hier an.
Die gefährlichste Malware aller Zeiten.
Ja, also sobald du anfangen willst zu
Clustern, ganz ehrlich, die wenigsten
Leute setzen den eigenen Kubernetes-Cluster
wirklich auf. Kann man machen, bei
DigitalOcean ist es auch nur ein Klick und ist
auch günstiger. Da kann man auch sich das
Google Cloud Testguthaben holen.
Let's go.
Wo sind wir stehen geblieben?
1,3 Millionen für einen uralten
Notebook. Okay, nice.
Das ist Kunst?
Ein altes Notebook zu nehmen
und Malware drauf zu installieren?
Ups, falsches...
Warum ist das... Also ich meine ernsthaft,
was ist daran denn Kunst, bitteschön?
... in den USA verboten, für die
Optionen in New York gab es aber eine Ausnahme,
weil... Kunst. Und auch wenn es
Kunst ist, die Malware, die auf dem
Computer installiert ist, hat im Laufe
der Zeit einen unglaublich hohen Schaden
angerichtet. Und das ist doch ein guter
Grund, um sich mal genauer anzuschauen,
warum Malware eigentlich so gefährlich
ist und welche Unterschiede es zwischen den
Schadprogrammen aus dem Jahr 2000...
Ich war noch auf sein Intro. Wo kommt denn das Intro?
Oder gab es das am Anfang schon?
Woran, woran mit seinem Stuhl so
komisch ins Bild rollt? ... und aktueller
Schadsoftware gibt. Und was war
und was ist eigentlich die Motivation,
Leute mit Malware nicht nur zu ärgern,
sondern auch Milliarden...
Die Motivation aktuell
ist eindeutig Geld.
Gerade die letzten Jahre über haben
ja gezeigt, wohin der Trend geht.
Es geht nicht mehr nur um pure, wie soll man
sagen, Fame und Zerstörung,
sondern es geht hauptsächlich
um Geld. Ja, also
wir haben ihre Daten verschlüsselt, überweisen
sie mal ein paar Bitcoins, dann...
... dann werden ihre Daten wieder
verschlüsselt oder ja, wir haben
ihren Office-Fileserver verschlüsselt,
hier einmal Bitcoin überweisen.
Es ist einfach
Geld. ... Euro an wirtschaftlichem
Schaden zu verursachen. Und wie
funktioniert eigentlich der Handel mit Malware?
Bleibt dran. Liebe Hackerin, liebe
Internetsurfer, herzlich willkommen hier.
Erstmal eine Runde Hacker-Typer im Hintergrund.
Bye.
Also eins schon mal vorweg. In der Fachsprache
unterscheidet man bei Schadsoftware
zwischen dem Computer-Virus, dem
Wurm und dem trojanischen
Pferd oder Trojaner, auch wenn umgangssprachlich
eigentlich fast immer von einem
und dem Trojaner
Okay.
Ehrlich
gesagt,
ich hätte gedacht, hier gibt es größere
Überlappungen, aber
war mir so,
wusste ich gar nicht,
dass das die drei
Major-Kategorien sind. Ja, aber ein Virus ist
klar, Trojaner ist klar, Wurm...
Ich dachte irgendwie, das ist so mehr oder weniger
das Gleiche.
Also sprich,
dass man irgendwie Remote-Zugang
auf den, na gut,
muss ja nicht zwangsläufig sein, dass was
eingeschleust wird, wo man dann halt in der
aktuellen Zeit hauptsächlich auch Remote-Zugriff
auf die Systeme bekommt, für irgendeinen Angreifer.
Trojanischen Pferd oder Trojaner,
auch wenn umgangssprachlich eigentlich fast
immer von einem Virus gesprochen wird. Ja, mache ich
auch so. Das alles lässt sich aber unter dem Sammelbegriff Malware
oder Schadsoftware zusammenfassen.
Die erste... Schadware!
Wie das Semper-Video jetzt so
schön sagt, ich...
Wobei, so gut wie er kann das keiner
aussprechen. Schadware...
Ich kann das nicht.
In diesem Video nur ganz kurz.
Schad...ware.
Ne. Das kann nur er so gut.
Die erste bekannte Schadsoftware für
Computer ist älter als ich. Anfang
der 70er Jahre hat sich ein Computerwurm namens
Creeper im Internet
Vorgänger ARPANET verbreitet.
Das ist einfach 50
Jahre her. War Malware nur ein theoretisches
Konzept und hat vor allem in der Science-Fiction
Literatur stattgefunden. Ja, und dann
kam Bob Thomas, ein Entwickler,
der am Vorgänger des Internets
mitgearbeitet hat und mit Creeper ein Programm
geschrieben hat, das sich selbstständig innerhalb
eines Netzwerks verbreitet. Creeper
hat zwar keine Dateien gelöscht, dafür aber
infizierte Computer mit einer
Textnachricht auf dem Bildschirm kurzzeitig
lahmgelegt.
Daher kommt sicherlich nicht...
Creeper...
Die Leute heutzutage würden sagen,
Creeper, ich denk sofort an Minecraft.
...hat das Zeitalter der Malware begonnen.
Und diese Virenwürmer und Trojaner wurden
mit der Zeit halt immer gefährlicher und
wirtschaftlich gesehen teurer.
Allein der erste Wurm, der auf dem versteigerten
Notebook war, hat einen wirtschaftlichen Schaden
von bis zu 15 Milliarden US-Dollar
angerichtet. Und dieser Wurm hatte
den Namen I Love You oder auch...
Ah, okay. Von dem
hat sicherlich jeder schon mal was gehört.
Auch Leute, die 2000
noch nicht around waren. Ich war ja
da schon am Start. Ich war da 16.
Kann man sich gar nicht vorstellen, ne?
Das hat jeder schon mal
gehört.
Der hat sich im Mai 2000 explosionsartig
verbreitet und war damit der erste
Computerwurm, der so richtig für
Aufsehen gesorgt hat.
Ein als Liebesbrief getarnter
E-Mail-Virus hat sich heute
weltweit lawinenartig in
Computersystemen ausgebreitet.
Das Virus tauchte unter der Betreffzeile
I Love You auf den
Computerbildschirmen auf.
Einfach gesagt hat er sich das menschliche Bedürfnis
nach Liebe zunutze gemacht und den Opfern...
Das Video ist gut geschnitten von denen.
Die sind nicht so aufdringlich dauer
Jumpcut und Rumgespringe und
Gemache, aber die sind so, dass man gerne hinguckt.
...in einer Mail einen Liebesbrief
versprochen. Das Ganze sah auch der Zeit
entsprechend noch recht simpel aus.
Ah, gutes Outlook Express oder was das...
Leute, das ist doch bestimmt Outlook Express.
Das sah damals so aus.
Damals sind die Leute noch auf sowas reingefallen.
Und wisst ihr,
was das Witzige ist? Die Leute fallen halt immer noch auf sowas
rein. In der Betreffzeile
stand einfach I Love You und der Text war
eine einfache Aufforderung, den angehängten
Liebesbrief zu öffnen. Und das
war wohl viel entscheidender als
die Qualität des Quellcodes
von den Philippinen.
Was ist hier passierend?
Er kopiert
irgendwelche
Sachen
in das Windows-Verzeichnis,
was ja eigentlich nichts Besonderes
war. Damit gilt I Love You auch als
die erste flächendeckende Verwendung von
Social Engineering, also quasi
der psychologischen
Stipulation von Menschen.
Insgesamt waren wohl 45 Millionen Leute
weltweit von diesem Wurm betroffen.
Dabei war I Love You auch eine der
ersten Mailwares, die sich über das Öffnen
eines Mail-Anhangs verbreitet hat.
Dieser Anhang hat auf dem PC des Opfers
dann ein Skript ausgeführt.
Hat man sich den Wurm eingefangen, hat er
alle Dateien auf dem Computer überschrieben
und mit einer Kopie von sich selbst
ersetzt. Außerdem hat er allen Kontakten über Outlook
eine Mail mit einem weiteren Liebesbrief
gesendet. Und so hat sich der Wurm immer
weiter ver... Ja, da kann ich mich noch dran erinnern.
Das war ein riesen Ding damals.
Wie gesagt, ich war damals 16.
Ich war auch schon
im Internet. Aber mich hat damals
schon keiner geliebt. Ich hab nicht mal
I Love You Viren bekommen.
Ich kann mich zumindest nicht
daran erinnern, dass ich den
bekommen hätte.
Aber ich war auf jeden Fall schon
im Internet. Also ich weiß das daran.
Also ich mach das immer an folgenden...
Ich mach das immer an folgenden
Punkten fest. Also es gibt so
ein paar Meilensteine
so Computer
Usage mäßig bei mir, wo ich
immer so ein bisschen dran feststellen kann.
Okay, wann war denn
ungefähr was? Also das erste
bei mir ist 1997 Half-Life Release.
Das weiß ich. 1997,
weil das hab ich rauf und runter gespielt.
Dort noch Offline
mit den Leuten. Teilweise per Modem,
teilweise über ISDN und ein bisschen
später
dann online
über DSL.
Wie gesagt, ich hab's ja schon oft
erzählt. Ich hatte einen der ersten DSL-Anschlüsse
hier in Hanau, den es gegeben hat.
Damals noch 768K
war das.
Mit diesem fetten DSL-Modem.
Und das weiß ich,
weil 2001, 2002
rum hab ich Dark Age of Camelot angefangen,
MMO Kreiselgrind und solche Geschichten.
Danach hab ich dann so
2007, 2008 mit dem
Fabian, also mit dem Friseur ganz viel
Xbox Online gespielt.
Es gibt so ein paar Abstände,
die kann ich mir nicht wirklich in Jahreszahlen direkt merken,
aber anhand der Ereignisse, die da
gewesen ist. Ja, 2010
hab ich einen YouTube-Channel gemacht und solche Geschichten.
So kann ich mich da immer dran langhangeln,
so wann denn ungefähr was gewesen ist.
...verbreitet und
dabei insgesamt einen Schaden zwischen 10
und 15 Milliarden US-Dollar
angerichtet. Also schätzt man. Der Schaden
war vor allem deswegen so hoch, weil durch die
immer größere Menge an E-Mails schnell
viele Mail-Server überlastet waren. Und weil
der Wurm nachträglich einen Trojaner installiert hat,
der sich beim Öffnen des Internet Explorer
sensible Daten... Was natürlich
sonst, oder Leute?
Was sonst außer dem Internet Explorer?
...an Passwörter per Mail gesendet hat.
Betroffen waren nicht nur viele Privatnutzer, sondern
auch das Pentagon, das britische Parlament
oder die CIA.
Der Urheber des I... Der I Love You
Virus war von Deutschen gemacht, also in dem
in dem Titel der Datei stand irgendwas von
den Philippinen. Love You Worms war
der philippinische... Siehste? Philippinen.
...Informatikstudent Onel de
Guzman. Er konnte aber nicht angeklagt werden,
da das Programmieren und Verbreiten von
Malware damals auf den Philippinen noch
keine Straftat war.
Guter Ratschlag
an alle Kriminellen, wenn ihr kriminell
sein wollt, ihr müsst auf eine
Art und Weise kriminell sein,
die noch nie jemand
vorher ausgenutzt
hat. Dann habt ihr ne gewisse Chance
straffrei durchzugehen.
Aber die meisten werden dann nicht
pfeifett genug für sein.
Putz dann aber direkt danach.
Vier Jahre später, 2004,
wurde der Computerwurm MyDoom
Da kann ich mich auch noch dunkel dran erinnern.
erstmals entdeckt. Experten zufolge
handelt es sich bei MyDoom um den
größten Malware-Ausbruch seiner Zeit.
Es ist natürlich schwer, genau zu
beziffern, wie sich der Virus genau
ausgewirkt hat, aber es gibt immer Auswertungen
von Antivirenfirmen, die ja sehen,
wie viel Malware sie gefiltert haben.
Die Antivirenfirma F-Secure hat damals
von bis zu 30% aller Mails
gesprochen, die mit MyDoom... Boah, das war
schon krasses Zeug. Ich mein, heute
ist das kein Ding. Heute sind,
glaube ich, 98% oder so
der Mails Spam
und Bullshit.
Ich glaube sogar,
dass es die letzten Jahre über minimal
gesunken ist. Es schwankt immer so. Ich glaube,
es waren 98% oder sowas.
Aber 30%
des E-Mail-Verkehrs
nur davon, also das ist zur damaligen
Zeit schon enorm viel.
Und dadurch waren viele E-Mail-Postfächer
schnell voll und haben nicht mehr funktioniert.
Und das lag auch an der Effizienz, die
der Wurm an den Tag gelegt hat.
Verschickt wurde er in Mails mit dem Betreff
Error oder Delivery failed.
Und der CEO dieser Mails hat damals selbst erfahren...
Moment, was? Es ist ein
Screensaver! Ich fasse es nicht,
Leute! Hat jemand mal
ein Video geguckt, wo ich gezeigt habe,
wo mich die Scammer gebeten wollten auf
YouTube? Das war auch
ein Screensaver. Die können mir doch nicht
erzählen, dass seit 2004
über die gleiche
Art und Weise Viren
unter Windows eingeschleust werden, nämlich
das gefakte Screensaver.
Seit 2004!
Delivery failed und
der Stil dieser Mails hat damals selbst
erfahrene Nutzer dazu gebracht, auf den Wurm
reinzufallen. Wenn man dann die
angehängte Exe-Datei angeklickt hat,
hat sich der Wurm auf dem Windows-PC
eingenistet, indem er sich in der
Windows Registry verankert hat.
Dann hat er auf dem PC nach allen
verfügbaren E-Mail-Adressen gesucht, um sich
dann selbst weiterzusenden. Dazu hat er
extra einen einfachen Mail-Server auf dem
befallenen Computer installiert. Gleichzeitig hat
der Wurm eine Backdoor auf dem PC der Opfer
eingerichtet und darüber war es möglich, den PC
aus der Ferne zu steuern und
etwa für einen DDoS-Angriff
zu nutzen. Also DDoS, dass einfach
ganz viele Rechner ganz viele Anfragen
irgendwo hinschicken und dadurch diesen Server dann lahmlegen.
Und genau das haben sie dann einige
Tage später auch gemacht. Am 1. Februar...
Die Extension wird ja unter Windows
standardmäßig nicht angezeigt, was ich übrigens
nicht nachvollziehen kann, warum das immer noch
der Default ist. ... wurden die Server
des Softwareunternehmens SCO
massiv überlastet, sodass die Website
nicht mehr erreichbar war. Das haben die Kriminellen
geschafft, indem sie die verschiedenen infizierten
Computer gleichzeitig auf die Website der
Firma haben zugreifen lassen. Aber das wirklich
perfide an diesen Würmern ist, dass die Betroffenen
ohne ein Anti-Viren-Programm
nicht mal bemerkt hätten, dass ihre
eigenen PCs gerade massenhaft Mails
verschickt und an einem Angriff beteiligt
waren. MyDoom scheint besonders effektiv
zu sein, weil er auch sogar heute noch aktiv
ist. Laut Palo Alto net...
Ernsthaft?
1,1%?
Geil...
Das hätte ich nicht gedacht.
... einem Anbieter von Cyber-Sicherheitsprodukten
befand sich MyDoom 2019
noch in etwa 1% aller
Mails mit Malware, die von ihnen überprüft
wurden. Und das fast 20 Jahre
später. Interessant.
Aber auch die nächste
Schadsoftware hat eine steile Karriere
hinter sich. Angefangen hat die
berüchtigte Malware Emotet im Jahr
Okay, da kann ich mich auch noch dran
erinnern. 14 Mal als Trojaner,
der Kundendaten von deutschen und österreichischen
Banken über den Browser abgefangen hat.
Und ist dann zu einer der größten Trojaner
Gefahren der aktuellen Zeit geworden.
Besonders gefährlich ist Emotet, weil es durch
sogenanntes Outlook-Harvesting in der Lage ist,
sehr echt wirkende Spam-Mails
zu versenden. Emotet liest Kontaktbeziehungen
und E-Mail-Inhalte aus und
so erhalten Empfänger fingierte Mails
von Absendern,
mit denen sie wirklich erst kürzlich
in Kontakt standen. Und auch der Inhalt der
Mails sieht nicht wie klassischer Spam
aus, sondern bezieht sich auf ein echtes
Mailgespräch. Diese Technik nennt sich
Spearfishing.
Es geht dabei darum, dass man nicht einfach nur
eine Spam-Mail schreibt, die super schnell als
solche zu erkennen ist. Stattdessen wird die Nutzerin
oder Nutzer im Vorfeld ausspioniert
und bekommt dann eine individuell
zugeschnittene Mail mit dem Schadprogramm
als Anhang. Emotet hat diese
Technik sozusagen auf Massenbasis
gebracht. Auch hier bei Heise
hat Emotet schon eingeschlagen. War bestimmt
äußerst erfolgreich. Und das ging damals super schnell.
Es hat ein E-Mail-Anhang
auf dem Windows-Rechner gereicht.
Hat die Sekretärin mal wieder verkehrt geklickt.
Und schon war unser
Netzwerk infiziert. Wie genau Heise
von Emotet betroffen war, seht ihr
übrigens in diesem Video bei Heise
online.
Vielleicht war es auch der Sekretär.
Nicht das jetzt hier ist
Sexism oder so.
Emotet hat dann weitere Schadsoftware
heruntergeladen. Emotet bietet anderen
Cyberkriminellen nämlich an, ihre Schadsoftware
auf den gehackten PCs zu installieren.
Und das kann für betroffene Opfer dann
richtig schmerzhaft werden. Denn wenn Emotet
vor allem das Ziel verfolgt, möglichst viele PCs
zu befallen und sich in Netzwerken auszubreiten,
haben andere Programme oft das Ziel, Daten
oder Passwörter zu stehlen und die Nutzer
dann zu erpressen. Eine der
Lücken, die Emotet verwendet, nennt sich
Eternal Blue. Das ist ein Exploit,
den die NSA gefunden hatte und
jahrelang für sich selbst benutzt hat,
ehe ihre Entdeckung von der Gruppe
The Shadow Brokers geleakt wurde.
Im Anschluss hat die NSA die Lücken
Das finde ich interessant, ja.
an Microsoft gemeldet.
Dabei hat Eternal Blue eine Schwachstelle
im Netzwerk-Kommunikationsprotokoll
Samba ausgenutzt und das wurde schon 1983
entwickelt und sollte eigentlich dafür sorgen,
Ja gut, Samba ist uralt,
zumindest, weil mit Samba ist ja mittlerweile
Version 4 oder 3 oder sowas,
gibt's ja auch schon ein paar Neuauflagen von
... dass Nutzer gemeinsam auf Dateien
oder Drucker zugreifen können. Wenn ihr jetzt
bei solchen professionellen Malwares
an irgendwelche super ausgestatteten
Computerlabore
aus einem Hollywoodfilm
denkt, dann guckt mal hier. Die ukrainische
Polizei teilt hier auf YouTube
immer wieder Videos, wie sie
komplizierte Malware-Kriminelle festnehmen.
Hier zum Beispiel wurden zwei
Was ist denn das für ein Loch, Alter?
Menschen in der Ukraine festgenommen,
die aus diesem Haus ein Emotet-Netzwerk
betrieben haben sollen.
Der Staubsauger liegt bestimmt daneben,
weil die
der CPU-Lüfter an sich schon nicht mal
funktioniert oder sowas.
Der wird mit dem Staubsauger gekühlt.
Das sieht jetzt irgendwie nicht so aus.
Und daneben liegt irgendwie die
Kopfschmerztabletten oder sowas.
Alter, was ein Ding, ey.
... Netzwerk betrieben haben sollen.
Sieht jetzt irgendwie nicht so aus, wie man sich organisierte
Kriminalität im großen Stil vorstellt,
oder? Aber laut der ukrainischen
... PCI-Slots, Poggers, IDE
und PCI-Slots, das ist ja hier
absolut Technik vom Feinsten.
... Polizei soll der Schaden mehr als
2,5 Millionen ... Okay, der Rechner sieht
halbwegs, halbwegs okay aus.
... den US-Dollar betragen. Klar, da haben auch noch viele ...
Hauptsache
RGB-Lüfter, Mann.
Alles andere übelst ...
Alles andere
übelst versifft und übelst räudig.
Aber ein RGB-Lüfter, der muss
sein. Das ist schon ein paar Jahre her.
Aber für RGB-Lüfter hat's gereicht
anscheinend. Oh, ein Raid.
Die Raspberry Pi-Clone
hat geradet. Dankeschön für den Raid.
Poggers.
Wir haben letztens übrigens, glaube ich, auch ein ...
Wobei wollte ich nicht ... Ich bin mir
nicht sicher, ob ich letztens ein Video nicht
gucken wollte von dir auf dem
YouTube-Channel oder ob wir sogar geguckt haben.
Nee, stimmt. Ich wollte ...
Ich wollte, glaube ich, das Hetzner-Video bei dir
gucken, aber wir haben das Hetzner-Video tatsächlich
dann bei ...
... Hardware-Deals, glaube ich, geguckt.
Aber ...
Danke für den Host.
Man würde davon ausgehen, dass die Geld haben,
aber ich mein, anscheinend wurde das
ganze Geld in RGB-Lüfter gesteckt.
Ich mein, man sieht's hier ...
Das ist das beste Beispiel für, ja?
Das ist das beste Beispiel für,
was man hier wieder dran sieht. Wenn man Prioritäten
setzen kann, dann
ist RGB-Lüfter das
Allerwichtigste. Sogar Malware-Netze
laufen schneller mit RGB-Lüftern.
Die Hetzner-Videos sind alle unterschiedlich.
Das stimmt. Vielleicht sollten wir uns das andere
Video nachher auch noch angucken.
Aber ich hätte jetzt halt gedacht, dass die Videos ... Ich hab mir auch
das vom Bauer und so nicht angeguckt.
Ich hätte jetzt eigentlich gedacht, dass
ziemlich viele Überschneidungen sind.
Äh, wat?
Dein VM Champ ist mega.
Funktioniert das mit der SSH-Unterstützung?
Ja, achso. Nee, wie funktioniert das mit der
SSH? Äh, ich kann nicht richtig reden.
Mit der ZSH-Unterstützung.
Ähm, das ist
eine Completion
Function,
die du über VM Champ
Complete, glaube ich,
aufrufen kannst. Dann spuckt dir das in der
Kommandozeile aus, was der macht.
Ähm, ich kann ...
Ich will jetzt nicht so auf gar viel
Technik eingehen,
weil ich gehe davon aus, dass es viele auch, die
den Stream nicht verfolgt haben, jetzt gar nicht mitkommen würden.
Ähm, du kannst jetzt aber ... Also, wenn du
es genau wissen willst, wie das funktionieren will,
noch mal ganz kurz. Du gehst bei mir einfach auf GitHub.
Das ganze Ding ist ja eh Open Source.
Und da kannst du dir rein ...
Kannst du dir hier angucken, wie das mit den ...
mit der Completion funktioniert.
Hier am Anfang siehst du es hier.
Das ist ... Das ist im Prinzip das,
was für die Completion sorgt.
Ja, das ist die ...
Das ist die Sache, die exportiert wird.
Für ZSH.
Und anhand dieser Geschichte erkennt
ZSH dann, wie man completen muss.
Und die eigentliche Completion selbst,
der Kommandos,
die passiert bei den einzelnen Befehlen.
Also, wenn du hier zum Beispiel den ...
dir den Run-Befehl anguckst,
da siehst du hier am Anfang, er macht
Completion.
Hier, guck. Completion Options.
Kannst du setzen.
Und das wird alles mit diesem ZSH-Export
miteinander verdrahtet, ja.
Dieses Complete muss ins ZSH-RC rein.
Ja, das steht ja auch. Steht ja auch hier. Guck da.
Das musst du machen.
Wenn du das einfach
nur ausführst, dann kriegst du halt diese Completion
Function. Und wenn du das
sourcest in deiner ... Also, genauso wie es
drinnen steht, in deine ZSH-RC reinschreibst,
dann funktioniert es.
Dann kannst du zum Beispiel auch sowas machen wie
vmchamp, run, äh, keine Ahnung,
memory, tap tap tap,
das da. Ja.
Das funktioniert dann.
Vielleicht gucken wir uns nachher tatsächlich nochmal
die anderen Hetzner-Videos an.
Muss ich mal schauen. Oder sagen wir mal, vielleicht den einen bei
nächsten Streams. Ich bin ja schon drei Minuten, äh, drei Stunden
elf wieder, wieder am Start.
Trotzdem danke schon nochmal für den Host.
Poggers. Äh, Onessi, danke schon
für den Sub.
Ja, bei AliExpress gibt's die Lüfter
schon billig. Also RGB-Lüfter
an sich, das war jetzt ja auch eher als
Spaß gemeint, aber RGB-Lüfter an sich
sind sicherlich jetzt kein super Qualitätsmerkmal
von irgendwas. Billigste
RGB-Lüfter findest du überall.
Äh, also.
Es gibt bestimmt sogar LC-Power-Netzteile
mittlerweile mit RGB-Lüfter.
Warum hat Hetzner
keine RGB-Server-Options?
Das müsste ich sie tatsächlich mal fragen, warum das
nicht so ist. Ja.
Ja, wir müssten eh mal
gucken, dass wir wieder ein paar
Sponsor-Streams oder sowas
an Land ziehen. Muss ich mal den
Moritz fragen, ob er sich da mal mit denen in Kontakt
setzen kann. Weil
es gibt ja ein paar neue Sachen, die man durchaus mal zeigen
könnte. Wir könnten beispielsweise einen
Mini-Kobanenis-Cluster mal aufbauen
bei Hetzner. Also komplett mit
selbst gemanagt.
Oder uns vielleicht auch mal die neue
ARM-Server angucken oder irgendwelche
Geschichten da in der Richtung.
Ja, da müsste ich sie tatsächlich mal
fragen, warum
gibt es keine RGB-Server?
Und wir müssten mal weitergehen. Nicht nur RGB-Lüfter,
sondern wir brauchen selbstverständlich auch
RGB-RAM. Ja.
Und RGB-Netzteil-Lüfter,
RGB-Gehäuselüfter,
um die letzten paar Performance-
Boosts aus unseren Kisten rauszuholen.
Hast du eigentlich
Videos zu deinem Arch-Terminal
wie das
eingerichtet ist? Ja, es gibt
im Archiv
es gibt im Archiv
gibt es Streams,
wo ich die Kiste
eingerichtet habe. Musst du hier mal gucken.
Arch, Arch by the way.
Ne, hier haben wir ein Package gebaut.
Also du kannst im Archiv gucken.
Wubblos.tv
Aber, was dir wahrscheinlich
noch ein bisschen mehr hilft ist, du kannst
bei mir auf GitHub schauen. Da hab ich
die ganzen Config-Files liegen.
Zwar hier.
Da hast du die ganzen Config-Files für
die Shell und auch
für das Terminal.
Das hier ist die Terminal-Config.
In den Datasendern
gibt es keine RGB-Dinger. Wozu soll
das? Gut, jetzt.
Wo sind wir denn hier gelandet, dass RGB
in Frage gestellt wird?
Das ist wissenschaftlich
bewiesen.
Das kann ich nicht verstehen.
Also wie kann man ernsthaft davon ausgehen,
dass es nichts bringt?
Unverständnis pur.
Siehste, der Chat weiß Bescheid.
RGB-Deniers.
Jetzt mal, Fun Fact.
Fun Fact. Wir hatten bei uns,
also auf der alten Arbeit, im Keller
in diesem Mini-Rechenzentrum, wir hatten ja mehrere Standorte
und an dem einen im Keller war halt
so ein bisschen kleineres. Da hatten wir tatsächlich
mal einen Case-Moded-Server stehen.
Da hat irgendeiner so eine
Leucht-RGB-Röhre reingepappt.
Ich weiß bis heute nicht warum.
Es war der merkwürdigste
Anblick ever, als ich das Ding aufgeschraubt
hab damals, dass da eine RGB-Röhre
drin ist. Und das war keine
RGB. Das war so eine,
wie man früher Case-Moding gemacht hat,
mit so Leucht-Röhren und sowas drin.
Hä? Warum?
Warum ist da so eine Leucht-Röhre drin?
Spielst du eigentlich noch Battlefield
2042? Ich würde gerne mal
wieder ein bisschen spielen. Aktuell gibt's halt wenig
Anreiz, es zu spielen.
Bei Season 5 spätestens wieder.
Gucken, ob's da was
Gescheites gibt.
Also RGB-Deniers sind ja wirklich
cringe. Du hörst doch Metal,
oder? Schon das Doom-Cover von denen
hab ich nicht gesehen. Aber ja, hör ich.
Hör ich.
Beste.
Wo wir bei guten Spiele-Soundtracks
sind, massive
nicer Soundtrack.
Okay. Ich will
für die Leute, die jetzt nicht auf so Musik stehen, dass
ich zu sehr übertreibe.
Ja. Nee, aber
das kenn ich noch nicht.
Es kamen schon viele ziemlich
nicht unbedingt schlechte,
aber technisch mies umgesetzte
Games.
Das kann sein. Irgendwie sowas hab ich mal
bei uns im Rechenzentrum in so einer selbstgebauten Kiste
gefunden. Das ist alles schon ein bisschen her.
Wie gesagt, das war noch, als ich beim Provider gearbeitet hab.
Da gab es noch Leute,
die haben irgendwelche selbstgebauten Kisten ins
Rack geschoben und sowas. Dabei hatte einer
halt so eine RGB-Röhre drin. Das Ding hab ich
aufgemacht und hab gedacht, hä?
Warum ist da RGB-Beleuchtung im Server drin?
Das waren aber eh noch bisschen
andere Zeiten.
Das waren die Zeiten, wo
im Rechenzentrum Patchpanel
noch so ausgesehen haben.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee.
Ich muss eher nach
Kabel-Salat suchen wahrscheinlich.
Ja.
Wo Patchpanel noch so, also
Netzwerkschränke und Patchpanel-Sachen noch so
ausgeschaut haben. Die Zeit war das.
Und ich wette mit euch, in vielen Rechenzentrumen
sieht das heute immer noch so aus.
Ja.
Also unsere, unsere Sache
damals in dem, in dem Main
Verkabelungs-Netzwerk-Dings
Rack in dem einen Rechenzentrum,
das war noch voller.
Das war so voll.
Leider hab ich davon nie, oder
hab ich davon mal Bilder gemacht? Ich weiß es nicht.
Ich muss auch meine ganz alten iPhone-Backups
durchsuchen, ob ich davon vielleicht nicht
irgendwann mal ein Bild gemacht hab.
Zumindest,
diese Dinger hier waren bei uns so voll,
du hast die ganzen Panels nicht mehr gesehen
und du hast den, den, die Tür
auch nicht mehr zugekriegt. Die hier haben's clever gemacht,
die haben auch nicht mal ne Tür, aber unsere Racks
hatten halt Türen und die konnte man theoretisch
abschließen, aber die hatten jemand abgeschlossen, man konnte
so nen Hebel, so nen Hebel runter machen.
Und die Tür ging nicht
mehr zu und es hat sich auch keiner getraut,
die Tür zuzudrücken. Ja, so.
So. Da ist es ganz so krass nicht.
Es hat sich aber auch keiner getraut, die Tür
zuzudrücken vom Schrank, weil
man wusste, dass manche Kabel so alt waren und
klapperig, dass sie Wackelkontakte hatten
und wenn du die Tür zugedrückt hättest, hättest
du entweder Pech gehabt und hättest Glasfaserkabel
abgeknickt oder du hättest
Wackelkontaktkabel halt in den Wackelkontakt
reingedrückt und
im Prinzip waren alle an diesem Schrank,
der sah tatsächlich ein bisschen so aus wie der hier bei uns,
waren alle äußerst
vorsichtig,
Reddit Cable
fail, waren alle äußerst, also
extrem vorsichtig, wenn sie das
Ganze angefasst haben.
Boah.
Weil sie halt Angst hatten, dass sie
irgendwas kaputt machen und ich glaube eines der
größten Ausfälle, die ich mal produziert
habe bei mir auf der Arbeit
damals war, ich hatte den
Auftrag, ich sollte einen neuen ESX Server patchen.
Da war ich noch Azubi.
Also das ist wirklich schon ewig her.
Da war ich noch Azubi, ich sollte einen neuen ESX Server patchen.
Da war ich mit Felix zusammen
drüber. Felix kennt vielleicht noch den einen oder
anderen, wir haben auch ein paar Videos früher zusammen
aufgenommen.
Wir haben auch bis vor kurzem
noch zusammen gearbeitet.
Aber jetzt beim neuen Arbeitgeber
ist der Felix nicht mehr mit am Start.
Aber wer weiß, vielleicht mal wieder
irgendwann in Zukunft.
Zumindest haben sie Felix und mich rübergeschickt
und wir sollten einen neuen ESX Server
patchen. Haben wir gemacht, exakt dort
wo es der Plan vorgesehen hat.
Das dumme war nur, dass du
halt, um das Kabel dort ordentlich rein
zu kriegen und das zu verfolgen,
das alte Kabel halt abmachen musstest
und das neue dran und dabei haben wir irgendeinen
Wackelkontakt ausgelöst, was dazu
geführt hat, dass es,
ich müsste jetzt lügen, wenn ich genau wüsste,
was das eigentliche Problem
wäre jetzt nach all den Jahren. Zumindest
gab es einige Probleme netzwerktechnisch
und auf einmal standen irgendwie drei Leute
im Rechenzentrum, oh, was habt ihr gemacht?
Und damals haben sie was probiert,
das nehme ich meinem damaligen Chef heute noch
übel. Und zwar,
wir haben nichts verkehrt gemacht, wir haben
exakt das gemacht,
was beauftragt wurde bei uns.
Nämlich dort
das Kabel ab und dort den ESX
dran. So, der
eigentliche Fail war der Plan
und das, wie es vorher
gepatcht wurde. Also wir haben nichts verkehrt gemacht,
wir haben es wirklich exakt so gemacht, wie es beauftragt wurde
bei uns. Und mein damaliger Chef
hat
gesagt, die Azubis haben es kaputt gemacht,
weil sein Hintergedanke war,
Azubis kriegen ja keinen Ärger.
Und ich habe auch
immer gesagt, so nach dem Motto, ey, das ist genau
das, was ihr wolltet, was wir gemacht haben. Und das haben
auch alle gesagt, ja, ihr könnt da nichts für.
Aber ich habe dann später mitbekommen, auf
Runden weiter oben, wurde
erzählt, ah ja, unsere Azubis haben komisches Zeug
gemacht, ist ja auch
klar, sind ja Azubis, die wissen ja nicht genau, was sie machen
und dann wurde das damit
abgebügelt.
Ich meine, an sich könnte man sagen,
clevere Entscheidung, gibt es keinen Ärger, weil man kann sagen,
die Azubis waren es, die Azubis wird man eh nicht los.
Aber unterm Strich, wirklich, eigentlich
eine Sache, richtig,
richtig, richtig
Arschmuff, ja. Und das nehme ich ihm auch heute
noch übel,
das, was damals so gemacht wurde. Weil wir haben nichts
verkehrt gemacht. Ne.
Das hat mich damals wirklich sehr
getriggert, würde man heute sozusagen.
Kennt ihr noch Ferritkernspeicher?
Ne, das ist
tatsächlich vor meiner Zeit
gewesen. Also,
das war ja noch an Zeiten, wo du
Arbeitsspeicher, die einzelnen Speicherzellen
angesehen hast.
Das waren solche,
ja, solche Magneten,
solche Netze, genau.
Ne, das war noch vor meiner Zeit.
Also, ich bin
1984 geboren
und ich mache das, also mit Linux
beschäftige ich mich seit ungefähr so, sagen wir mal
2000,
2005?
Professionell dann seit 2007.
Aber diese Zeit,
ne, da gab es mich noch nicht.
Dann verstehe ich auch, warum du
RGB nicht magst.
Für dich ist RGB wahrscheinlich so ein neumodischer Kram,
den keiner braucht, oder?
Leute, was meint ihr denn, warum
ich da abgehauen bin?
Das ist das gleiche Laden, wo ich euch die Videos
von dem Teambuilding-Workshop erzählt habe.
Das war voll für den Arsch.
Deswegen bin ich ja da auch so schnell,
wie es geht nach der Ausbildung weg. Ich war noch ein Jahr
nach der Ausbildung da und bin woanders hin.
Der Laden war kacke.
Sowas sollte eigentlich nicht passieren.
Okay, das ist nochmal ne ganze Ecke mehr.
Nun gut, wir gucken jetzt das Video erstmal fertig.
Wo ist es denn überhaupt?
Hier, die gefährlichste Malware aller Zeiten.
War das der Tele...
Nein, nein, nein, das war...
Das war nicht die Telekom,
wo ich meine Ausbildung gemacht habe.
Übrigens, den Provider, wo ich meine
Ausbildung gemacht habe, gibt es heute unter dem
alten Namen gar nicht mehr.
Die sind pleite gegangen,
oder, tja, sag mal, ich weiß nicht, ob die
wirklich pleite gegangen sind, aber die sind
in Zahlungsschwierigkeiten gekommen und
wurden dann übernommen von einem
größeren Anbieter. Also dort, wo ich meine
Ausbildung gemacht habe, den Provider gibt es heute
in der Form gar nicht mehr.
Den gibt es noch, aber unter anderem Namen.
Ja, ratet ihr mal weiter.
Nichts zu sagen.
Viele andere Kriminelle auf der ganzen Welt mitgemacht,
aber trotzdem irgendwie anders.
Nein, Kabel Deutschland war es auch nicht.
Als man sich das vielleicht vorstellt.
Und da fragt man sich ja auch, wie läuft das eigentlich
genau ab? Also wie kommen diese
Kriminellen eigentlich an die Malware?
Und das habe ich mal meinen Kollegen Jürgen...
Wie die Kriminelle an die Malware kommen? Ja, es gibt ein paar,
die entwickeln Malware, und es gibt viele,
die kaufen sich Malware einfach ein.
Schmidt von
Heise Security gefragt. Ja, sag mal Jürgen,
wie finden diese Kriminellen eigentlich
die Sicherheitslücken? Genau Jürgen, erklär uns das mal.
Das ist mittlerweile erschreckend
einfach geworden, weil es gibt da ein
ganzes Ökosystem im Untergrund,
wo unheimlich
viele Dienste as a Service
angeboten werden. Du kannst da sozusagen
Ransomware mieten.
Also du bekommst von
einem Ransom...
Du kannst ja nicht nur Malware mieten oder kaufen
oder basteln lassen. Du kannst ja auch die passenden
Exploiter für einkaufen und sonst was.
Das heißt halt ein richtig, richtig großer
Markt dahinter,
wo halt auch massig Kohle drinsteckt.
Sonst würden die Leute das Risiko ja nicht eingehen.
Und man muss halt auch mal sagen,
dass die Chance,
das sage ich jetzt, ohne dass ich persönliche
Erfahrungen damit hätte, bevor jetzt wieder
einer komische Sachen vermutet,
dass die Chance,
dass du erwischt wirst,
meiner Ansicht nach auch relativ gering ist.
Klar, wenn du bei was richtig
Großem vielleicht mal involviert warst,
wo dann auch richtig viel Geld dahinter steckt
und international gesucht wird und
alles, mag das sein,
aber es gibt ja so viele kleinere
Malware-Angriffe und sonst was, dass man
an die... Also dass ein Malware-Entwickler
da im Hintergrund jetzt großartig
geschnappt wird,
ließ immer mal wieder was.
Aber im Großen und Ganzen würde ich fast behaupten,
lebt man als Malware-Entwickler
relativ sicher.
Und dass man da erwischt wird,
würde ich mal sagen, sind die Chancen
relativ gering. Wenn man weiß, was man macht.
Was wahrscheinlich auch ein Grund
sein wird, warum das so sprießt und gelingt.
Beide.
Malware as a Service-Anbieter
bekommst du einen Baukasten
mit einem grafischen Frontend,
wo du dir dann letztlich deine
Malware zusammenklicken kannst.
Du kannst dir einen Namen geben, du kannst
die Erpressermeldung da als Textdatei
reinschmeißen.
Also meine Erpressermeldung wäre eindeutig...
Kannst diverse...
Das war's. Nur das.
Parameter einstellen und dann
spuckt dir das am Ende ein Programm aus.
Das ist deine Malware.
Dinge kann man im Internet
Der Weep-Champ.
für vergleichsweise
wenig Geld mieten.
Das heißt, man hat dann
irgendein Abkommen mit dem
eigentlichen Hersteller, diesem
Ransomware-as-a-Service-Anbieter
und der bekommt dann
je nachdem, wie gut du als Kunde
bist, irgendwas zwischen
30 und 80 Prozent
deiner Einnahmen aus.
Boah. Na gut, der hat aber auch
das Risiko.
Je nachdem, wie du es verteilst.
Dafür nimmt er dir aber auch noch
eine ganze Menge andere Sachen ab.
Also diese ganze Geschichte mit
Management der Schlüssel
für die Verschlüsselung, das
Kryptozeug, die Infrastruktur
für das Geldwaschen und so weiter.
All Dienst ist dann sehr häufig
in diesen Paketen mit drin.
Das heißt, das ist für
0815-Kriminelle,
die sich überlegen, dass ihnen das
mit dem Verkauf von
Drogen oder Waffenschieberei
oder andere Sachen zu riskant
geworden sind und die jetzt auf
die Idee kommen, wir probieren mal
Ransomware, das ist ja der neue heiße Scheiß.
Erschreckend einfach
da auf diesen Zug aufzuspringen
und sich da
die entsprechenden Tools im Internet
zu besorgen. Aber wenn das so einfach
ist, wieso gehen dann die Ermittlungsbehörden,
also zum Beispiel die aus der Ukraine,
wie in dem Video gerade, nicht einfach
dagegen vor? Weil es nicht so
einfach ist. Du musst ja erstmal die Leute finden.
Es ist ja nicht so, als würden
die schreiben hier, Impressum
Frankfurt auf der
Zeil dritter Stock.
Du musst ja erstmal dahinter kommen, wer da denn Sache ist.
Außerdem musst du das dann auch irgendwie
noch halbwegs lückenlos ermittelt haben.
Du kannst ja nicht einfach mal random irgendwelche Häuser
raiden. Gut, in Russland
kannst du das vielleicht schon machen. Aber normalerweise
kannst du nicht einfach mal random irgendwelche Häuser raiden.
Und es sind ja auch Länder
oftmals flächenmäßig sehr groß.
Du kannst ja nicht in jedes Haus reinkucken. Aha, wird dir
illegale Malware entwickelt?
Okay, nächste Wohnung.
Das funktioniert nicht. Du musst ja erst die Leute erstmal finden.
Und das stellt sich garantiert als
nicht so einfach dar.
Sind die sich gar nicht bewusst, was
da abgeht? Die sind sich
dessen bewusst und im Rahmen ihrer
Möglichkeiten gehen die auch dagegen
vor. Aber natürlich
reicht das im Moment bei weitem nicht
aus. Also das Ganze ist tatsächlich
eine essenzielle, existenzielle
Gefahr, Bedrohung für
äh, so
gut wie alle Unternehmen.
Es ist aus Sicht...
Beim alten Arbeitgeber hatten wir auch einmal
einen Security-Vorfall, was
Verschlüsselung, Verschlüsselungssachen
anging. Und das Einfalltor
war lächerlich einfach.
Es war
ein Windows-Server,
selbstverständlich, wer hätte das gedacht?
Ein Windows-Server,
der beliefert werden
konnte über einen
FDP, also es war ein FDP-Windows-Server
und
der wurde beliefert von einem,
von irgendeiner Marketingagentur
und diese Marketingagentur
hat sich Malware eingefangen und
über diesen Zugang zu diesem
Windows-FDP-Server, von da haben wir uns
die Malware dann eingefangen
und ähm, ja,
die Details kann ich ja nicht so genau erzählen.
So lief das. Ja, und die waren dann auch
relativ schnell dran,
dass die irgendwelche
AD-Berechtigungen hatten und über die Softwareverteilung
wurden Keylogger ausgeliefert.
Also sprich, alle die Windows-Notebooks
hatten, wurden Keypass-Dateien
gedumpt und
Passwörter mitgeschnitten.
Und man hat das Ganze nur
zufällig entdeckt, weil auf
einem Windows-Share
eine entschlüsselte Keypass-Datei gefunden
wurde. Und da hat man sich so gedacht,
hm, wo kommt denn hier eine entschlüsselte
Keypass-Datei her? Und dann hat
man genauer geguckt und hat festgestellt, oh fuck,
ist ja schon in der kompletten
Softwareverteilung. Und dreimal dürft
ihr raten, welche Server
und welche Endgeräte
nicht betroffen waren von der ganzen
Geschichte. Ihr dürft
jetzt mal kurz raten. Ist jetzt relativ
offensichtlich, wenn ich das so blöd sage, ja.
Aber welche Teams,
welche Leute und welche Server waren
nicht betroffen? Mac-User, korrekt,
ja. Und natürlich wir
als Linux-User. Unsere
Notebooks waren alle safe und
unsere Linux-Server waren auch alle safe.
Ist das die Story, wo du dann
Microsoft Defender auf Linux-Server installiert
wurde? Ja.
Ja.
Genau das ist die Story.
Der Kriminellen ist das ein Goldesel,
wo sie mit vergleichsweise geringem
Risiko eine Menge
Geld machen können
und die Abschreckung,
dass da eben Leute erwischt
und tatsächlich nicht nur
verhaftet, sondern dann auch
verurteilt werden, ist vergleichsweise
gering, was eben
auch damit zu tun hat, dass
das eine internationale
Geschichte ist. Das heißt, man muss da
eben zum Teil dann
Spuren verfolgen, die ins Ausland
zeigen. Nicht selten sind diese
Banden eben irgendwo in
Osteuropa ansässig.
Zum Beispiel gibt es also tatsächlich
einen Hotspot in Russland, wo
die entsprechenden Täter
zum Teil sogar bekannt sind, aber
keine Sprachverfolgung durch
die Behörden zu
Die joggt das nicht.
Die Comrades
befürchten haben. Okay, danke Jürgen.
Bei der nächsten Malware in diesem
Video führt die Spur nach Russland
und dieser Trojaner legt
nochmal eine Schippe drauf, aber von
Anfang an. Unter dem Namen Petya
ging 2017 zunächst
eine vermeintlich neue Form eines bereits
bekannten Erpressungstrojaners
in den halben Globus. Nur war dieser
Erpressungstrojaner eigentlich gar keiner, denn
während am Anfang alle dachten, es würde sich um
eine neue Version des bereits bekannten
Trojaners Petya handeln, stellte
sich schnell heraus, dass es sich wohl um eine politisch
motivierte Cyberattacke handeln würde.
Das war NotPetya.
Genau.
NotPetya.
Das eigentliche Ziel der Angreifer war nämlich
möglichst viel Chaos anzurichten.
Und zwar Chaos bei allen Unternehmen, die
an die Meldung kann ich mich noch
dunkel dran erinnern, mit der Ukraine
geschäftliche Beziehungen haben.
Und deswegen haben die Angreifer eine
Schwachstelle in der ukrainischen
Steuersoftware MiDoc verwendet.
Das heißt, dass jede Unternehmen, das in der Ukraine
Steuern zahlt, auch von dem Angriff betroffen ist.
Der Trojaner hat dann auf allen befallenen
Computern die Festplatten gelöscht und
so dafür gesorgt, dass ein Großteil der
Computersysteme nicht mehr benutzbar war.
Und deswegen gilt NotPetya auch
als die wohl bisher kostspieligste
Cyberattacke überhaupt.
Konservative Schätzungen gehen von einem Schaden
von mindestens 10 Milliarden US-Dollar aus.
Achso, und weil ich am Anfang gesagt habe, dass
die Spur nach Russland führt. Also es ist nicht
bewiesen, aber die CIA
und andere Geheimdienste glauben,
dass hinter dem Angriff
Russland steckt.
Gut.
Selbst wenn nicht, also ich gehe
stark voraus, dass da durchaus was dran sein kann,
aber selbst wenn da jetzt Russland nicht dahinter
gesteckt hätte, dass
sie das sagen, würde mich jetzt auch nicht
großartig wundern.
Malware gibt es quasi schon seit
fünf Jahrzehnten, aber so richtig heftig
wurde das in den letzten 20 Jahren.
Und die Schadprogramme, über die ich gerade geredet
habe, sind wirklich nur ein kleiner Teil von dem,
was in den letzten zwei Jahrzehnten so durchs
Netz ging. Und die Motive dafür
haben sich in der Zeit krass verändert.
Während am Anfang vor allem noch
verkannte Nerds einfache Programme
geschrieben haben. Ja, am Anfang war das halt so ein bisschen
Hame und
Zerstörungswut, nennen wir es mal.
Oder halt auch zeigen, so
nach dem Motto, was technisch geht.
Mittlerweile ist das eindeutig Geld,
was das motiviert.
Ne, WannaCry hat er anscheinend
wirklich gar nicht drin.
Und sie es einfach faszinierend
fanden, wie diese Programme sich selbst
weiterverbreiteten und es gar nicht darum
ging, Schaden anzurichten, hat die
Organisierte Kriminalität
das Thema Malware für sich entdeckt
und mit Schadsoftware wie Emotet richtig
viel Geld vernichtet. Und dass Malware
und Sicherheitslücken quasi schon
von Anbeginn auch Teil von staatlichen
Angriffen waren, ist eigentlich schon wieder
ein Thema für sich. Viele Techniken, die heute
im Cybercrime üblich sind, waren
vor fünf Jahren noch Anzeichen für Angriffe
durch staatliche Organisationen.
Eternal Blue zum Beispiel wurde ja fünf Jahre
von der NSA benutzt, bevor sie von der
Organisierten Kriminalität verwendet wurde.
Und das könnte in Zukunft noch deutlich
zunehmen. Also hoffen wir mal, dass sich
vor allem die Sicherheitsaspekte von modernen
Computersystemen in den nächsten Jahren noch weiter
verbessern. Denn jeder flächendeckende
Angriff ist nicht nur teuer für die Betroffenen,
sondern mittlerweile auch wirklich eine Gefahr
für die öffentliche Sicherheit. Schließlich ist
ja mittlerweile so gut wie alles miteinander
vernetzt. Für eure Sicherheit könnt
ihr euch mal überlegen, Linux zu benutzen.
Das stimmt wohl, ja.
Bringt einem aber
alles nix, wenn man jedem 0815
Cloud-Anbieter seine ganzen Sachen anvertraut.
Ein Arbeitskollege schwärmt von CyberArk.
Kennst du das? Ja, das hab ich schon
gesehen. Ja, das kenn ich.
Das kann jede Menge Sachen. Das kann
SSH-Sessions mitlocken,
Windows-Sessions
mitschneiden
und solche Geschichten.
Video-Feed mitschneiden.
Naja, das ist
für so
Security-Paranoia-Leute sicherlich
was. Statt Windows oder
macOS. Weil ist klar, Windows ist das
populärste Betriebssystem, deshalb wird auch
die meiste Malware dafür entwickelt.
Und allgemein gilt natürlich
nicht auf unbekannte E-Mail-Anhänge oder
Links klicken, dafür könnt ihr aber gerne auf
den Abo warten, wenn ihr wollt.
Und wenn man seine Sachen unter Linux
öffnet, beziehungsweise sogar
zwielichtige Seiten unter Linux
browset, ist man eh relativ safe.
Kann ich jedem nur empfehlen.
Habt eine Linux-VM hier irgendwie auf dem
zweiten Desktop am Start, so wie ich hier.
Und wenn ihr was aufmachen wollt,
sei es Anhänge von Mails, irgendwelche
Seiten besuchen, wo ihr euch nicht ganz sicher seid,
was ist das, was gibt's da, was machen die da.
Macht es einfach unter Windows.
Macht es einfach nicht unter Windows, sondern unter Linux.
Und ihr habt
so gut wie nie Probleme.
Moment.
Das haben wir doch gerade noch geguckt.
Langsam, langsam.
Muss mal kurz gucken, wann es Essen gibt, aber ich glaube, es dauert
noch ein bisschen.
Ja, dauert noch.
Gab's nicht mal vor ein paar Jahren einen Exploit in
der PNG-Lib, die für...
Bestimmt, bestimmt. Es ist ja nicht so,
als gibt's unter Linux keinerlei Exploits und
Probleme.
Log4j,
Shellshock,
Hardpleat und was wir nicht noch alles
hatten. Es gibt ja durchaus
unter Linux auch Probleme.
Aber das sind halt eher
anders gelagerte Angriffsszenarien.
Ja, das greift dann meistens irgendwelche
Services an oder irgendwelche
Dienste auf Servern und weniger jetzt
einen PDF für
den Endanwender, was manipuliert ist.
Wann es Essen gibt, kocht jemand
für mich. Ja, in dem Fall heute tatsächlich.
Heute kocht meine Mutter was für mich.
Ich bin mir bloß noch
nicht so ganz sicher was, weil
die muss Sachen vorbereiten
für heute Abend.
Also wahrscheinlich ist es irgendwie
Nudel oder sowas.
Die Playstation basiert auf BSD.
Also die
ganzen Playstation Sachen basieren zum
größten Teil auf BSD. Bei der Playstation 5
sind sich die Leute noch ein bisschen uneins
gewesen, wo ich das letzte Mal mich drüber
informiert hab, ob das auch auf
FreeBSD basiert, aber ich würde mal drauf
tippen, weil alle anderen Playstation
vorher, ich glaub außer der 1er,
selbst da bin ich mir gar nicht sicher, auch auf FreeBSD
basiert haben. So, haben wir noch
irgendwas was wir uns angucken können jetzt?
Ich mein ja, wir haben genug, aber irgendwas
was ich jetzt gucken will.
Was haben wir denn hier?
Serverless was a big mistake, says Amazon.
Amazon sagt viel, wenn der Tag lang ist, vor allem wenn sie
was verkaufen wollen in der Richtung.
Lohnt sich das Video? Können wir auch gucken.
Wir gucken uns erstmal eine Runde FireShip an.
Amazon sagt Serverless was a big mistake.
Tja, Amazon.
Ja gut, das stimmt, da hat er recht.
Serverless heißt ja nicht, dass es keine Server gibt.
Die Bezeichnung war schon immer ziemlich pepega.
Die Bezeichnung war schon von fünf Männern.
Also bringt Galena Sch mysteries.
Vaterflecki, ne 不是
Sag doch Horror!
Diese Diskussion, Leute!
Ja, darüber zu diskutieren. Das ist das genauso, wie sie vor ein paar Jahren erzählt haben, oh Monorepos, oder ne, vor 1, 2, 3, 4, Monorepos ist der neueste Shit, es macht doch keinen Sinn, jede Furz in einem eigenen Repo einzuchecken und so.
Und davor so nach dem Motto, ah ja, du musst alles super asynchron über Message-Queues und Microservices. Man könnte es einfach mal ganz nüchtern sehen. Man sollte sich eine Anwendungsarchitektur überlegen, die gut zu dem Anwendungszweck, beziehungsweise dann auch zu der Anwendung und dem Service, den man anbieten will, passt.
Es hat keinen Sinn, irgendwie was in 800 Microservices aufzusplitten.
Aber es hat keinen Sinn, in 800 Microservices aufzusplitten.
Es macht auch nicht immer Sinn, also kann man auch nicht so pauschal sagen, alles in eine Anwendung reinzuklatschen.
Also es kann durchaus Sinn machen zu sagen, okay, man hat eine relativ komplette, komplexe Web-Anwendung mit vielen Teilen, die macht man zusammen in einer, in einer, ja, einem großen, großen ganzen Anwendung und dann hat man beispielsweise asynchrone Jobverarbeitung über irgendeine Message-Queue, die dann, äh, Mails,
verschickt, Abrechnungen macht, was auch immer, ja. Das kann man schon so aufsplitten. Man muss es halt, man muss weder das eine Extrem machen, noch das andere Extrem.
Also insofern, das ist jetzt eigentlich gar keine große, große News irgendwo, ja.
Dass natürlich immer alles versucht wird, das ist auch was, was ich bei den ganzen Bullshit-Buzzword-Bingo immer blöd finde, dass immer so getan wird, das wäre jetzt so, dass, man hätte jetzt das Rad neu erfunden und das ist jetzt so quasi die beste Erfindung seitgeschnitten,
und man muss das jetzt immer und für alles und am besten rückwirken, muss das so machen und alle Anwendungen, die nicht so gebaut sind, sind Kacke und Legacy und, kannst du nicht verwenden?
Eigentlich, eigentlich sieht man das immer am besten, wenn eine Technologie, wenn der Hype rum ist, wenn der Hype rum ist bei einer Technologie, dann sieht man die guten Teile, die übrig bleiben, die, die sich bewährt haben, denn man muss da nicht direkt drauf springen, das ist zum Beispiel, ich nehme mal, ich nehme mal ein Beispiel von vor ein paar Jahren, ja.
Vor ein paar Jahren, also, das muss so irgendwie, frag mich nicht, sag mal, ungefähr zehn Jahre her sein, sag mal mal vor zehn Jahren, vor zehn Jahren kam das ganze Thema, wir machen Web-Anwendungen in Node.js und nur noch mit MongoDB und NoSQL auf.
Und jeder hat gemeint, oh, fuck, jetzt aber, jetzt aber ganz zackig, neue Anwendung muss her und natürlich in Node.js und auch NoSQL, SQL selbst ist ja viel zu oldschool und sonst was und dann haben sie Zeug damit gemacht, wofür es überhaupt nicht gedacht ist.
Node.js magne.
Node.js mag eine coole Technologie sein, Node.js ist nicht, nicht gut geeignet für jegliche Art von Backends, ja, nicht jeder, jedes Entwicklungsteam ist in der Lage, gute Node.js Anwendungen zu entwickeln und auch nicht für alles ist NoSQL das Allheilmittel, ja, wenn ich irgendwelche Key-Value-Sachen unstrukturiert speichern will, mag NoSQL geil sein, wenn ich irgendwelche Time-Series speichern will, zu Zeiten, wo es noch keine Time-Series-Datenbanken gegeben hat, mag NoSQL vielleicht auch geil sein.
Sobald ich aber irgendwelche Beziehungen abbilden muss zwischen den Daten, dann hat, geht mit MongoDB auch, dann ist aber klassisches SQL sicherlich auch nicht verkehrt.
Wofür ist Node.js gedacht?
TRPC, TRPC ist eine coole Sache, ja, das ist tatsächlich eher was im Node-Ökosystem, wofür Node.js gut ist.
Node.js ist zum Beispiel gut, wenn du einen Haufen JavaScript-Anwendungsentwickler hast und die sollen jetzt eine Backend-Anwendung,
Oder aber, wenn du beispielsweise viele Snippets und Datenmodels und was auch immer hast, die du sharen willst zwischen deiner Backend-Anwendung und deiner Frontend-Anwendung.
Also das kann schon durchaus Sinn machen, Dinger in Node.js zu entwickeln.
Und jetzt, nachdem der Hype vorbei ist, sieht man das auch.
Ja, da sagt man, okay, wir haben den Fall, wir haben viele Sachen, die wir sharen können zwischen Frontend und Backend.
Wir wollen sowas wie TRPC benutzen, ja.
Wir wollen vielleicht Server-Site-Rendering machen mit Hydration, dass man eine JavaScript-Runtime auf dem Server braucht.
Wir machen Teile davon in Node.js.
Vollkommen in Ordnung.
Aber einfach zu sagen, wir machen jetzt unsere Sachen mit Node.js und NoSQL, einfach nur, weil es der neueste Scheiß ist.
Ja, das bringt nichts.
Aber jetzt, nachdem das schon eine Weile rum ist und man jetzt so die guten Parts davon kennt,
kann man sich heute auch bewusst dafür entscheiden, okay, das machen wir in Node.js.
Und nicht, weil es der Hype ist, sondern weil man explizit sagt, okay, das ist eine gute Technologie dafür.
Das heißt, unterm Strich ist immer am besten, wenn es um solche Hype-Geschichten geht,
sich das wirklich erstmal in Ruan zu gucken und nicht unbedingt nur drauf aufzuspringen.
Es ist einfach, sich von so einem Technologie-Hype mitreißen zu lassen.
Und es ist auch nicht verkehrt, sich das anzugucken, weil man muss ja immer ein bisschen auf dem Laufenden bleiben.
Es ist einfach, sich mitzureißen, weil es gibt zig Konferenztalks zu solchen.
Neuen Themen, ja, Amazon, Microsoft, Google, alle preisen das Neue an.
Dann hast du irgendwelche Consultants, die dir das erzählen.
Also es ist natürlich einfach, sich von irgendwelchen Hypes mitreißen zu lassen.
Man muss aber immer gucken, ob das für den eigenen Anwendungsfall irgendwo Sinn macht.
Und bei dieser ganzen, wir übertreiben es mit Microservices-Geschichte,
sieht man jetzt halt auch, dass es nicht immer sinnvoll ist.
Es kann durchaus für die jeweilige Anwendung sinnvoll sein, Microservices zu verwenden.
Allerdings.
Mit mehr oder weniger großen, großen Blöcken dazwischen.
Also man hat dann vielleicht nicht 30 Services, sondern man hat vielleicht 2, 3 größere,
oder vielleicht eine richtig große, 2, 3 mittelgroße und ein paar kleine,
die asynchron irgendwas verarbeiten.
Ist doch auch sinnvoll, wenn es zur Anwendung passt.
So, jetzt gucken wir uns mal das Video fertig an.
Ja, das ist wohl wahr.
Das ist tatsächlich bestimmt auch eines der größten Vorteile gewesen von dieser ganzen Microservice-Geschichte,
dass du halt dadurch, dass du das so schön entkoppelt hast, das schön skalieren kannst.
Ja, lassen wir zwei Instanzen laufen.
50 Instanzen davon ist uns egal.
Es gibt halt Sachen, die sind schlecht zu parallelisieren.
Ja, gerade Abläufe, wo das eine auf das andere wartet,
oder wo dann Transaction-mäßig was in Datenbanken passieren muss, wie auch immer.
Es gibt Fälle, da ist es nicht so schön mit dem Skalieren,
auch wenn du mehrere Anwendungen starten kannst.
Und es gibt auch genug Anwendungsfälle, da musst du gar nicht großartig skalieren.
Gehen wir mal von einem einfachen Fall aus.
Ja, gehen wir mal davon.
Gehen wir davon aus, irgendeiner will im Internet was verkaufen und braucht einen Shop.
Ja, du kannst diesen Shop, wenn du Amazon bist, sicherlich als 800 verschiedene Microservices laufen lassen.
Und bei Amazon ist das sicherlich auch sinnvoll.
Wenn ich jetzt allerdings einen Frankfurter Inlineskate-Shop aufmache,
der gut läuft, aber weit davon entfernt ist, Amazon zu sein,
da kann ich auch einfach irgendeine Shop-Software nehmen,
auf drei VMs schmeißen und gut ist.
Das muss weder hochskalierbar in einem Kubernetes,
noch muss das überhaupt regelmäßig skaliert werden.
Das legst du einfach so aus, dass es den normalen User-Ansturm abkann und gut ist.
Und im Zweifelsfall sind ja diese Anwendungen auch nicht davon abhängig,
dass du die jetzt innerhalb von Sekunden hochskalieren kannst.
Wächst du mal wirklich raus, dass du sagst,
okay, und die Server, die wir uns dafür gemietet haben,
die sind jetzt wirklich ein bisschen zu schwachbrüstig,
dann kann man immer noch eine Instanz mal abschalten,
eine neue, fettere VM aufbauen,
und gut ist.
Und wenn man damit feststellt, okay, man kommt damit nicht hin,
dann kann man sich Gedanken drüber machen, wie kann man das skalieren.
Und dann muss man vielleicht auch die einen oder anderen Teile neu entwickeln.
Aber von Anfang an davon auszugehen,
man startet die nächste Hype-Anwendung
und jeder kleine Furz da drinnen muss hyperskalieren
bis zu was weiß ich wie viel, tausend Instanzen,
ist natürlich bescheuert.
Verbrät auch unnötig viel Geld am Anfang,
nur was, was vielleicht nie abhebt.
Das Gegenargument dazu wäre jetzt natürlich,
okay, es ist schwierig, im Nachhinein Anwendungen umzubauen zu skaliert ordentlich,
wenn man nicht von Anfang an dran gedacht hat.
Das stimmt.
Es ist halt die Frage, wann will man das Geld ausgeben?
Nachdem es abgehoben ist und man Geld hat?
Oder im Vorfeld schon, wo man noch nicht mal weiß,
ob die Idee überhaupt abhebt?
Twitter.
Oder Github.
Die hätten sich beide sicherlich gefreut,
hätten sie nicht so monolithisch angefangen wie am Anfang.
Sowohl Twitter als auch Github,
also Twitter schon lange nicht mehr,
Github bis heute immer noch zu teilen,
waren beide Ruby on Rails Anwendungen.
Das war eine fette Anwendung mit ein bisschen Message Queue,
vielleicht nebendran eine externe Datenbank
und die hätten sich sicherlich nach ein paar Jahren gefreut,
hätten sie von Anfang an ihren Service skalierbarer ausgelegt.
Aber hey, weder Twitter noch Github hätte wahrscheinlich gedacht,
dass sie mal an der Position sind, wo sie dann paar Jahre später waren.
Also insofern ist eigentlich keine super große neue Erkenntnis hier.
Money.
I really appreciate Amazon's transparency here,
because they're one of the original pioneers of serverless with Lambda functions.
And nowadays you have tons of platforms offering serverless services
like Vercel and Netlify,
which are actually just using and reselling AWS services behind the scenes.
There's almost an entire industry of startups that make AWS easier to use,
including open-source projects like the Serverless Framework and SST.
But not everyone is drinking the Kool-Aid.
Like DHH, the creator of Ruby on Rails and Basecamp,
has been advocating for Majest...
Den Dude, den kürzt man nicht wirklich DHH ab, oder?
... in the Kool-Aid.
Like DHH, the creator...
Okay, der Name ist ein bisschen kompliziert,
gerade für Amis wahrscheinlich auch, zu sprechen.
Also der Name klingt eher schwedisch oder so,
oder finnisch oder dänisch oder so was.
Was ist denn das eigentlich?
Dänisch, dänisch, ja.
Und außerdem wollte ich gerade sagen,
der Typ, der fährt doch jetzt irgendwelche Autorennen.
Dänisch.
Ja, da tun sich die Amis natürlich schwer,
aber DHH, also seriously.
... of Ruby on Rails and Basecamp
has been advocating for Majestic Monoliths for the last decade
and took his entire company off the cloud
after they spent over three million dollars in one year.
Now they just run their own servers.
A lot of successful startups like Dropbox
end up leaving the cloud once they get big enough.
However, I personally use Serverless for my projects
and it's an absolute game changer for getting things done quickly.
Although I have accidentally created a few infinitely scaling infinite loops
that could have potentially cost me an infinite amount of money.
But what's the difference between a microservice and monolith architecture?
At Prime Video, they needed a tool to analyze audio content
for issues like video freeze and corruption.
To implement this tool, they use multiple serverless functions
called Step Functions, which are basically the same thing as Lambda,
to handle different responsibilities.
You have an initial entry point,
which kicks off another service to do a file conversion
that converts an audio-video stream into...
Das ist halt wirklich...
Also, ey, das macht vielleicht Sinn,
wenn man YouTube- oder Amazon Prime Video ist oder so was.
Aber das ist halt schon extremer Overkill
für Video-Encoding und solche Geschichten.
Aber warum nicht?
Das ist Amazon.
In der Größenordnung von Amazon macht vieles sicherlich Sinn,
was für normale Leute wenig Sinn macht.
... by the detector.
You've got multiple detectors using machine learning to analyze the video.
They have another function to aggregate the results and store them in a bucket.
But there's a little bit of overhead every time you pass data from one service to another.
They need to serialize and deserialize data and communicate over a network.
In this case, their service needed to run multiple times
for every second of a video stream.
And they quickly hit a bottleneck with their account limits,
just trying to orchestrate the service.
In addition, by temporarily uploading files to S3,
they were burning through money just accessing these files in the buckets.
They realized that the distributed architecture
was the root cause of these bottlenecks,
causing them to make a bold decision
to re-architect to a monolith instead of running decoupled distribution.
Naja, wenn das Problem ist,
dass ein Großteil der Zeit und Ressourcen für Interconnect irgendwie draufgeht,
dann ist es doch ein großer Indikator dafür,
dass gar zu viel Microservices doch keine gute Idee ist.
Weil es ist halt relativ easy,
von einem Prozess zum anderen oder gar in-process
RAM-Teile, die im Arbeitsspeicher liegen, zu sharen,
wenn man das serialisieren muss, in irgendeine Message Queue schreiben muss,
dann liest dann wieder einer.
Also dann hast du ja irgendwann 60, 70 Prozent deiner Zeit und deiner Ressourcen
einfach nur für Datenaustausch.
Dafür ist ja ganz klar, dass es keine gute Idee ist, das so zu bauen.
Und da ist jetzt auch Amazon wohl draufgekommen.
Distributed Services, they took everything and made it run on a single container.
All the components are the same, but now that they run on a single server,
they can only scale vertically.
That means to do more work, they'll need to make each server bigger.
Unlike the microservice architecture, which could scale horizontally
by creating more servers for each individual component
based on its scaling needs.
That seems like it would be a drawback, but it eliminated all...
Du könntest sicherlich auch mehrere Container davon starten.
Allerdings nicht in solche Extreme wie vorher.
Vorher hatten sie ja pro Video mehrere Instanzen.
Da kannst du natürlich krass horizontal skalieren.
Wobei, ihr wisst ja, wir skalieren prinzipiell nur diagonal.
Da haben wir beides schon in einem...
In einem Step.
Aber das geht jetzt nicht.
Aber du kannst trotzdem horizontal skalieren,
weil du kannst ja immer noch pro Video so einen Container starten.
Du kannst jetzt nicht mehr für innerhalb von einem Video mehrere Instanzen starten,
aber du kannst immer noch eine Instanz pro Video starten.
Also du kannst immer noch in beschränktem Maße horizontal skalieren.
Wenn du allerdings die Performance pro Video dann optimieren willst,
dann musst du vertikal skalieren, indem du die Hardware besser machst.
Klingt doch nach einem sinnvollen Trade-off.
...unmögliche Kommunikation und Netzwerken,
die ihre Kosten um 90% reduzieren.
Und für ein Produkt dieser Größe bedeutet das Millionen...
Also, wenn du 90% Kosten sparst,
dann war das vorher einfach extrem over-sized und over-engineert, das Ganze.
Also, ich glaube...
Und wahrscheinlich hat sich keiner getraut, was zu sagen,
weil dort irgendein Manager erzählt hat, so nach dem Motto,
wir haben eine Cloud-first-Strategie und du musst alles Cloud machen
und benutze unsere Functions, benutze das.
Das haben sich bestimmt Entwickler jahrelang dort schon gedacht.
Haben sich aber nicht getraut, was zu sagen.
Dass so was so lang dauert, ist meistens irgendwelcher Management-Fail.
Aufgefallen ist das den Entwicklern sicherlich schon ganz schnell.
...is that if you're using microservices,
you should probably cobble them together into a monolith right now.
Well, not so fast. In this case, the optimization was pretty obvious.
Famously, back in 2008, Netflix was based on a monolith architecture
and had a massive failure that motivated them to break their architecture...
Ah, obviously.
...into hundreds of different microservices...
Cringe, wer nicht versteht, was...
...that can scale independently with fault tolerance.
It might be more complex and expensive,
but if Netflix goes down for a few hours,
it'll cost them way more money and lost memberships.
Then, for small businesses like me,
I can easily deploy my shitty JavaScript code
without ever having to think about infrastructure.
I rarely even bust out of the free tier,
and when I do, it's money well spent because I have peace of mind
knowing that I'm not going to deploy some bad code to my monolith
that takes down my entire operation.
Ultimately, when it comes to cloud architecture,
there are no solutions, only trade-offs.
This has been The Code Report. Thanks for watching.
And I will see you in the next one.
Ja, der macht immer ganz gute Videos.
Wenn er mir auch teilweise etwas zu viel mimt in letzten Videos,
wo du dann teilweise schon gar nicht mehr erkennst,
hat das jetzt wirklich jemand gesagt, den er da zitiert, oder nicht?
Meistens, wenn dir das Zitat komisch vorkommt, dann eher nicht.
Aber der macht trotzdem gute Videos immer.
Ich hab Hunger.
Mal kurz checken, wann's Essen gibt.
Kurz Home Automation schauen.
Wisst ihr, wie ich rauskriegen kann, ob's bald Essen gibt?
An solchen Tagen?
Über meine Heimautomation.
Ich hab ja auch schon mal ein Video gemacht,
wo ich gesagt habe,
bei der Heimautomatisierung, Easy-File-Fat.
Ich hab keinen Sensor, der mir sagt, ey, guck mal,
ähm, da wird gerade Essen gemacht.
Kamera.
Nee, nicht wirklich.
Ich kann das über Schalter, also ich hab ja remote-schaltbare Steckdosen
in der Küche, ich kann das über den Status von manchen Schaltern erkennen,
aber hauptsächlich über den Stromverbrauch.
Ja, Stromverbrauch, genau.
Stromverbrauch.
Stromverbrauch, erkenne ich das immer ganz gut.
Es sei denn, es sei denn, die Mikrowelle, Mikrowelle ist nicht so gut zu erkennen.
Also, Herd ist deutlich besser zu erkennen als Mikrowelle.
Haben wir sonst noch irgendwas?
Oh, nee, auf den Bibliothekar, weiß nicht, was das ist.
Haben wir sonst noch?
Euer Smart Home.
Menschentiere-Automation.
Jawoll, die gucke ich auch.
26 Minuten, Mann.
Das können wir uns jetzt nicht angucken.
Dafür hungere ich.
Bin jetzt schon vier Stunden online.
Wenn ich das Video gucke, brauche ich locker 40 Minuten für, Mensch.
Wir können anfangen, oder haben wir noch was Kürzeres?
Nee, komm, wir fangen an.
Die Videos gucke ich immer gerne, gerade also diese Serie hier.
Das Wii-Video, ich glaube, das ist nicht so spannend.
Das ist irgendeine alte macOS-Version, das ist nicht so.
Lass mal kurz gucken.
Wollen wir fragen zu dem Kamel auf deinem Dachboden?
Moment mal, warte mal, warte mal.
Kann ich euch auch noch...
Zum Thema Kamel.
Kann ich euch eine richtig lustige Story erzählen.
Und zwar auf meiner aktuellen Arbeit, da haben wir...
Story ist wurscht, ja.
Da haben wir eine Software eingekauft.
Und da muss man manchmal mit dem Support schreiben.
Und einer von dem Support heißt Kamel.
Oder ich weiß nicht, ob man ihn so ausspricht.
Also nicht Kamel, sondern Ka-Kamel.
So, und...
Manchmal, wenn man mit dem Support schreibt, da sind die Leute faul.
Und jagen die E-Mail-Antworten, die man denen zurückschreibt,
durch den Translator, durch DeepL.
Und irgendwann hat DeepL das Ganze mal mit Camel übersetzt.
Die übersetzen dann immer von Deutsch auf Englisch.
Und auf einmal steht dann in der Nachricht,
Hello Camel.
Das hat er nicht so ganz kapiert,
dass man den Namen nicht übersetzen sollte an der Stelle.
Auf einmal war er dann ein Kamel.
Aber glücklicherweise hat man das vor dem Absenden erkannt.
Es wäre schon ein bisschen peinlich gewesen, oder?
Hättest du dann den Namen so verunstaltet.
So, also, lasst uns mal angucken hier.
Was macht ihr denn da oben?
Fangt ihr irgendwie russische Spionagenachrichten ab?
Was haben wir da gerade gesehen?
Wo geht's los hier?
Andi schickt uns seine automatisierte Speicherluke.
Wir schauen...
Automatisierte Dachbodenluke, so was könnte ich auch machen.
Allerdings ist meine Luke, glaube ich, viel zu schwer.
Und zu blöd zu automatisieren.
Weil meine Luke geht nach unten auf mit einer Treppe dran.
Und ja, das könnte man automatisieren, aber...
Im Rahmen unseres Umbaus haben wir eine alte,
klapprige Auszieh-Speichertreppe durch diese Raumspartreppe ersetzt.
Und was lag da näher, als die Speicherluke zu automatisieren?
Was hat er ersetzt?
Auszieh-Speichertreppe durch diese...
Ah, er hatte eine Ausziehtreppe.
Ja, ich habe immer noch eine Ausziehtreppe.
Und ich will auch eine Ausziehtreppe behalten,
weil sonst hätte ich eine Treppe mitten im...
Bei einem Flur?
Wobei, die Katze fände das sicherlich megageil.
Raumspartreppe ersetzt.
Mhm.
Und was lag da näher, als die...
Wie heißt das Ding?
Raum-spa-treppe?
Was kostet denn so was?
So was?
Nee, so was, wie der hatte, ja.
Wow!
Alter!
Das ist, das ist...
Aber trotzdem, so selten, wie ich auf den Dachboden gehe...
Ja, so was hier, ja.
So selten, wie ich auf...
Das hält?
So selten, wie ich auf den Dachboden gehe, ist es mir lieber.
Ich habe keine Treppe im Flur.
Scheiße zum Laufen.
Ja, gut, die Leiter ist sonst auch scheiße zum Laufen.
Speicherluke zu automatisieren.
Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt.
Erzähl mir mehr.
Boah!
Der Hintergrund ist auf...
Okay, meine Luke geht nach unten auf.
Okay.
Außerdem ist nichts gedämmt.
Bei mir ist da irgendwie 15 Zentimeter, 10, 15 Zentimeter Dämmung.
Wir haben uns ein Speicherfenster haben einbauen lassen
und im Sommer die Möglichkeit haben wollen, bequem vom Sessel aus...
Kennt ihr noch den ursprünglichen Aufbau von meinem Opa?
Der Opa hatte ja da einen Aufzug gebaut, mit auch so einem Seil.
Für alle, die es nicht kennen, ich zeige euch das mal kurz.
Das ist richtig abenteuerlich mit der Baustelle.
Ähm...
Max reagiert auf im Garten durch den Schneestell.
Das hat jemand auf meinem Stream mitgeschnitten.
Ist der Aufzug noch hier?
Nee, der Aufzug ist schon...
War ich Aufzug in dem Video?
Oder ist das noch von der Baustelle hier?
Ja, warte mal, hier ist der...
Nee, der Aufzug ist schon weg.
Hier ist der Aufzug schon weg.
Okay, ähm...
Also, das hier ist der Flur.
Ihr seht es hier nicht mehr.
Das hier oben ist quasi der Flur.
Und da geht es dann...
Könntet ihr schon gesehen haben...
Da geht es dann halt hoch.
Da gibt es halt so eine Luke mit Treppe zum Aufzug.
Oh, den kann ich jetzt nicht suchen.
Wo ich die Bilder vom Opa gezeigt habe...
Äh...
Ich glaube, das Video habe ich auf Privat gestellt.
Hier, hier sieht man es.
Das Video habe ich, glaube ich, auf Privat gestellt,
weil da hat man nackige Sachen im Video gesehen.
Und YouTube ist ja da mittlerweile sehr...
Also, man hat Bilder von meinem Opa gesehen,
wo er nackige Mädels gemalt hat.
Und klar, das geht als Kunst durch,
aber man weiß ja nicht, wie YouTube das Ganze einschätzt.
Ich glaube, das habe ich auf Privat gestellt.
Ist hier der Fahrstuhl noch da?
Nee, hier ist auch schon die Treppe da.
Ja, wo ist denn hier das Video mit dem Fahrstuhl, Mann?
Keine Ahnung.
Ja, dann weiß ich nicht.
Durch die Baustelle.
Es gibt ein Video von, wo der Fahrstuhl noch da war.
So, und das ist halt mega-nice Konstruktion,
was der Opa damals gebaut hat.
Habe ich nicht sogar Baustelle in der eigenen Playlist gehabt?
Ah, nee, ich habe die ganzen alten Playlists gelöscht.
Ach, ja...
Ja, okay, dann weiß ich jetzt auch nicht.
Irgendwelche...
Privat-Leute finden vielleicht noch das alte Video.
KZFPS am Start.
Stell dir mal... Mein Klo.
Ach, shit.
Hätte ich euch jetzt gerne gezeigt,
aber ich finde das nicht mehr viel zu viele Uralt-Videos.
Hätte ich euch gerne gezeigt,
wie du den Dachboden stellst, da ist es doch.
Hier, hier sieht man es.
Hier.
Da, da ist der Fahrstuhl, den der Opa gebaut hat.
Guckt mal.
Ja, auch hier live mit dabei, diesen geilen Fahrstuhl.
Guck mal, hier.
Juhu.
Der hat schon ein bisschen gelitten gehabt,
der Fahrstuhl, zu dem Zeitpunkt.
Das war schon mitten im Renovieren.
Ja, also du hast... Du machst dann hier zu.
Und dann hast du solche...
Den gibt es nicht mehr, den Fahrstuhl.
Ja, aber coole Konstruktion.
Verdass das der Opa...
Ich würde sagen, hier, Hut ab vor meinem Opa.
Also, dass der so was alleine bauen konnte, ja.
So, dann hat man hier so Knöpfe gehabt,
und dann fährt man da hoch.
Und das ist halt schon ein bisschen abenteuerlich gewesen, das Ding, ja.
Weil, ich hoffe, ich drehe mich jetzt um.
Beste Kameraführungsskills aller Zeiten.
Ähm...
Ja, hier sieht man ein bisschen was.
Hier sieht man das... Genau, hier sieht man es hier daneben,
dass man so Schienen hat.
Und das Ganze hing hinten an einem Seil, an einem Drahtseil dran.
Hier, da ist es, da sieht man es.
Lull.
Der gesamte Aufzug ging über so was hier.
Da seht ihr es.
Man erkennt es, leider war das Video noch mit 30 FPS, ja.
Aber man erkennt es halbwegs.
An diesem Drahtseil hängt halt der gesamte Fahrstuhl dran, oder hing.
Hier erkennt man es gut.
Hing der gesamte Fahrstuhl dran.
Und da unten ist halt der Motor drinne.
Das war halt auch so eine sehr abenteuerliche Konstruktion.
Aber mega nice, dass der Opa das alleine hingekriegt hat.
Der hat die komplette Konstruktion alleine gemacht.
Und ich glaube, der dürfte auch so ziemlich der Einzige gewesen sein
in der ganzen harten Straße, der einen Fahrstuhl auf den Dachboden hatte.
Hält schon viel aus, ja.
Man muss sich halt immer nur schön in die Mitte stellen und so was.
Eigentlich eine richtig coole Konstruktion, ja.
Ja, das ist Dachbodenstelz Teil 2.
Das erste musste ich leider löschen, weil...
Nacktbilder von...
Selbst wenn es Kunst ist, man weiß bei YouTube ja nie.
Ja. Und daran hat mich diese Konstruktion tatsächlich ein bisschen erinnert.
Die Luke zu öffnen, das Speicherfenster zu öffnen
und dann von unten durchlüften zu lassen.
Das Ganze wurde realisiert auf Basis der Menschentierer-Automation Nummer 12
und dem Fernseher, der einem Schlafzimmer aus dem Bettkasten kommt.
Da kann ich mich noch dran erinnern.
Das fand ich wahnsinnig unsinnig mit dem Fernseher.
Beim Shelly 2.
Ich hab erst mal Fragen zu dem Kamel auf seinem Dachboden.
Aber auf jeden Fall vielen Dank dafür.
Ich werde mir direkt hier eine kleine Notiz machen.
Vielleicht auch eine große Notiz.
Denn ich spreche nachher mit meinem Elektro-Partner in Crime für unser neues Haus.
Und an eine smarte Dachboden-Luke hatte ich bisher noch nicht gedacht oder die vorgesehen.
Ich nehme das mal mit auf die Liste.
Ah, eine gute Idee.
Dann hat Felix seinen Warmwasser-Boiler.
Der war automatisiert und ich bin sehr gespannt.
Leider geht meine Luke in die andere Richtung.
Was macht man nicht heute alles, um ein bisschen Strom zu sparen?
Du hättest Strom sparen können.
Strom sparen?
Strom sparst du am ehesten.
Beziehungsweise für die Umwelt was Gutes tust du in der Regel damit,
und das muss man jetzt an der Stelle auch noch mal sagen,
indem man das alte Zeug, was man hat, möglichst lange weiterverwendet.
Klingt jetzt vielleicht blöd,
aber unterm Strich ist es meistens die richtige Entscheidung.
Klar, ein neues Auto, neue Technik, was auch immer, ist meistens sparsamer,
ist meistens ...
umweltverträglicher,
aber das muss auch erst mal alles hergestellt werden.
Also in der Regel bist du immer ...
Man kann es nicht allgemeinpauschal sagen,
aber in der Regel bist du umweltfreundlicher,
wenn du die alten Sachen weiter benutzt,
solange du sie weiter benutzen kannst.
Aussagen bestätigen die Regel.
Und meistens ist es hier bei den Einsparungen auch so,
die Technik, die man sich anschafft,
die sorgt eventuell dafür,
unterm Strich, dass man ein bisschen was einspart.
Meistens ist es nicht sonderlich viel,
aber bis man das Geld, was die Technik gekostet hat,
wieder drin hat, dauert auch oftmals lange.
Also aufgrund der Geldersparnis, Stromersparnis,
ist es meistens auch nicht die beste Variante dafür,
in Heimautomatisierung zu investieren.
Wo es viel sinnvoller ist,
ist halt, um einem das Leben einfacher zu machen.
Und wenn man nebenbei noch ein bisschen Strom spart dadurch,
ist ja auch nicht verkehrt.
Bei vielen von den Zuschauern,
indem du den Hintergrund deiner Animationen schwarz gemacht hast.
Tab auf.
Dann wären auf allen OLEDs die Pixel ausgeblieben.
In unserer Küche haben wir, so wie viele andere auch,
einen elektrischen Warmwasserboiler,
der einen kleinen 5-Liter-Tank permanent auf 60 Grad halten möchte.
Da wir aber hauptsächlich die Spülmaschine nutzen
und Warmwasser nur so ein bis drei Mal die Woche benötigen,
sah ich dort Optimierungspotenzial.
Also nahm ich eine möglichst billige WLAN-Steckdose
mit Strommessfunktion, in meinem Fall eine TP-Link TAPO P110.
Da würde ich sagen, hätte er sich auf jeden Fall was vorgestellt.
Da hätte er sich was holen sollen,
was man mit Custom-Firmware flashen kann und das Motor ausstatten.
Jep. Aber das kann man so machen, ja, klar.
... mich an meinen Computer.
Mittels eines selbstgeschriebenen Python-Programms
und der Library PyP100 versuchte ich also,
alle Werte auszulesen, die mir die Steckdose so liefert.
Am interessantesten waren dabei der Wert des Schaltzustandes,
also Steckdose an oder aus.
Oder man hat eine Smart Home-Lösung,
die diese Plattform schon unterstützt,
und das muss man gar nichts für programmieren.
Da der Wasserboiler scheinbar nur ein dummes Bimetall verbaut hat,
das je nach Temperatur die Heizung des Boilers an- oder ausschaltet,
ist der Stromverbrauch entweder bei 0 Watt oder bei ca. 2 Kilowatt.
Das ist ein gut zu erkennender Unterschied.
Das sollte relativ klar zum Bescheiden sein, ja.
So, der Hauptteil ist diese Endlosschleife,
in der haben alle ...
Alter, der ist ja professioneller als die professionellen Entwickler,
die ich kenne hier, mit Flowchart und allem dabei.
... die Steckdose ausgelesen wird,
die entsprechenden Werte, hab ich ja grad gesagt,
der Warmwasserboiler, ob der an ist oder nicht, wird ausgelesen,
wenn er nicht an ist, dann passiert halt einfach nichts in dem Programm
und es geht weiter.
Wenn er an ist, dann wird als nächstes geprüft,
ist der Stromverbrauch von den ausgelesenen Werten über 5 Watt?
Wenn das so ist, dann ist die Heizung des Warmwasserboilers an,
und das merken wir uns auch.
Der nächste Durchlauf.
Wenn der Stromverbrauch nun unter 5 Watt ist,
also die Heizung ausgeschaltet wurde,
prüfen wir, ob die Heizung bereits lief.
Das wissen wir ja jetzt über den Zustand gerade lief.
Wenn das der Fall ist, ja, die Heizung läuft nicht mehr,
merken wir uns auch wieder.
Leute, ich muss mal kurz was zu essen beauftragen.
So, weiter geht's.
Und wir wissen, aha, wir haben eine falsche Flanke erkannt,
die Heizung ist fertig, das Wasser ist also auf Temperatur,
dann triggern wir die ...
Ja, okay, das haben wir verstanden, das ...
... also, ist der ...
Das muss für dich bereit.
Hier sieht man, wie es am Ende ...
... bei IFTTT, genau, so weit, so simpel.
IFTTT.
Und dann sieht das Ganze wie folgt aus.
Starte das Warmwasser.
Okay, das Warmwasser ist in circa acht Minuten für dich bereit.
Dein Wasser antropft.
Das wäre noch eine Sparmöglichkeit.
Dein Warmwasser ist fertig.
Das Ganze hat den Nachteil,
dass man natürlich nicht jederzeit warmes Wasser in der Küche hat.
Das ist aber hauptsächlich für Freunde merkwürdig,
wenn die mal in unserer Küche rumhantieren.
Meine Freundin und ich haben uns bereits daran gewöhnt.
In der Regel wissen wir ja im Vorfeld,
ob wir Warmwasser benötigen oder nicht.
Also, ich fände es nervig, wenn ich Warmwasser aufdrehe,
und es kommt erst mal kein Warmwasser raus.
Aber gut, wenn man das im Vorfeld steuern kann, why not?
... wir uns, dass wir so circa 60 Euro im Jahr sparen,
was wir als Studenten doch wirklich besser einsetzen können.
Das ist auf jeden Fall ein interessanter Ansatz.
Ich bin mir nicht so ganz sicher.
Aber die WLAN-Steckdose hat davon ja schon mal wahrscheinlich 20, 30 Euro gekostet,
und dann musste das andere erst mal einsparen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es so sinnig ist, aber gut, wenn es Ihnen gefällt.
Ich weiß nicht mehr, mit wem ich drüber gesprochen habe.
Ich glaube, mit unserem Küchenplaner im Zuge des neuen Hauses.
Aber da ging es um diese Heißwasser-Wasserhähne,
wo 100 Grad heißes Wasser oder knapp 100 Grad heißes Wasser aus der Leitung kommt.
Und er mir sagte, dass es so wenig Strom verbraucht,
um das Wasser heiß zu halten, dass es günstiger ist,
die zum Beispiel über ein Wochenende entweder laufen zu lassen,
als die auszuschalten und dann nach dem Wochenende das Wasser wieder hochzuheizen.
Und ich weiß, wir sprechen da von anderen Wassertemperaturen
und vielleicht auch einfach von einer anderen Dämmung
und wahrscheinlich auch von der Dämmung,
aber auch von einer anderen Wasserbehältergröße.
Und ich will ja auch gar nicht komplett in die Parade fahren,
weil ich die Idee grundsätzlich gut finde.
Aber ich würde vielleicht mal darüber nachdenken, ob du, na gut,
wenn du zwei-, dreimal die Woche warmes Wasser brauchst,
ich weiß nicht, wie du damit hinkommst,
aber dann ist es wahrscheinlich auch einfach egal.
Aber ich werde es wahrscheinlich dann einfach für den Tag,
wo ich es hochgeheizt habe,
wenigstens bis zur üblichen Betissen-Warmwasser-Abgreifzeit
laufen lassen oder so.
Aber ansonsten ist es top.
Und das ist meine Buchhaltungssoftware Cevdesk.
So, als Nächstes hat Mirko eine smarte Dunstabzugshaube geschickt
und wir schauen mal rein.
Die Dunstabzugshaube, die ich hier habe, die ist eine ganz normale.
Die hat hier oben so ein paar Bedienelemente
und sie hat zusätzlich eine solche...
Ist das nicht unten?
Also, ja, sie ist oben, aber unten.
...Wärmebedienung.
Die funkt auf 433 Megahertz.
Ja, Standard.
Und dann habe ich mal ein bisschen recherchiert dazu
und habe mir...
...hier oben ein Kästchen gekauft von der Firma Broadlink.
Ja, die haben vieles in der Richtung.
Die haben auch solche Kisten mit eingebautem Infrarot und so was.
...die Videobeschreibung noch packen.
Ich packe die Produkte, soweit ich sie finde,
auch noch mal in die Videobeschreibung
meiner Videobeschreibung, meines Videos.
Ihr wisst schon.
Und dieses Gerät, damit kann man über ein Homebridge-Plugin
die Funkbefehle, die diese Dunstabzugshaube
von der Fernbedienung empfängt,
kann man abfangen und kann dann diese entsprechend
in diesem Homebridge-Plugin...
Ja, das ist, dass es lernt, was für Sachen darüber geschickt werden.
...dass sie ausgelöst werden über Schalter.
So, hier seht ihr jetzt die Homebridge-Konfiguration
von dem Broadlink-RM...
Auf Homebridge hätte ich halt wenig Bock, aber okay.
...Plugin.
Und hier seht ihr...
Ich will am Ende sehen, wie es funktioniert.
...hier steht und die Hände voll zu tun hat mit Töpfen und Bratpfannen,
dann kann man sagen, hey Siri, schalte...
...Lichtabzugshaube an.
Ich hoffe, ihr schaut das gerade nicht in der Küche.
Ansonsten, Kopfhörer sind bei diesen Videos immer ganz hilfreich.
Hätte ich vorher sagen können.
Okay, ja, nice, aber...
Also, normalerweise haben die Dinger doch einfach einen Knopf dran.
Da drückst du drauf und dann geht das Licht an.
Oder du drückst drauf und die Dunstabzugshaube geht an.
Das ist halt eine Sache von einer Sekunde so oder von zwei Sekunden.
Ja, okay, kann man machen.
Hey, Siri, schalte die Lichtabzugshaube aus.
Ist eher ein bisschen Spielerei.
Und natürlich geht es dann auch für die entsprechenden Abzugsstufen,
aber das zeige ich euch jetzt aus.
So, Tom macht seinen Hasenkäfig smart und warm.
Ich stelle euch heute mal eine kleine Automation vor,
die dafür sorgt, dass unsere Hasen im Winter nicht auf Eiswürfel rumkauen müssen.
Und zwar war es jetzt in den vergangenen Tagen...
Smarter Hasenstau.
... öfter mal in den Minusgraden.
Und da die Hasen eigentlich immer Frischfutter bekommen,
ist es dann eingefroren oder ziemlich hart geworden.
Und die Hasen haben es dann nicht mehr gegessen.
Die kleinen Fell-Diven.
Ja, ich würde auch kein gefrorenes Essen fordern.
Um dieses Problem dann zu lösen,
haben wir eine einfache Infrarot-Wärmelampe gekauft,
welche dann irgendwie immer am Dauerstrom war
und dann immer mit 250 Watt da langgebraten hat.
Slowcooking nennt man das, glaube ich.
Sous-Vide.
Ne, Sous-Vide.
Was dann aber nicht so wirklich energieeffizient und smart war.
Und da das Smart Home ja hier schon eh sehr gut funktioniert
und ein I.O.-Broker und das Motor erkenntnisse alle da waren,
habe ich dann einen Zwischenstecker zwischen die Lampe und...
Da würde ich mir vielleicht ein bisschen Gedanken machen,
je nachdem, wo das hängt, ob das nicht Probleme gibt,
falls es nass wird draußen.
Gerade so die ganz billigen Stecker haben da ein bisschen...
Die sind absolut nicht für Feuchtigkeit gemacht.
Selbst ein bisschen Spritz-Regenwasser mögen die nicht.
Den Dauerstrom geklemmt, welcher über den I.O.-Broker den Befehl bekommt,
dass, wenn die Temperatur unter...
Blockly!
Sieht ja fast aus wie Battlefield 2042.
Portal.
Daku, danke schön für den Sub.
...0 Grad ist.
Und danke an die ganzen Follower und Subscriber heute, Leute.
Ich habe euch wieder Hälfte nicht gesehen davon.
Wie ich geguckt habe.
Daku, danke schön.
Breserife ist auch wieder am Start.
Die habe ich auch gar nicht gesehen.
Ateno, NierDuo am Start.
Binne, Gartenkalle.
Ich habe euch wieder alle übersehen.
Danke für die ganzen Subs, Leute.
Und für alle, die neu hier sind und euch das Ganze gefällt,
normalerweise gibt es kein Reaction-Content,
nur immer sonntags morgens.
Ihr könnt mir natürlich auch ein Follow dalassen.
Würde mich freuen, wenn ich euch öfters hier sehe in Zukunft.
Dass er diese dann bitte einschalten möchte.
Die Daten kommen dann von einer...
...Wetterstation.
Ich auch, Splixer.
Ich finde es auch viel einfacher, ordentlich irgendwie Source-Code zu lesen,
anstatt diese komischen Blog-Dinger.
Leute, mein Essen ist gerade gekommen.
...bei uns auf der Garage am Mast hängt.
Und somit hat man quasi immer die aktuellen und eigenen Werte.
In Zukunft soll dann noch...
Moment mal.
Was macht die denn da oben?
Fangt ihr irgendwie ein lustiges Spiel?
Boah, Alter, was haben die denn auf dem Dach stehen?
What the...
Boah, was geht denn mit denen ab?
...Naschenachrichten ab, kommuniziert ihr mit den Voyager-Sonden
oder habt ihr euch einen eigenen Handymasten gebaut?
Das ist jetzt so, um rauszufinden, was der Kaninchenstall für eine Innentemperatur hat.
Vielleicht ein bisschen over the top im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes.
Ein eigener Temperatursensor in den Käfig reinkommen, um zu sehen,
wie effizient diese Lampe ist und wie lange diese Lampe an sein muss.
Also erst mal vielen Dank, Tom.
Damit haben wir nämlich auch die Tiere.
Die sind im Videotitel abgehakt.
Aber ich glaube, wir müssen noch mal eben in euren Stall gucken.
Okay, da ist ein Fenster drin und da unten ist eine kleine Luke davor.
Aber ich glaube, ja, also ein Sensor im Stall dürfte tatsächlich noch sinnvoll sein,
weil 250 Watt wahrscheinlich bei null Grad und auch ein bisschen darüber
oder wenn das irgendwie einen Tag immer so auf der Kippe steht,
wahrscheinlich einfach die Hasen ein bisschen zu früh grillt.
Ich glaube, das ist eine ganz gute Erweiterung.
Und wenn du dann weiter eskalieren willst,
dann könntest du natürlich die Tür automatisch schließen.
Und da müsstest du sie wahrscheinlich hin und wieder mal kurz aufmachen,
damit bei der Kälte ausgesperrte Hasen wieder rein können.
Oder du brauchst eine Kamera mit AI und Hasenerkennung.
Aber ich glaube, damit könntest du auch noch mal die Heizkosten
für deinen Hasenbräter reduzieren.
So, dann haben wir...
Da merken wir uns, wo wir stehengeblieben sind, Leute.
Bei 14 Minuten.
Ich werde jetzt was essen.
Ich habe übelst Hunger.
Ich bin auch schon viel länger on als sonst.
Ich meine, fast viereinhalb Stunden, das ist auch außergewöhnlich.
Ich lache für meine Verhältnisse Sonntagmorgen.
Wir sehen uns.
Ich gehe jetzt was futtern.
Macht's gut.
Vielleicht bis heute Mittag.
Da gucken wir uns vielleicht noch die restliche KDE-Sache an.
Bis dann, macht's gut.
See you.